[Music]
the stakes have never been higher and
I've never been so high as we are right
now here in Toronto you can see the
beautiful CN Tower behind me as the Sun
Peaks through the clouds on another
amazing day here at the 2023 Champions
chess tour final we have day two of the
semi-finals coming up it's Chile
downstairs Chile chess with Levy and KY
on our YouTube channel and it's Chile up
here so if you don't mind let's get
downstairs and let's get to it because
day two of the semi-finals starts right
now
[Applause]
you've heard the sayings The Road Less
Traveled rubber meets the road I'm on
the road to nowhere that need to get up
and go to just shut up and drive to
Parts Unknown it's in our DNA but this
road has an end and the
beginning well let's throw that in
Reverse it's over we have a winner
Magnus Carlson what has this kid got in
store he
might one move Checkmate there's been
curves Hills corners and even a
breakdown or two the game is over that's
the w we see a reaction Magnus mous
Magnus Mouse slipped oh my gosh look at
Jan's face some have pulled over but
some what is he doing slammed that foot
to the floor and just kept going any
second Nakamura is the winner not of
Maxim vaj the French man he wins the AI
cup after six stops along the way it's
time for the greatest proven ground and
online chess to drop that final pin in
the
GPS destination Toronto Canada eight
players from all four corners of the
globe descend on the Queen City with one
goal to prove who the one true king of
online chess really is I think this is
the strongest final there ever been I
know that it will not be easy it's nice
to play in top tournament Magnus will
want revenge it's my last tournament of
the year I'm a bit desperate to end it
well having the opportunity to play
against the best players in the world
it's always a challenge and I enjoy it
it's going to be a very close fight it's
going to be very exciting live from
Toronto Canada this is the 2023
Champions chess tour finals and it
starts
now
[Music]
indeed it does start right now shout out
to Wood Harris shout out to our awesome
hype video it's the CCT finals you know
the drill we're getting set for day two
of the semifinals here in Toronto so
much action about to go down on the
board we are downstairs now no longer on
the roof here with KY and Levy inside
the playing Hall where all the action
has been taking place all week and guys
Boy A lot happened yesterday yep I'm
going to skip past the first question
which is was it hard to steal Ray yota's
suit from Good Fellas oh listen I
appreciate it but but it looks good it
looks better on you I appreciate it
shout out Joe bananas Jo but you're
looking good are you feeling good and
what was your give me your biggest
takeaway from day one of the semis
biggest takeaway was we got everything
we could have asked for in the match
between Fabiano and Magnus and damn n
Beck Is For Real yeah that was that was
the takeaway we'll see if he can get to
the finals yeah your your thoughts oh
ABD satov honestly I mean really for me
Abdu satov is swinging it's more like
you know that guy that you know you're
running you're running the race right
and you know the guy's behind you but he
like really behind you like is he really
catch is he actually faster than me now
maybe he's you know what I mean what's
going on that guy and I love what you
said that we got everything we wanted
because we didn't know how we were going
to get another epic Fabiano versus
Magnus match we kind of assume that it
is usually going to be epic between
those guys but you know Magnus was a
moment away from losing right one game
away and he comes storming back in
Armageddon and then of course as you
already said Notre Beck uh showing that
he is here to stay at the top well we
just gave you our takeaways if somehow
you missed it we're going to give you
the Highlight Reel show you what went
down right now I think that Magnus is
about to get checkmated and Magnus he
slows down but he's got six six seconds
to decide now The Rook can go on on to
the Sea file and win the queen he gives
up his Queen Magnus Carson surely Fabian
is going to take it wow he just
blundered the pawn with check he should
have pushed the other one the G Pawn
wrong choice there and Magnus is alive
look at those white pawns paralyzing The
Black Queen five doesn't know where to
go but now it's winning for Magnus he
brings his Rook all the way down Rook it
he chooses the wrong Square he trapped
his own Queen and it's handshake Magnus
gson does the unbelievable he wins down
a
queen look at that big move that is big
chest by nbec Abdu satov a rook
sacrifice impressive stuff there Abdu
satov game over if he sacrifices his
Queen right now Abdu satov he does it
it's on the board Abdu satov finds the
finishing touch this is simply game over
weso resigns Abdu satra of the comeback
kids strikes again Magnus drops his
night back a big blunder according to
the evaluation bar can black just
continued the journey with his night
Fabiano kanana are really bringing his
aame today Magnus car is about to go
down in game three wellow we see
resignation that one is over Fabiano in
control from start to finish sure
determination from nyb it's just grit
his hard work is paying off one move
away from winning that pawn is about to
get to H2 there's two of them black has
two of the porn Stone and Wesley resigns
n back Abdu satov also gets the back to
back Victory and takes the lead in his
patch the only way to keep Black's
Knight alive is to repeat draw and
handshake Abdu satov takes it it's
handshakes Abdu satov wins set one of
the semi-finals again the Wesley
Soul Knight Will trap this white king
Magnus has spotted it all all Magnus
Carlson needs is a draw and he's about
to force the draw this is unbelievable
recognition Fabiano just frustrated he
got so close he tried what he had to but
in the end handshake Magnus
wins wowers wower it was amazing the
usbeck dragon spit in hot fire as he
takes down Wesley so and uh he didn't
even need Armageddon like Magnus did
Magnus of course as you saw there come
storming back to win an Armageddon and
that's where we sit if that's where we
stay we would have a Magnus Carlson
versus Notre Becka turov final who knows
if that's what we're in store for but uh
again real quick thoughts on uh on the
the big the big the big the big Play We
just saw there well yeah I mean I think
it's important to point out Fabiano was
was dominant in the first three games he
almost won three nothing right but we're
talking about NOC that's really the star
he came out guns blazing against last
year's uh Global chess champion right
and that was uh Wesley so he took him
down after losing the first game he
stormed back twice he won in convincing
fashion had absolutely no problems
putting the match away did not need an
Armageddon yesterday 19 years of age the
only other player currently sitting here
that has a World Chess Championship and
that is in rapid chess and uh doesn't
get much better than winning at around
95 1.2% accuracy versus the second most
accurate chess player in the tour which
is Wesley so only behind Magnus yeah
weirdly enough it actually seems like
you know people forget all the time and
even even I like you say it every day
but then you forget that he's a world
rapid Champion bro like he if you said
if Magnus was World rapid Champion oh
you expect that let's see oh you expect
you know five time right but Norbeck is
like oh man I'm the I'm a world rapid
Champion I'm right behind you guys I'm
to bring the heat and show you I am a
world champion just like you Max you
always know that at some point the next
generation is going to start breaking in
to this group and start winning these
events right we all kind of want it
right you have Magnus and Fabby and
Hikaru and Wesley they've been
dominating for years but then when it
starts to happen it makes you a little
uncomfortable you go wait a second are
we ready for this I mean like let's just
no was born in 2004
yeah I think I was think I was
graduating high school in in 2004 all
right let's let's show everybody the uh
the fun fact here which is that Notre
Beck is the youngest World rapid
Champion he won it as the second
youngest behind hoyon second youngest
World rapid champion in history right
there and uh you know again he's he's uh
he's a boss right there we see the
ranking of of world champions in any
format and Hoy fun man I didn't realize
she was so young when she won by the way
sorry I'm just like staring at that stat
yeah and and and I mean she won it it
she won the World Championship overall
shout out shout out to Hoy fwn great
friend at chess.com she's done
commentary with us before so I apologize
I fumbled a little bit looking at that
cuz I was like she was 16 yes Nock is
the second second youngest player in
history to win a world championship she
won the overall Women's World
Championship but he won the world rap at
17 years of age and I think I think he
won it in like a tie break versus y
pishi who's like that's no slash man
that's a top five rapid and Blitz player
and classical player in the world
two-time Challenger for the World Chess
Championship not at the time but now we
know so I mean noback he's got the
nerves and and he's got the skills to
back it up 100% we're going to move
through talking about his opponent now
yeah Wesley so the guy who dominated
we've been calling him flexy Sano all
the things you talk about but KY despite
what was the dominant story line through
the round robin portion it could all be
slipping away from Wesley if he doesn't
hold on tight right now yeah in fact it
was the nerves it was something we
haven't seen from Wesley all you know
six seven matches he played here until
he played norback in fact when he play
nck there you know it got a little shaky
you could tell even nbe said himself he
can just smell the blood in the water as
he like stares at his opponent which is
very uncomfortable imagine I'm just up
Danny you're move bro yo you're move you
know what I mean don't get your makeup
on my
shirt I did that last time too fact but
stare you know staring at you that close
right is it's uncomfortable right I I I
hate that like you know you just playing
somebody and it's just like this and
then they're just oh yeah yeah how you
how' you like that
moveo yeah that doesn't feel too good he
just stares at you you know and you
can't stare back cuz it's your move it
is a little different playing OTB when
that stuff's going down right I mean you
feel like if so was shaky which is what
not Notre Beck said he felt like so was
a little shaky maybe something has to do
with the psychology you think a little
bit there 100% probably a little bit I
mean he doesn't stare at people because
he thinks they're handsome I mean I
maybe he does I don't maybe he's like
damn Wesley's got he's got some nice
stuff going on the face he he's looking
at him because he's like I'm going to
bury you into the ground with my moves
not these fists not yet and that's how
he took the lead on day one like I said
yesterday this is Wesley's worst
situation in Toronto two years in a row
he's just he won last year and he
destroyed the round robin pH and today
he's looking at potential elimination
third and fourth place so who said chess
was not a contact sport right full of
emotion and intimidation seriously and
it is something that you can feel when
you're here and you can see it as the
players look at each other but all right
we also had a lot of fun with Wesley
maybe he's feeling intense right now but
he was feeling pretty relaxed after the
round robin stage and he and I got up to
some topics a little bit off the board
all right first game we're going to play
is rapid fire all right basketball uh
Kobe Kobe all right baseball uh
shoot well the ones who play at the St
Louis card now they have some players I
think was Mike mintini a player I like
him I meet him what about what about
soccer lonel Messi because he's very
consistent okay also since back in
college days he was already number one
and he's still okay he's still until
recently number one football my homies I
watch him I watch also his commercials
okay tennis yovic yovic all right I love
it golf I guess everyone says Tiger
Woods but there's this uh very pretty
girl Paige SP up all right I like it all
right what about uh
poker I only know Jennifer
Shah yeah I only know her and so you
hear that J you're the goat you're poker
all right chess chess uh Danny wrench
okay come on you're the best I
appreciate it I'm going to say Wesley so
then you said favorite right the
favorite or who's the goat who's the
goat goat yeah hard to I'd say fisher
for now but I I I suppose the right
answer is Caron but I'll say fisher
because he's American okay just
boxing I'll pick my boy KY oh I love it
yeah he he hasn't done it yet but he I
think he might be one of the greatest
ever when he's done probably yeah he's
uh pretty pretty good your favorite
movie well Lord of the Rings first comes
to mind okay classic I can watch it uh
over and over again but there I know I
like the the very the newest bat the
Batman Okay 3 hours now the latest one
so I like it yeah it's I think it's the
best Batman movie ever okay favorite
book I like his history like World War
III books World War I I have tons of
those also books about Napoleon like I'm
a big fan of Napoleon although the the
the new movie was horrific was it not
good haven't seen it yet yeah man I
don't know reallyy Scott personally like
the actors were good they did their best
like haen penix I think did a good job
but the story was not accurate at all
okay yeah you would you would know yeah
so I like I pretty much read everything
about Napoleon favorite TV show is the
crown a TV show The Crown yeah yeah I
love it yeah we're gonna go watch it
right after this tournament the the the
latest season I love that's great that's
great favorite author I'd say sam
Shanklin if he writes more books okay
well that's the first thing that comes
to mind like I I really want to read
leby roseman's book so I'll get there
one day well on L I'll ask you who's
your favorite chess Creator uh well
hikaro I I I love uh his uh twitch
streams although since his ttch websites
I've been following him less but when he
was in twitch like I enjoyed watching
his uh title Tuesday stream especially
like yeah favorite chess game of all
time okay my my game against Sergey
kaken in
2017 Norway was an amazing game my win
against dingler in 2015 in bilbow in the
Kings Indian was also pretty epic like
that was the last time he literally
played the Kings Indian with black uh
but I think you broke him you broke him
in his King's Indian relationship I
broke his King's Indian yeah for sure
like he never played the Kings Indian
again after that so you guys should
really check out that game that was my
most beautiful game one of my favorite
games of all time Wesley so over Gary
Kasparov it was a Blitz game but I
covered it recently in like everything
you need to know about Chess series
thank you that was a oh you did yeah
thank you that was a game right there
all right yeah I wish I play like that
again well what about Wesley so Magnus
Carlson 2023 Champions chess tour not
bad today ight G5 yeah it was pretty
good I made him jump you did that was
good that was good I hope I can play it
again Blitz or classical classical
online or OTV over the board E4 or D4 E4
Fisher or Kasparov ah yeah that's hard
question but I go with Fisher at the
moment closed or open positions
open open positions Searching for Bobby
Fisher the movie or the Queen's Gambit
on
Netflix yeah it's a tough question but
go with the queen Gambit
okay Wesley is hilarious by the way we
had to edit that down because we talked
for a while he gave a lot of answers we
need that we need these guys we need
these guys to open up to tell us about
their interest cuz we need all the fans
watching at home to care about them not
just their chess moves like Wesley's a
great interview so thank you Wesley
thank you Wesley thank you Wesley that
was awesome it was great there's more
coming your way if you follow our
YouTube channels you can get into it but
we have got to get into the next match
boys we've got got Carlson 32 over
Carana because of the Armageddon
tiebreaker he uh he's getting set today
for uh probably a very very motivated
Fabiano so let's move over to that one
if you're Magnus West uh uh I almost
called you Wesley cuz I'm thinking about
Wesley if you're Magnus Levy you
acknowledged that you didn't necessarily
have your best chest yesterday you also
acknowledged at this point you kind of
have an issue with starting slow yeah so
how do you fix it if you're magnus's
coach for a second I mean if I I knew I
would probably be up there playing as
opposed to commentating uh the first
three games did not go his way the last
two did very much A Tale of Two matches
within one match itself uh we will see I
think Magnus is capable of adapting to
whatever happens in the first game or
two of today's match so remember the the
the second set is at Best of four if
Fabiano clutches it out and wins that
set then they play a slightly shorter
set which breaks that tie so we might
have a bunch of Chess today um as we
talk about the highest I mean El of all
time right it's really hard to against
well you mentioned Fabby clutching it
out Levy and um let's remind everybody
that these two guys we're watching are
two of the three obviously with Kasparov
highest rated players in history so
sometimes I think we take it for granted
but they may they may go down as always
being two of the top three together
right I mean these guys have had
incredible careers their rivalry is
insane and KY your thoughts I'm just
going to ask do you think Fabby clutches
it out yeah you know if Fabby does what
he did yesterday and just stay in the in
the groove here you know hey Magnus he
knows what he needs to do of course
Magnus is like hey if I'm playing at my
best if I'm feeling good I'm going to
play good I'm one of the best to ever do
it right but if fa can do what he did
yesterday and just repeat and stay
consistent and stay in his own lane
there he might have a chance actually
really uh as he did yesterday you know I
thought Faby was going to crumble when
he blew that first game but he didn't
yeah he almost won the match I think
he's the guy we always say is the most
stoic the most present you think that
that's something that's really going to
pay off for him today well look my picks
were were were Carlson and and so right
CU I just thought they were the
favorites in their matchups um but I
can't change that pick because now that
I know the results of the first day of
the semi-final but I will say it almost
felt like Fabiano lost a couple of Min
matches within that match yeah right
because he was up 2-1 that fourth rapid
game with white Magnus would just showed
up just vintage imbalance creating a
complicated position that he won and the
Armageddon was very tense but it came
down to a couple of critical decisions
so you lose a couple now you gotta wipe
the Slate clean and you have to show up
today we'll see if Fabiano can put on a
good fight right uh and I mean I'm just
hoping for as much chess as possible so
well we're all hoping for as much chess
as possible we want long days here in
Toronto because uh that means we're
having a lot of fun and all right more
ad breaks or ad or more ad breaks we
want more ad breaks we want more
subscribers we do appreciate everyone
and uh we want more time with Ka we're
going to throw over to her right now let
her take it away and talk about catching
up with Magnus
Carlson hey Danny I'm standing here in
the hotel lobby bar where the venue for
for the CCT finals is and I have to say
you guys are looking surprisingly fresh
and feisty this morning because I hear
you guys were spotted at a bar here in
Toronto last night having some drinks
playing some bug house with the chess
bras and I also hear Magnus Carlson was
there to hang out with you guys and to
have some fun and speaking of fun that
was one of the top goals for Magnus
Carlson this year I met up with him in
January and I asked him what are your
goals for the 2023 CC
season if you could list your three
goals that you hope to achieve in 2023
Magnus Carlson is looking ahead to yet
another year with exciting chess but
first let's go back to 2022 I would say
on the board it was mostly Pretty good
overall um I think it was one of my
better years he definitely seemed
focused at the board as the 32-year-old
finished the Year by winning back the
rapid and Blitz World Champion I ship
titles was relief uh a part of what you
felt there uh heading into a year where
you will give away your your classical
title the timing is perfect like if
there was one time that I really uh that
I really want of those titles it would
been out yeah it just gave me gave me
joy and like still when I I think about
it makes me smile uh it was a really
great moment and joy is exactly what the
world's best chess player wants more of
in 23 just want to you know to play and
have fun and I feel like that's true
more than in a long time especially now
that I have these rapid and Blitz W
titles though I can just relax and have
fun I think I look at it at least
sometimes a little more philosophically
than before that you know if I have a
bad event I have a bad event and I'll
hit back in the next
[Music]
one number one is win a game with one 1
V3 okay and second is to have fun and uh
third one is to win a game from minus 10
position that's for the
tour and here they are Magnus Carlson
top three goals for the 20123 CCT season
and yesterday he was able to check one
of those goals off because he was able
to come back from a minus 10 position
against Fabiano Karana in the first game
so let's see today Danny if he's able to
also tick off those two other boxes back
to you
guys I love it I'd say the second one is
also checked off cuz we did have fun
last night I think Magnus is having fun
and we actually were joking about that
video that when is he going to have a
chance to win a game minus 10 we
literally talked about that when the
tournament started wasn't evenus 10
there was an
M say it was like a BMW model of a car
it was like M10 or something I mean it
was crazy it was check obviously finding
a Checkmate in 11 we all know stockfish
says that evaluation that just means you
win the queen then you win the game but
uh it's crazy I can't and but credit to
Fabby for winning the next two games you
said it like seriously I would have I
would have been pissed so abely will he
play 1 B3 that's the question if he
really wants to round out that list I
don't know if he is but we're going to
we're going to round out our show open
here by reminding everybody of what the
format is we've been doing it all week
you're having a blast let's remind you
of what's ahead as we get closer to
crowning the 2023 Champions chess tour
Champion the semifinals are set our top
two finishers from the survival bracket
Fabiano kowana and Notre Becka dorov
have advanced our survivors now join
Wesley so and Magnus Carlson in a single
elimination bracket as the number one
seed Wesley has chosen his first
opponent Notre Beck and we move one step
closer to determining who will be
crowned our champion of
[Music]
champions the match is rolling on the
updated most recent odds as of today
Magnus now in
87% wow favorite that's I mean it makes
sense right he won the first match he
was at 71 and kind of kind of cut that
in half and now it's 133% uh only for
Fabian caran in regards to his chances
who knows what those odds makers are
really up to behind the scenes fiddling
with math I don't I don't necessarily
believe in math but no I'm kidding I
think those odds science I'm not going
we're not I'm not so into science or M
no I'm kidding but it it I think the
odds check out we'll see what happens
obviously today something interesting
about that Magnus was the pre-tournament
favorite obviously at 50% I believe
yesterday he was still in the 50s maybe
he broke 60 and now he's at 73 according
to the math which we saw that means that
they're taking the odds that he will
play noer back in a final right that's
so that's a little if I'm n back I'm I'm
beating Wesley I'm going right back to
I'm pissed about that I'm fighting the
status that CH like you think this Notre
back guy looks for bulletin board
material oh 100% I think actually I
think Wesley is the one right now on the
back maybe watching the broadcast and
he's like oh yeah you think I'm all
wholesome and soft and like cute and
cuddly okay yeah wait wait till we get
out here today Right Wesley is out there
being wholesome and soft and cuddly we
hear him laughing you can hear his laugh
anywhere because because it is uh it's
amazing and it's genuine and all right H
speaking of amazing that's our crew in
Oslo they're pretty good at what they do
David Robert and T I don't really have
any better cue to throw to you I'll just
ask how you doing this afternoon we're
doing great Danny love the buildup also
big shout out to Levy suit great color
there loved it and we're really excited
about of course the chest that's coming
up we will keep checking in with all the
action with the gang in Toronto but we
have uh set two of the semi-finals that
are about to begin what are we expecting
from the players today Robert well for
some players it might be their last
match for Wesley so and Fa a caran in
particular they have to bounce back
right now they have one set to win and
if they do take the second set of the
match we go to set three and they'll
have to do it all over again it's Magnus
versus Fabby and Wesley against nbec ABD
satov the Magnus Fabby match five
decisive games a thrilling thrilling
match Magnus looks like he's just rolled
out of the bed shows up to the game is
down a queen wins the first game is down
two games wins the set how do you beat
someone like that how do you get over
the psychological battle I think nobody
knows that's the answer how do you beat
Magnus Carlson because you're always uh
fighting the unexpected no matter how
strong he plays no matter how he starts
the game no matter whether he plays Mimi
openings he's always eventually going to
bring his best when the critical moments
do happen when the clock ticks down so
Fabby is up against it but if he can
start like he did yesterday he's
definitely got a chance and these two
will be playing the other semi-final
match and it's always good to see Wesley
in a happy mood he's been having quite
the field day on Twitter enjoying
himself looks extremely relaxed but it's
time to get his game mode on he's
playing catchup to not set one win let's
listen
in switching chair I get it I get it I
have my technique now like I slide
it it's good for not usually play
musical chairs as a kid he's probably
got a little bit more recent experience
does Wesley get to pick magnus's chair
as
well wow maybe the players are
superstitious choosing their lucky
chairs
here
okay I feel dizzy just watching those
chairs Go Round And round and wait Fabby
now he's moving as
[Music]
well how dizzy are you guys getting I'm
struggling to keep up with these musical
CH here they are think they are ready
just all right to make sure that we the
players in in Toronto are ready with
that chess and it's time to get into the
chess for n beab do satro he took set
one this is set two Wesley has to win to
take it to set three
for nybeck he's the guy who knocked out
Hikaru Nakamura in the survival stage
take set one against Wesley so is Wesley
feeling the pressure because Wesley had
this incredible run in the round robin
but we've seen him get a bit shaky at
the end yeah Wesley earlier in the event
he did have that one match against Maxim
where he won on demand in game two but
he hasn't had his back against the
proverbial wall very much and being in
must-win territory for Wesley so can be
a bit uncomfortable and the games
they're off um we are off Wesley so what
will be his uh opening approach in this
one a set that he has to win on demand
he does the usual takes his glasses off
and it's one B3 Cowboys everywhere are
rejoicing Magnus gson said one of his
2023 aims is to win a game with 1 V3 can
Wesley pull it off for him wow Wesley so
loving uh the moment loving Toronto and
surprising us this I would never ever
have predicted he he has played 1 B3 as
recently as the world cup over the board
in classical in Rapid he has years and
years ago produced a course I believe
for chess base uh on this opening before
he'd ever even played it over the board
but uh this is really rare to see at the
top level white gives up any Ambitions
in the center and starts playing on the
flanks look at this last move he's
feeling care of to Bishop brought white
light squ Bishop out and now White
Knight sits on the edge of the board and
NC replies in kind and this is one of
those openings where I say do not try
this at home because both players just
put their Knights on the rim Wesley just
moved his light score Bishop for a
second time before developing his
kingside Knight or castling it's going
to be this a situation where you're like
what in the world my coach Tommy to
develop all my pieces Castle don't block
uh some Pawn pushes so my other Bishop
can get out this is wacky chess and
maybe it's what Wesley needs do not try
this at home unless you're Wesley so but
that said Wesley is the one who's got
his head in hands already plays a very
unconventional opening approach right
here it's the kind of opening that you
want to play in in this format when your
opponent has little time it's rapid play
you want to get them out of opening
preparation but so far
nbak has played quickly and this is the
first move that he slows down on what is
going on in his mind is he trying to
counter the night jumps that are coming
from White next yeah Nock he's trying to
just gain his bearings in this position
of course he wouldn't have expected one
B3 when the move came when the time came
he would have faced it before throughout
his career though and now he's just
going back into to those memory banks
that mind Palace he's recalling what his
opening Theory said maybe he's trying to
get Wesley out of his preparation either
way this opening M Wesley here is going
to look like a genius or it will
backfire and uh yeah we love to see it
though either way this approach in set
one it was nbec who played the better
chess in critical moments and in this
matchup there were several critical
moments as well between the two highest
rated players in the world fighting for
a spot in the finals Fabby has to win
this set it's starts with the kingspawn
opening and are we going to see another
archangels by Fabby that worked so well
the moment of truth is now wow and
Magnus Carson repeating his strategy
yesterday which somewhat backfired
yesterday one win one draw W uh sorry
one win one loss with the white pieces
for Magnus Carlson but both games he was
suffering it's Fabby though who switches
things up doesn't put the bishop on C5
puts black Bishop just on E7 so no dark
Archangel today uh going back to more
classical Waters Robert and we saw
Magnus look to the side because he
probably was anticipating that Fabby
might go back down his chestal course he
may have spent a lot of time outside of
playing in the pub watching some chess
videos seeing what Fabiano had in store
for him but this is some classical chess
opening lines and Magnus playing a quiet
variation from the white Side Pawn to A3
he's not challenging Black's Advanced
Pawn on the queen side over here so this
might be a longer battle who do you
think that suits more normally I would
say Magnus Carlson uh but then again
Fabiano is still well within his opening
preparation and unfortunately in this
opening the Spanish in general there's
not much new Under the Sun for Fabiano
he would have studied it all before and
you can see by his quick response he's
ready he's prepared he with black was
the first to launch a surprise and uh
Magnus now the first to think and for
set one U Magnus showed up straight out
of bed but it's clear that was quite a
wakeup call for him everything that
happened yesterday he was so close to
losing set one and today looking Sharp
playing a sharp opening as well despite
Fabby losing set one it just feels that
Fabby just needs to do exactly what he
did on day one because he could have
pretty much wrapped up the match in
three games yeah Fabby he just needs to
be maybe a bit luckier a bit sharper
when the clocks are really ticking down
low uh that's the only thing that
stopped him in game one yesterday but he
did everything right um you talked about
Magnus looking sleepy yesterday looking
a bit sharper today is that just because
of the hair quality slick back hair
today for Magnus uh Fabiano meanwhile
always looks sharp uh Bishop out to G5
still a new position uh still a
well-known position sorry Robert well
yesterday we talked about air quality
hair quality and today we really do need
to talk about chair quality because we
saw the Arbiter Judith she was fixing
the players chairs making sure that they
were sitting in the proper seat and
right now we see that Fabiano he thrusts
his Pawn forward to C5 we are seeing
some trades so by pushing the C pawn two
squares the square next to that D5
squares one that is accessible to whites
pieces so Magnus he's playing for these
pluses he has the control of that key
Central Square and for that night on the
rim for Fabiano I do expect it to jump
back there it goes I feel like we're
still in the framework of these two
players preparation and for Fabiano he
is making his responses very quickly
yeah both players well versed here just
a mark of respect to each other as well
both playing pretty much their best
repertoire not messing around with any
kind of surprise openings no one B3 in
this one it's all about playing
classical chess minimal risk uh just
play your best
and right now Magnus again thinking
surprised by this last move which looks
very natural looks very normal I think
Magnus just he'll take a pause here one
minute or so decide upon a plan which
pawns to push uh potentially on the
queen side and then he'll go for it but
uh looking very a balanced in these
early stages we see Loi girl there in
the background some chill music so far a
chill start to this game and Magnus he's
very concentrated because while he may
be up a set he of course has the inside
track to the finals we saw this
predictions beforehand 73% chance to win
at all 87% chance to win this match he's
not taking Fabiano lightly Fabiano did
outplay Magnus a day ago in those first
three games where Fai did score two
points in those three games and it could
have been even more had he not blundered
away a winning advantage in the first
one but Magnus he looks ready for what's
about to come today and for Fabiano he
may be shaken a little bit after
yesterday's result but he's clearly not
broken I think what's about to come on
the board today in this position is is
uh Fabby going ahead with the Queens
side pawns moving forward that a pawn
will March up the board where the square
the Knight has just vacated we can
expect the B Pawn to move forward
meanwhile Magnus eyeing a central break
trying to get D4 in but you always have
to watch out Fab's Bishop on F6 will
open up if there is a break in the
center I'm once again liking this
position for black out of the opening
who would you say has won the opening
battle so far o days despite the fact we
are out of the opening normally signaled
by when both sides have finished
castling and development here pretty
much most of the pieces have been
developed um I'll still say that the
players are aware of the middle game
plans they know roughly what they should
be doing which pawns to push uh which
pieces to put on which squares so I'm
going to try and hold off on answering
that one for now Tanya I think it's the
next five or six moves uh will dictate
who has won the real battle uh I don't
think Fabby has anything to complain
about so I'm inclined to say black as
especially after this last move Black
start Square Bishop would just drop back
to G7 a nice hiding spot the fien ketto
square after all but uh yeah still maybe
too early to tell and we get some Kings
Indian like Tendencies if that Bishop is
able to slide back and the F Pawn goes
forward for black because the side that
controls the pawn breaks it's off in the
side with the advantage you hear me say
this all the time that's a key Pawn
break available to Black and for white
you can strike on the queen side maybe
you push your Pawn to B4 maybe you push
a pawn to A4 you have some choices here
if you're Magnus Carlson I like that
Fabby is playing quick quickly yesterday
that served him very well when he had a
lead on the clock he also was able to
dictate some of the course of action
over the board and for Magnus he's
trying to determine which Pawn to push
how do I deal with this he does play B4
and it remains level but I like the
chances that both sides have here
they're playing on opposite flanks yeah
maybe I'm just too biased because I like
these positions with black I play them
with black and it just feels that uh you
manag to get the space on the queen side
you can think about expanding on the
king side there's A5 breaks there's
potential F5 coming in next you have to
watch watch out with the D5 Knight jumps
though it's going to be uh an
interesting fight it's one of those
positions that starts really slow and
strategic but once you get a break in
once the pawns start disappearing from
the board the position suddenly explodes
yeah and it is likely to explode
eventually just judging by the way they
were both playing yesterday as well
often there would be slower starts a bit
of buildup a maneuvering phase for 10
also moves in the middle of the game and
then suddenly it's just chaos clocks are
down tactics GW left right and center
and right now this does feel like the
Cal before the storm in this game and uh
meanwhile we might be able to switch to
the other game shortly because that one
is much Wilder a very different type of
game happening in the other semi-final
right now and uh here we go Wesley so
against nbec Abdu satov and wow white
Pawn landing on D5 he might have started
with a flank opening one B3 very quiet
porn push but Wesley has now gone to
that Central strategy and pushed
everything forward in the middle of the
board to my eyes just at first glance
superficially it looks like he's
achieved a lot here Wesley so and look
at the clock Wesley is up nearly five
minutes on the clock against one of the
quicker players nordbeck is the one
who's often pressuring his opponent on
time and this last move D5 it's causing
nordback to pause here because the
bishop on B2 he started as the B3 cowboy
and that Bishop on B2 it's on the
longest diagonal if black sticks a
knight in front of that Bishop's Dagon
Knight E5 the White Queen jumps out to
D4 and it's not even threatening a
checkm it's just black pieces are a bit
loose in this position and if you have
to part with your Dark Sword Bishop if
you are not you're not going to be happy
there's such long-term pressure on this
diagonal I certainly prefer Wesley's
chances yeah I'd agree with everything
that you just said Robert and that last
move D5 black really doesn't have those
many squares with the Knight the one
place you don't want to go right now is
the edge of the board because you're
just going to fall off the ledge well I
was talking about Knight A5 because it
just ends up getting trapped there with
the move B4 uh David while Knight the
other knight move that you were were
pointing out I think that's just not a
happy move Knight A7 has no future
meanwhile you can't drop your knight
back to E7 either because black white
just captures the Knight on F6 and that
would just destroy your kingside Pawn
structure which means that your move
Robert might just be the only one and it
feels as if Black's pieces are getting
in the way that Bishop on F4 the Knight
on E5 if the Knight was to jump to the
center of the board just looks a bit
unstable but it's probably the only move
that nck has and he's played it the
Knight has just landed and I love
Robert's move Queen into the center
always lining up on the diagonal uh with
queen and Bishop this battery can be uh
really promising long term and it causes
some immediate difficulties um there's
actually two moves that I'm quite
attracted to here for white uh firstly
parking the queen in the center also
even bringing this Knight to the edge of
the board to develop it with gain of
time with gain of tempo forcing this
bishop to move away but ultimately
Wesley he's achieved everything he can
hope for in this opening uh if he's
feeling ambitious he'll probably play
this queen move I'm looking at Pawn to
D6 as well just clogging up Black's
development that looks a bit tempting
too Wesley so spoiled for choice I think
he's achieved everything he can hope for
especially today where he needs to
strike back against somewhat amusing
because white hasn't completed his own
development but that D6 idea that you're
mentioning it's a good one to just shut
down that Bishop before it even thinks
about getting into play so Wesley he's a
bit spoiled for choice at the moment I I
think if I were him I would try to
maximize my time Advantage because this
position isn't going to get any simpler
in the near future if there's an
imbalance of an Dark Sword Bishop for
white compared to a knight for black
that's a long-term Initiative for Wesley
and I think he can use that to his
advantage and that is uh almost a five
minute advantage on the clock for Wesley
saw and a good position out of the
opening putting pressure on black
species now setan had a very different
narrative when nbec managed to get good
positions out of the opening we saw him
convert technical end games we saw him
play well aggressively sacrifice pieces
and w wrap it up when it was required
but this is the first time that we see
Wesley get an initiative out of the
opening and this reminds me of some of a
term that Magnus Carlson coined anti-
young player chess and one B3 do you
think that's what Wesley's achieved with
this yeah because they prepare so deeply
these days uh thanks to the accessible
engines uh the players they can study
all of their opponents games B3 is not
something you study in depth unless
you're playing against hiar Nakamura who
plays it all the time online and I do
think at the top players they be they
come more ready for it because of all
this online experience they get against
these top players who do choose to go
the B3 Cowboy route but in this position
I think they're both in novel territory
and I have to say that Wesley he he did
the best he could and he has a nice
chance here yeah it feels like both
players freestyling and this
hand-to-hand combat uh it tends to favor
the more experienced player or the
player who's more comfortable in the
type of position uh that is achieved and
yeah he needs to stay clear of those
long uh kind of technical end games
Wesley so today AB justor was just just
too strong yesterday you have to learn
from your mistakes try something new and
that's what he's been doing so I love
the approach with white bit strange to
see Wesley tank for so long right now
almost three minutes of thought in this
position where yes he's got two or three
tempting moves that we mentioned he
brings his Queen into D4 Robert's first
instinct very powerful move gaining time
against Black's Bishop but yeah two
three minutes he could have played this
instantly it was so natural almost
automatic and Abdus abov now needs to
think uh hopefully he's been think
Wesley's time he needs to react very
quickly and in that third game yesterday
Wesley had uh he was holding on for dear
life in an end game but with just a few
seconds on his clock it's where he went
wrong I think Wesley you know he was so
dominant the first six matches in the
round robin stage he maybe was a little
bit complacent lost to Fabiano in a
match that really didn't matter but then
he's fa facing off against a really
hungry nirca buar of somebody who's
determined in every single game he plays
whether it's in the park or on the grand
stage of the Champions chess tour finals
he wants it he's always going to dig
deep so for Wesley now he really has to
dig deep and he's doing a great job I
really like his position control the
dark squares and I think it's the kind
of position that we need to dig deep
into cuz black doesn't have uh so many
options on the board we see with that
last move Wesley hits the bishop on F4
the Knight on E5 is hanging there's no
way to stay connected to that the only
two moves that come to my mind David
would be that you either capture the
Knight on E3 or fall back with that
Knight on E5 to G6 defending the bishop
on F4 I'm not a big fan of retreating
with the Knight because I feel I'm
opening up the diagonal of the bishop
and the queen I'm already eyeing moves
like that white knight jumping to G4 uh
putting pressure on that black knight
take it please take it let me give you a
checkm in one not going to happen but
these kind of things would at least
terrify me so Bishop takes Knight would
be my move of choice here what would be
your approach o I didn't even notice
Knight G4 I must admit Tanya I thought
white would just develop uh but your
knight G4 would scare The Living
Daylights out of me and uh yes maybe
black can cling on by dropping the oh
dropping the bishop back putting the
Knight on the edge of the board but this
is ugly uh really really scary stuff uh
just purely due to the diagonal so I
agree Bishop takes E3 none of that
business you take off and then uh
ideally try to support your knight in
the center next move the problem is
after Queen takes Bishop uh with this
diagonal opening can you support the
Knight do you have to move it anyway
it's a double attack a double hit on
your uh piece here in the center the
question is after Pawn to D6 can Wesley
get greedy and capture a pawn if the
answer is no due to pressure on the E
file then I think this is what Abdus Tor
should be going for I think this would
provide at least some compensation for
the pawn definite compensation it's just
one of those moments where I remind
viewers that we and you have the
evaluation bar off to the side the
players don't so n would know that he
has some compensation he just doesn't
know how much is it Justified and even
if not taking that Knight on E5 like
let's say black does take the Knight on
E3 and the queen takes back and you
played Pawn to D6 if white plays a
simple move like Knight to F3 just
continues the development it's a
long-term Advantage thanks to that dark
Square Bishop for white black doesn't
have a counterpart so for Wesley as
we're seeing these trades I would not
take that 95 but no doesn't even give
him the chance wow dropping back fearing
that pawn sacrifice but this Knight is
not well placed later it will come under
Fire from Harry the hbor over here and
also it does give white the opportunity
at some moment to even sacrifice a pawn
throw a pawn away to block in this
bishop so again for Wesley multiple
tempt moves watch out for the white king
even castling Queen side if Wesley's
feeling super ambitious in this game
because he has so much space here he has
the better Bishop the better pieces and
wow this one is shaping up this warming
up really nicely and just how difficult
that decision to give up the dark Squad
Bishop for nbec you can see it on the
clock he took three minutes between two
moves to decide it was one of the Lesser
evils he is feeling the pressure White's
pawns have given so much space the two
Bishops Super Active especially the one
on B2 and Wesley is Unstoppable today
he's just going all out he doesn't think
about development just yet the hbor
moving forward H5 is a threat on the
board and the one thing I immediately
noticed is that if black was to slide
The Rook to the center of the board
David something that is such a natural
move that Bishop on B2 is quite the
monster and comes to their rescue
because you just take away the Knight on
F6 a key defender of that Rook so Rook
E8 is not an easy move or the one that
you want to make here uh and we will
Deep dive into this but we are getting
uh some insights coming in from Toronto
with
Levy Levy Wesley incredibly ambitious in
today's
opening yeah thank you Tanya uh and also
I noticed that we're matching uh so
that's very cool uh and I mean we're
looking at the game here in Toronto and
we're blown away by what we're seeing it
couldn't have gone any better I have a
question I kind of want to ask the
entire panel over there in Oslo how much
of this is Wesley's preparation and
knowledge of the position position and
also how much of it is nock's utter
shock at getting hit with 1 B3 pretty
non-traditional opening and he might
have just gotten himself into trouble
right it could he just could be reeling
from the very first move of the game
yeah Lev it feels like a bit of both at
least to me it feels like the shock the
surprise and kind of that Steely
determination to still play principled
moves to still try to uh be as kind of
ambitious as possible it's kind of come
back to haunt nck and how would you
recommend to the viewers out there
reacting to a priz like this one uh
follow nock's approach Fight Fire with
Fire or just uh try to survive in the
early stages because clearly what's
happened is backfired never an easy
choice right because when somebody hits
you with a surprise you don't know how
deep their preparation goes and for
Wesley he's shown that he can achieve a
good position so I think for notbe he's
doing the right thing for classical
chess standards using your time but as
we look right now he's 3 minutes 30
seconds remaining Wesley's nearly nine
it doesn't seem like it's a good
territory for
nck so what's the next move the
position's good the time Advantage is
strong but black has three pieces
pointing at White's G4 Square so I
really want to play F4 here and I wish I
could teleport my Pawn on G2 to G5 and
my H Pawn to H6 all in one go but I also
kind of just want to play slow with like
Pawn to F3 and maybe long Castle so
nothing can go to the G4 Square what
kind of stands out to you we've got two
grand Masters on the panel so what uh
what stands out to you what how do you
actually turn this attack into a full
point you can't just pause the game and
say I'm better and get a win that way
well I can do that because I'm sitting
in this chair but in all seriousness
Levy you you make a great point that
white has several options I would first
play Pawn up to H6 just to carve out all
of the dark squares in front of the
black king and then maybe later as you
said instead of pushing up to F4 maybe
you can even sit the pawn F3 taking away
critical jumps from the black pieces but
H6 right now for Wesley David that's
what I'm looking at at least yeah I love
it combine all of those ideas kind of
the direct approach approach lengthening
the diagonal of the white Dart squared
bishop and then take the slow approach
as Levy mentioned just get developed get
kind of fully organized before launching
that attack against the black king the
black King's not going away anytime soon
these long-term advantages are not
fading Wesley he's made that move Pawn
to H6 look at all those dark squares
Levy do you think we'll see a checkmate
at the end of this
game I mean that's it it really is
looking quite bad H6 G6 now we have the
queen and Bishop diagonal there for
Wesley and and we do see a long Castle I
think nbe can't sit and wait he might
have to create counterplay with
something like Pawn on B7 to B5 at some
point he may have to Chuck upon invest
upon for some counterplay but this is
what I will leave you with and send it
back to you guys Wesley won the first
game yesterday so this is a potential
disaster for Nock in game one but it's
not the end of the world right he is
going to come right back just like he
did yesterday potentially so uh he also
will come more prepared against 1 B3
that's the food for thought I will leave
you with and if Wesley wins this game I
still think we could go all the way
absolutely and it's uh not over till
it's over when you're playing against
the world's very best players for nbec
he's in early early pressure he did lose
game one of set one went on to strike
and take the match and it looks like
this is going to be a tough start for
him as well I'm just looking at those
dark squares around the king that Queen
lands on G7 that's Checkmate and can't
you just get rid of that Knight on the
center of the board push that F Pawn two
steps ahead F4 would be my first thought
in the position what's wrong with that
F4 for the score I think you just win a
piece nobec suddenly head in hands I
think he might have miscalculated he's
relying on a trick uh to bring the Black
Knight forward to eye up a fork B3 is
loose if you take this Black Knight now
whoops a royal fork and you lose
material but I think he might have
underestimated that this Pawn can simply
be defended uh it's not actually that
easy to hold this square but even if you
drop back the queen uh just to protect
for one more move this diagonal is still
open if the Black Knight moves this is
always going to be Checkmate uh just to
show and how else to keep the game going
you have to LEAP into the center I guess
with the Black Knight but now again you
just moved the queen it's actually quite
clever yeah it's quite clever from n
debeck and that's thing he is such a
fighter because the queen needs to stay
in line with that Bishop otherwise no no
Checkmate there if you move your queen
back oh I'm hitting your knight E5 with
my Pawn your knight E4 with my queen now
the Knight moves away from the E5 score
and The Rook on E8 protects the Knight
over there on e4 the game continues in
fact black wouldn't even be that much
worse so this is tricky stuff from not
back maybe Wesley I we see the
evaluation bar in the live position
after F4 Knight C5 it still says that
white is much better maybe it's just
like one of these just absolutely brutal
moves like King B1 just like you're not
going to Fork me you take my Pawn on B3
I drop my queen back to C3 and now
really both Knights are under attack but
I have to give nybeck credit he's giving
himself a Fighting Chance white doesn't
have so much shelter in front of his own
king that's actually an amazing resource
when I first spotted F4 Knight C5 first
was not even on my radar and I'm sure
for most of us it will be a difficult
move to find threatening a fork but
that's not the main thing the thing is
it's not easy for white to actually
defend that B3 Pawn so to think about
just Sid stepping with your king giving
it away for Wesley if he does the
calculation takes his time right now and
spot this defensive resource of King B1
that you pointed out this could be a
quick game then yeah this would be
almost over white would win a piece this
Black Knight would drop still some work
to be done to wrap it up to convert the
advantage but I think ultimately this is
the key moment if he if he finds King to
B1 at the end of this two3 move sequence
he should win with white and he plays
the first move F4 Moment of Truth he
plays King B1 Wesley so has a decisive
Advantage the Knight is falling in the
next move love this style from Wesley
just playing this ambitious chess from
the very start of the game he's finding
the tactics when necessary so it's not
just like Wesley only enjoys These Quiet
positions and we see the position on the
left hand side that is a very quiet
position between Magnus Carlson five and
a Carana we we see that both sides have
Queen two Rooks Five Pawns and a minor
piece it's very even on the left side
but on the right side we're going down
that line Wesley so has a huge advantage
and this is the Wesley that we saw in
the round robin stage and then he lost
the last match to Fabiano kwana and we
saw him struggle on day one but this
kind of precise chess is exactly what
happened in the first few days in
Toronto and Wesley is back in form back
in form it feels like the Beast has
woken again it's woken up from that
Slumber of just a couple of days off
there Wesley so and yes the Black Knight
is jumping dancing around but white is
up material white has an extra Bishop
now for just one pawn and uh yes even if
black gets another Pawn for it it's all
about the black king there's always
going to be checkmating ideas on G7 and
actually yeah I don't see too much
resistance Ator he really needs a
miracle now and let me pointed out that
on set one it was Wesley who got the
first win in but it was a very different
game the entire game it felt as if it
was advantage nbec and then in the time
scramble Wesley man managed to get some
tricks in and win it but this one start
to finish Wesley has dominated from the
opening stage he takes n back by
surprise then plays energetic chess with
that H Pawn moving forward playing on
the dark Square weaknesses and now he's
up material by the way also on the left
side we see a lot of moves being blitzed
out but I think the evaluation Still
Remains a level there's very little
material remaining on the left hand side
between Fabiano and Magnus that's
Advantage Fabiano drawing with the black
pieces that's what you're told to do at
the highest level a very solid start for
him but on the right hand side n debeck
i we don't really see him play too
solidly very often but it's not the type
of game that he wanted out of the gates
against Wesley you don't want to give
him that confidence because Wesley's win
in game one yesterday that was from noty
going too far he had an extra Pawn in an
endgame but then he couldn't hold
himself back couldn't show that
restraint end up losing here it's just
Wesley blowing him off the board yeah
when Wesley has nothing to lose uh as we
saw earlier in the tournament against
Magnus Carlson in that amazing
Armageddon uh then Wesley just display
some incredible chest it's as if Wesley
so turns into mik tal somehow just
sacrifices pieces attacks checkmates and
he's doing the business there meanwhile
back to the left hand side of your
screens Magnus Carlson against Fabiano
Carana level pawns but things are
changing pawns are dropping um actually
if anything I would probably take
Fabiano's position if he can stabilize
in the next move or two because White's
remaining Pawn on that left side of your
screens the B Pawn is weak Black's
Bishop is about to unleash itself and uh
a very strong piece I think Magnus needs
to pull the break now and uh there
should still be ways to force the draw
but ultimately it should just be level
and Fabby had to fall back with the
queen to defend that Rook on B8 which
was hanging so no time to pick up that
Knight on F3 he needs to watch out for
his clock though Fabby is down to about
two and a half minutes Magnus has uh a
three minute Advantage almost on the
clock is it time for Magnus to liquidate
the situation further pick up that E5
pawn and he'd be happy if black was to
pick up the B4 Pawn can Fabby actually
make something of the pin if Magnus was
to go Knight into Pawn at the center of
the board I don't actually think there's
a way to exploit the pin because white
can always defend it but it does look
like as daveid would say hoovering off
the pieces is the way to go so if Magnus
can just get them all off it'll be equal
but on the right hand side of our screen
the evilart went down a bit nbe quickly
responded and it went right back up so
perhaps missed opportunities there for
nir abatar I don't think he's mentally
resigned because he always gives a fight
and he is opening up a line on the right
hand side in front of the white king but
apparently there was a better move yeah
there was a better move uh not an easy
one I think he played the most human
approach abdor of he's trying to open up
White's King which doesn't look like it
has too much shelter so still some
counter chances against Wesley's King
there but he could have actually brought
the black queen forward into E7
difficult move eyeing up the A3 Pawn
there was a pin on the E file uh now
Wesley has stabilized the only safe
Square for the white king is the one in
the corner but luckily it's protected by
that beautiful dark squared Bishop which
landed on B2 as early as move two and is
now dominating the board dictating the
play Wesley still a piece to the
good not a back Abdu satov as always
just never giving up and I think there
were a lot of takeaways from day one and
one of them was that you just continue
to fight it out till the end and he has
sacrificed his Rook for that Bishop that
you were pointing out which controls key
squares on the queen side and now a
black can think about stepping up with
that Rook to B2 to create some chances
to at least create a Chaos on the board
a huge threat Queen takes Pawn as well
as the knight in the center of the board
Under Fire and Wes's move here is pretty
easy he has one move that defends the
Knight and defends the pawn queen
diagonal to to the right hand side Queen
E3 protects both the black king is also
about to get checkmated so it's not just
the white king in danger the black king
actually may be even more trouble so
great recognition by Wesley also great
time manage by him he's been leading on
the clock from start to the finish and
now not back just down to a minute left
and his chances are going out the window
and I want to draw your attention to the
left side of the board because that
Central Pawn was grabbed by Magnus
Carlson and we were talking about
whether you take advantage of the pin or
not Fabby instead of hoovering all the
pawns off the board steps up with The
Rook to the Central File attacks that
Knight white has moved the Rook as well
are we expecting all the trades on that
E5 Square pick up that B4 Pawn draw
agreed yeah Fabiano kowana has the
chance to draw pretty much on the spot
if he trades off the white knight in the
center of the board over there if he
takes it it's a draw guaranteed he's
looking for more he's trying to look for
options to keep the game alive but
ultimately there was nothing else he
takes takes takes takes the Rooks off
the board as well black will take the
pawn and dead draw we see a handshake
Carson against Carana it is a draw first
game between the two top players in the
world world number one and world number
two ends in a draw three more rapid
games to go meanwhile Wesley putting the
finishing touches in his game has nbec
managed to muddy The Waters from a
practical standpoint
yes and no I'm going to say yes he's
muddied it it looks a bit of a mess
right now uh Wesley so chose Messi as
his favorite footballer this position is
the definition of Messi but I do think
he's going to win it I think he's just
got too much control he's got an extra
Rook nbec trying his best to set up
these sneaky traps attacking White's
Rook on D1 now threatening to maybe
bring the black Rook to B3 but look at
this Wesley so so energetic Knight to C6
counterattacking against the black Rook
watch out for the black king check mate
on the background incoming and I think
this will be the Clincher there's
Checkmate on the back rank there's a
Checkmate if that Queen lands on G7
everything is a problem for nir he's
also down an entire Rook right it's not
like he has material compensation and I
think that's the point even if he
doesn't deliver the check and the Queens
get traded off that's an end to the game
as well where there's one check that
black gets in do not step up with that
King to A2 that would be a mate on
Wesley so he blocks it with the queen no
time to pick up the Rook on D1 because
Black's Queen is hanging on F6 and and
that is it it's handshakes Wesley gets
the job done in game one on his route to
try to level the mat car and take it to
set three we heard that interview with
Wesley and Danny Wesley talking about
his best game ever against Sergey kakin
which was a beautiful one you should all
look that up but this game right here
that was also a sight to behold he just
crushed nybeck never gave him a chance
absolutely and I think that was the more
impressive thing than the actual win
itself that how it was Wesley dominating
from from start to finish the Magnus
Fabby game which ended in a draw was
peaceful throughout and I think for that
Fabby should be relieved with the black
pieces once again neutralizing out of
the king spawn opening keeping
everything under control but Wesley was
uh the MVP of this round yeah this was
Wesley so at his best back to another
level and uh I want to show some
highlights from that game from that
classy Victory against Abdu satov the
first game of today yeah we will uh get
to that segment and throughout the
Champions Testa the players right now
are in Toronto playing over the board
but throughout the season they have been
setting up their Opera browsers and been
playing some spectacular spectacular
online chess it is uh the first the
world's first ever chess te browser with
some really cool features including a
built-in VPN you've got the messenger on
the side and the best part my favorite
part Robert there's a chess com
integrated on the sidebar you click it
and you can stop playing chess
immediately I mean I'm it's bad news for
a lot of people out there who need to
stop playing so much chess I know some
of you are playing chess into the Wii
hours you know who you are maybe take a
break every now and then but it's really
cool just one click away you get to go
and play your friends or anyone on the
internet the Opera Razer you've got to
check it out and David's going to show
you how it's done while analyzing a key
position as well David that's right
Tanya Robert alluded to those chess
addicts out there there I am one of them
and I'm going to show you not just how I
play but also how I analyze these games
so this is my start screen nothing
special going on until you see the Opera
browser I'm going to open it up this is
my homepage you see the cool background
here chess.com integrated indeed I'm
going to go to the shortcut this is uh
my favorite feature you can go there
minimize it when your boss comes around
at work if you're secretly playing some
chess games and uh this is how I analyze
so right now you have all the options
here of course I'm going to go in to the
Champions chess tour finals and uh here
we do see us on the screen our broadcast
but not just that I'm going to go into
the games where Wesley so did defeat uh
nobec Abdus satov and this game we see
if I can maximize which I will try to do
here uh we do see the game we had
earlier weslio did win and it was just
this one moment I wanted to highlight
The Classy moment where he clinched it
all the way back in the early stages of
the middle game with this beautiful
Bishop along the diagonal here we have
the computer moves the accuracy
incredible 947 and 94.7 in a complicated
position but it was here Pawn to H4 want
to remember at home push those Rooks
pawns especially when your opponent has
a Sitting Duck a sitting Target here
like the black king and just a few moves
down the line the H Pawn was the one the
wrecking ball it wrecked the black
King's structure there were all sorts of
checkmates and later this diagonal
became the essential one Wesley wrapped
up the win of a piece just a few turns
down the line p F4 and he went on to
clinch the
game Opera is amazing and the speed with
which Wesley saw got the job done in
game one is also amazing and before we
start game two we got a couple of
minutes the perfect time to get your
Opera browser on go. chess.com
Opera best ever chess tee browser in the
world and Wesley so's got a smile on his
face after that fantastic game won from
start to finish forless play and
meanwhile nbec Abdus satra will be
fighting it back we will be back in just
a
[Music]
few nbec Abdu satoro is a phenomenon the
teenage Prodigy from usbekistan had his
first big breakthrough in 2021 when he
won the world rapid Championship since
then he has smashed through the 2700
barrier and even LED his country to
their first ever gold medals at an
Olympiad it is Abdu soro's endgame
skills that truly set him apart from his
peers he has a very mature approach to
the end game as evidenced by this win
against Magnus Carlson in the 2021 World
rapid
championship in this position Abdu
sattorov had white he is ahead in this
race white Pawn only being one square
away from promotion and after a careless
move by Magnus playing the Pawn to B4 he
didn't get tempted he wasn't greedy he
did not capture this Pawn instead
delivering a very accurate check this
immediately provoked a mistake from
Carlson the end game is winning for
white anyway but Carlson Advanced his
King to the corner and this cross check
forcing the queen exchange won the game
for Abdu satoro after the Queen's
disappeared white is about to make a new
Queen and he went on to win the
game a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
[Music]
things
who doesn't love the mittens plusy and
it is on our merch store some great
gifts that you can pick up for the
holiday season head to tescom do shop
it's B Bigg ger it's better and it's
cuter than ever and speaking of plushies
it is time to get to some plush chess as
Wesley so gets the early lead in his
match against nbec Abdus satro and he
gets it done ticking off one of Magnus
Carlson's goals for 23 win a chess game
with 1 B3 and speaking of Magnus Kaa
caught up with the world number
one game one is a draw and is that a
good result for you Magnus uh when uh
well Faby will have to win this match um
I think it's all right um I wasn't
thrilled about the way
um yeah I wasn't thrilled about the way
that I that I handled it I I think my
play was a little bit too too soft I was
thinking after all these exchanges that
I might have some uh good Bishop versus
uh sorry good knight versus bad Bishop
scenario at some point but it's not um I
think it's not remotely
um realistic so um yeah I I I yeah I
think that was a bit of a m misjudgment
like generally white doesn't have much
in general but the way that I played out
just made it really easy for him but um
yeah at least it's nice to have one game
that's
not um you know like
yeah yeah all right myness today we have
been talking about your goals today
because yesterday uh you checked off
your goal of winning game from minus 10
position um so first of all uh
resourcefulness I guess was like the
topic for you yesterday what is the
topic for you today well clearly in the
first game a bit of solidity but uh I'm
I'm sure the match will take off
eventually all right and uh two more
goals here have fun I have to ask you
have you checked that off in the CCT
season this season oh yeah I mean I've
definitely had lots of fun in in
different uh tournaments and um finals
as well it's been a little bit stressful
at times but it's still had some fun
moments all right so we're going to get
that checked off but the third one to
win a game with one B3 I know you can't
reveal your openings but do you have an
ambition to make that happen before the
CCT 2023 is finished I haven't won a
game with B3 this season no okay then uh
then I might have to try and funny that
we are talking about that because I
don't know if you checked out Wesley
Souls game he played with 1B 3 and I
think he just won that
game yeah I mean what's not to what's
not to like like it's not a terrible
move okay okay well uh not to reveal any
of your opening tactics but what is it
about for you rest of today I don't know
really um I mean so far that's a bit of
a tentative start uh but um yeah we'll
see what he what he wants in the in the
in the second game all right well go
have some fun Magnus thank you for
stopping we will get that checked off
Magnus Carlson confirms he has had a lot
of fun in the CCT season this season so
back to you guys and we've had so much
fun as well Kaa there giving some
opening ideas maybe 1 B3 needs to check
that off his list he doesn't have that
much time but there is also a world
rapid and Blitz coming up later yeah
Magnus has time to check that off his
list he's having a lot of fun that's a
good thing and I was just thinking he
said his play was a little bit too soft
that was the first draw between them
yesterday I don't know who was Paul Dano
and who was Daniel de Lewis but there
was definitely blood today we have a
quieter start in their match but Wesley
on the other hand he got the job done
against nck in game one how much would
you love to see Fabiano throw 1 B3 at
Magnus right now just to be a bit of a
troll just to get in magnus's mind uh it
feels like all the players are having
fun out there in RTO BBY needs to get in
on the action yeah he does and we did
have a lot of action with five decisive
games including the armag between these
two in set one a slow solid start
between the world number one in world
number two but there was it was anything
but solid on our other matchup Wesley
still going all out today I think that
nck would have preferred to be solid but
Wesley gave him no chance at all Wesley
was in a punishing mood he delivered a
knockout very quickly that was barely
even a game I don't think nck even felt
like he got his feet beneath him so
we'll see what n brings in game two he
actually has come back from a deficit
three different times in the Champions
chest or finals here but he's proven
already that he can do it yeah including
against Hikaru in the survival stage as
well losing game one striking back and
then knocking Hikaru Nakamura out on day
one on set one of this very semifinals
nbec Abdu satov lost the first game and
then strikes straight back what does he
need to take away from those two games
is exactly what he's thinking about he
starts with the white pces what will be
critical in the opening in this one well
firstly he needs a better opening than
the previous game luckily starting with
white he'll dictate the nature of the
play The Pawn structure and uh maybe
he'll be able to land the first surprise
I think that would be key for NOC but
then just do what he's been doing
throughout the tournament as Robert
mentioned he's come back so many times
his play is decisive by nature and he's
got to take inspiration from these
semi-finals in general we've had 11
games including yesterday's Armageddon
nine decisive results only two draws it
feels like something's in the air out
there and he could take inspiration even
from the first game he got into big
trouble against Wesley so but finding
that resource with Knight D7 Knight C5
nck is sharp it shows that he's not
going to go down without a fight but
he's playing Wesley so and you look at
Wesley he's ready for game two and we
are ready for game two as well and in
just a few seconds we will have the
first moves nbec Abdus satro playing
catchup he starts with the white pieces
will it be the king's spawn opening it
is the Queen spawn opening Wesley there
adjusting the pieces jup and what is he
going to start with Knight to F6 o he
lingered on his Knight for a second but
nope it's uh symmetry copy catches D4 D5
and the Queen's Gambit offered by Abdu
satoro rejected swiftly by Wesley so
going for the slav defense one of the
most solid openings in chess and uh what
variation of this slav will we see how
ambitious will nbec be here all the
knights are out now and decision time
does black just set up more pawns on
solid squares does he capture White's
Pawn here we go semis slav and uh the
triangle variation where black just puts
Pawns in the center it's interesting
because Wesley In classical chess as
well has often chosen to play Queen game
at accepted positions where he takes
that pawn on C4 but he doesn't want to
give ner backck the center when you
steal that pawn it is a Gambit white
would control some key Central squares
namely the E4 Square so Wesley he's
adopting a much more solid approach he
says that my Pawn triangle it's going to
keep control of the center for now I can
develop my dark Square Bishop Castle my
king I think that Wesley's taking the
right approach thus far and very
instructive how Wesley waits for white
to first develop the bishop and then
captures that Central C Pawn forcing
nbak to waste one move by having to play
the bishop twice and immediately strikes
with B5 this is still within Theory
territory that Bishop the light Squad
Bishop that Wesley has will come out to
B7 and often these positions are again
about getting those Central breaks in
for black if Wesley's able to get the C5
going but right now under control what
do you make of this Choice by Wesley to
dissolve the center yeah interesting
choice it means that he's deep in
opening preparation otherwise Wesley
wouldn't be playing like this giving
white extra Central pawns lovely shot
there I've got to say with both Fabiano
and Magnus super curious super
interested in the opening developments
before they get ready for their own
games these top players they love love
chess they want to learn all the time
and uh okay they go off ready to start
their match but in the meantime it is
nybeck the first to slow down NC's
thinking here because he has a big
Choice does he push his Pawn in the
center E4 they say is best by test and
he can test Wesley right here to see if
Wesley understands the Dynamics of the
pawns pushing but I think that right now
nck should be happy with the outcome
even though he's the one thinking it
will be a fight in the center with nbec
expanding with E4 and Wesley trying to
break with C5 and meanwhile this Fight
Continues with Fabiano starting with the
white pieces and once again we see him
employ the King's Pawn opening and this
time no Sicilian by Magnus Carlson his
opening of choice for the Armageddon a
more solid approach thankfully we will
not see a Berlin the Cil was killed
yesterday FAO Carana beat Magnus Carlson
the white side of that Ros was Sicilian
so now we get an Italian game and it's a
quieter start there could have been a
fried liver for those of you who are
learned chess as kids where everyone's
playing the fried liver going straight
for that F7 Pawn not here not against
Magnus Carlson there's a ton of theory
there and at the highest level that
theory often allows black to equalize
yeah just looks like noral things
happening on the board and shout out to
air things uh for showing us the air
quality out there in Toronto looks like
uh perfect conditions for the players we
see the chairs we see the uh kind of
Esports Arena we've built for them and
no complaints about the uh conditions
great uh yeah great temperature Magnus
loves it warm out there 25 degrees in
Toronto I'm jealous sitting here in
Norway where it's freezing outside but
uh in the meantime early days it is the
Italian opening and Fabiano very
ambitiously brings his Bishop out so
he's feeling good he's feeling ambitious
in this game as evidence this last move
it is risky White's Bishop could be
misplaced if it gets kicked about but it
is provocative at the same time asking
black to push pawns forward and that's
the kind of Chess you need to play right
now and that last move by Magnus it just
signals that he wants to keep everything
under control in this position wants to
keep it as solid and basically ask Fabby
to show his cards to try to create
something Magnus not getting provoked to
push the G Pawn forward just yet we see
Fabby trying to get play more space on
the queen side that a pawn can further
March down the board to A5 technique
that got him good results in set one it
did indeed and right now I think that
Magnus has a bit of a passive position
but he's okay with that if he keeps
drawing the games the good news for
Fabiano in particular is that a 22 tie
there are no ties with Armageddon on the
line so for Fabiano if he just draws the
next three games he still have a chance
in armagedon but Magus says I don't want
to risk losing I don't want to play
anything overly ambitious why should I I
one set one I have the inside track to
the finals yeah historically Magnus has
such a monster score score in Armageddon
chess uh Norway chess the event earlier
this year he won seven in a row there
only losing one eventually this
tournament he's only lost one Armageddon
Magnus to Wesley so and uh yeah I think
Fabiano it's nice to have that safety
net but he needs to strike earlier and
these Pawn pushes it does show he's
being ambitious Magnus Unsure how to
react this is always frustrating when
the opponent pushes their Rooks Pawn on
either flank so far up the board do you
block it do you let it continue
advancing we've seen that backfire on
multiple occasions that white porn could
become a queen later on it's so close to
promotion later in the end game a real
Ace card up his sleeve and Magnus
pausing For Thought does he want to
waste time even looking at the queen
side maybe he focuses on the other flank
uh right now and if he does that then
he's uh provoking or inviting Fabby to
push that a pawn even further down the
board if white if it's white to play I
think A6 becomes a reality in the
position you really want to break down
on the queen side for Magnus the choice
is does he continue with development or
waste that one tempo pushing his own a
pawn stopping the Advance on the left
side of the board I would be tempted to
pause and go A6 here yeah it's magnus's
style as well not to allow pawns too far
kind of too deep into his throat into
his position here and it's actually
magnus's style to push his own Brooks
pawns up the board as far as possible as
early as possible so Fabby taking a leaf
out of magnus's book and okay he doesn't
block its advance so white might well be
able to establish a really strong Pawn
on A6 in the next few mooves first a
question like trade or no light Bishop
trade Fabian has to decide what to do
with this tension right now I think he
more or less has to trade the light
score Bishops but does he want to
actually take that black Bishop on E6
and we see him just grab it now double
pawns they're often criticized not seen
as particularly good in the end game but
at this stage double pawns means open
files that Rook next to the black king
it's on a semi-open line there could be
an attack in the future and now the A6
pawn it doesn't feel as strong because
if you push it up there for Fabby you
can can't really capitalize on the light
score weaknesses without your light
score Bishop yeah therefore Fabiano just
completes development he gets castle
with the white King Super safe now and
mcus needs to deci uh decide upon a plan
White's plan is simple White's going to
expand on the queen Side Pawn to C3 Pawn
to B4 throw pawns forward maybe uh kind
of eventually aim to open the center but
uh just really tense right now and wow
on pasant isn't forced Magnus did you
not realize did you not get the memo he
puts a Pawn on B5
we say wow because it's such a anti kind
of intuitive move I think we're so uh
kind of the idea is so engrain deep
within us that we can never allow aason
at any cost that we sometimes forget
these types of moves exist and uh yeah
he's basically saying I'm bypassing your
Pawn if you don't capture me on passant
right now White's a PA might stick out
like a saw thumb but if Faby was to on
passant that only helps Magnus to
develop his pieces without moving it
even once and that's that Rook on a that
will be very happy after the a pawns
move on to the B file I would be
surprised if Fabi Ashi decides to go a
takes B6 the on pan that you're talking
about natural moves like put that C2
Pawn to C3 and I've got a big threat on
the board would be something that I
would consider here David I want to go
Queen B3 next but just as I said Fabby
takes a drastic decision he decides to
go for the trade on B6 does this
surprise you at all Robert I am
surprised because I think that this
allows black to continue his plan he's
just trying to trade off pieces that
pawn on E6 it's hard to Target it it's a
maybe the one weakness in Black's
position and fabbi he's continuing to
develop like nothing has happened at all
but I don't know where he is going to
strike because if you push D4 in the
center that eventually will allow a
series of Trades black will no longer
have double pawns so I don't think that
Magnus is the least bit unhappy and we
first have to trade Rook something like
that but the point still stands that it
will allow black to UND double the pawns
and that means that there's no issue
whatsoever I think Magnus just like
Fabby in game one is super happy happy
in game two yeah Magnus described his
play as a bit soft it feels like White's
play has been a bit soft here as well
not able to achieve anything much and
like you said Robert if you trade off
Rooks and then go D4 this is kind of the
only uh kind of logical way to make
progress right now or at least the most
direct path but yeah just a series of
Trades why should black ever be worse
here I don't see it black can always
block the center push a bunch of
different pawns depending on uh his
taste right now and looks very very
level to me yeah well Magnus Carlson can
afford to be solid Fabby cannot this is
one of his two whites and he has to find
a way to break through and he has to do
it soon this game looks like Magus
should be happy out of the opening
outcome no big weaknesses rook's getting
traded off on the a file while on our
other board to me it looks like the kind
of opening that you want when you are in
a must-win situation well not in this
particular game but over the match nck
has to score somewhere we see an
asymmetrical Pawn structure there is an
offer of a night on e4 but more
importantly the fight for the C5 square
if white is able to control that white
does end up with an advantage out of the
opening and black can go wrong here in a
number of ways for example a tempting
move a rookie it's a great move from
Wesley so you don't want to push your
pawns too soon that was a lesson I was
about to try to teach everybody because
if he had pushed his B Pawn too early
that gives white just hands it over the
light squares and that would be light
Square domination it' be hard for black
to fight off for those squares so I
think that this is a great start for
Wesley is he going to strike with C5
it's a question that will remain
unanswered until Wesley actually plays
that move because that's the key idea
yeah just building up Wesley keeping the
tension and uh body language it doesn't
look like Wesley's too thrilled with
this position but at least he has no
weaknesses and if he does get that uh
kind of C5 break we will show this on
the board shortly but um if it's all
about that square all about that pawn
break and Abdu sator of no obvious moves
to clamp down yet he's still needs a bit
of uh a helping hand I would say here in
order to fully achieve exactly uh what
he wants right now wh's goals to shut
down that C5 break not quite attainable
right now so really tense position
really balanced but nbec I wouldn't say
that this is exactly what he would have
been hoping for he would have maybe
wanted something a bit more Dynamic
rather than playing for these small uh
kind of strategic preventing uh porn
break type of ideas but it's never easy
to achieve that when you're playing
against a player like Wesley no no
tough to beat tough to beat and in this
one tough to crack as well the position
that we have in front of us uh once
again it is a fight for who gets control
of that C5 Square I'm looking at natural
moves here for white you know you're
playing on the white side you want to
get your Rooks into the game you want to
get them onto the Central File the good
news for nbec right now is that because
of the pressure on the pawn next to the
C Pawn the B Pawn the B5 Pawn C5 isn't
exactly easy to achieve for black and
black did a free move I think he can get
away with C5 simply because the Rook on
C8 stares down the path towards the
black queen on C2 so C5 is a huge idea
and you see that Nery Beck first trades
and he's trading some more so he is
doing everything he can to prevent the
C5 push because now if there's a night
trade again in the center as the Knight
covers C5 you can't play C5 because the
bishop is loose the queen B6 for black
that's often the way to solve your
problems is you defend your Bishop you
reinforce the C5 score but white is just
in time to push with B4 now and truly
clamped down on the queen side so not's
doing everything right here he keeps
posing this question can you get C5 in
will you be able to make it work and for
the moment it doesn't seem that easy to
accomplish for Wesley yeah the big
question is does Wesley have options
does he have to trade off a set of
knights looks like the White Knight is
heading into this square and just to
show what not to do uh kind of The
Nightmare scenario for black is to just
kind of ignore this uh to allow the
White Knight to park itself on C5 to
have to trade off and to be left with a
horrible horrible uh Bishop this is why
we're talking about this Pawn break so
much because suddenly you could find
yourself with a dead piece stuck behind
its own Pawn here on C6 and white would
have the bishop air white would have a
bind on the darkart squares this would
be oneid of traffic and actually I think
long-term white simply winning so you
have to act very quickly wly so before a
white knight lands on the Square or
before white is able to clamp down with
a move like B4 the more you're breaking
this down the more we're looking at this
position it just feels like this is
Advantage not a back unless there's
something immediate and I think Ley
realizes exactly all these points and
he's going all out for it he makes the
move C5 one thing is easy to spot that
if white was to take the B5 Pawn black
captures on D4 really good but my
question what happens if white was going
to take the Knight on F6 I want to
deflect your Bishop from E7 and capture
the C5 Pawn but wesy relying on a very
nice tactic the queen D5 at the end
lining up his bishop and queen to the G2
Square so you have to stop Checkmate
white is forced to do that otherwise you
lose and then Queen takes C5 and there's
no way black is really in any danger at
this and in fact Rook takes E5 if you
push F3 I was think E4 perhaps instead
but just to force the matter and after
the Queens are traded B5 is defended A5
may not be but B2 is loose so too many
pawns are hanging for both sides to give
anyone an advantage yeah really
beautiful tactics and he played 1 B3 in
the first game suddenly his long uh his
kind of uh long piercing Bishop in this
game as well on the long diagonal is the
key piece look at this G2 Pawn it's
vulnerable Knight takes C5 was going to
be the other move I wanted to suggest
originally but again Queen to D5 type of
ideas here threatening Checkmate and
this is just really awkward to answer
how does white uh kind of block this
Checkmate threat the answer is if you
push your Pawn to E4 you might just
collapse on the C5 this would be a
disaster town and if you push F3
suddenly look at these white Bishops
lined up skewed on the dile so notet
correctly did avoid this he went for the
other option uh as tan mentioned but
already Wesley so throwing the tactics
out there hidden uh kind of gems there
from Wesley the tactics and Bishop takes
I'm assuming he's going to appear on the
board is he really contemplating taking
with the pawn oh my gosh oh that would
be ugly for the black king but maybe not
objectively bad maybe the black king
will Shuffle out the way the black Rook
would land on the G file later wow
Wesley so he's paused for a reason and
when the top players stop when there's
natural moves it means they're thinking
about something a bit crazy a bit spicy
but he does go back with the bishop and
do you think if he threw the first game
instead of having won he might have
really considered GT of6 there's no need
to risk it but the engines they approve
of it and Wesley was legitimately
thinking there so you know that he kind
of wanted to play it yeah but Bishop
takes Knight given the Matt situation
such a good human approach here and for
me it's also so impressive just this
excellent understanding that the top
players have the grand Masters have of
these critical moments we were looking
just to stop we were looking at Queen D5
instead another way another tactics to
actually equalize the position yeah yes
white can take the bishop thank you very
much give me your Bishop on D3 uh and I
think then black will be attacking the
C5 Pawn but just understanding these
critical moments that you need to break
out now or you pass over the advantage
Wesley sensed it he sensed that moment
and energetically played C5 yeah that's
the thing we talk about players Styles
we say certain players are really hyper
aggressive they're very direct they
always kind of have this itch to do
something we say other players are solid
they like to curl up but ultimately if
you give a good player a position where
there's only one way to keep the balance
or they need to act energetically kind
of in that specific moment more often
than not they play the position rather
than uh anything else they go for it
they find the best moves so that was the
case Wesley had to break out with C5
otherwise he would have been suffering
long term he found it uh yes he had to
rely on tactics yes he had to calculate
a bit but he pushed himself to do it and
uh I think black is totally fine here to
your point Wesley so is one of the most
accurate players in chess history he may
not always win games because he doesn't
take risk in moments where some people
make make a speculative decision to go
for an attack but he is incredibly
precise and he will punish you and right
now n irck he's the one who's deep in
thought right now can I continue this
game but perhaps if he does continue if
he doesn't take this bishop get to a
position with opposite colored Bishops
where it should be equal maybe he's the
one who can get in trouble his pawns are
split after all there's pressure all the
way down towards the white king So for
nck Who's down two and a half minutes in
the clock I think he might just have to
settle for that half Point by just
getting into opposite color Bishop
position but he needs to be precise do
even gets that half a point at the
moment and we see the clock situation as
well Wesley ahead on the clock so for
nbak uh the next few moves are quite
critical now he can either take the
bishop on B2 but there is a check on the
board that he can throw in as well all
the way on 87 does that change the
position in any way the Dynamics of the
position potentially it does force the
black king into the corner and uh I
guess the question is now do you take
this bishop or do you just move your
Rook out the way I'm not sure you should
delay too much longer if you move the
Rook for example then the bishop just
gets out of Dodge just moves away and no
good discovered attacks against the
black queen actually this Pawn is being
rounded up watch out for Black's Queen
coming over and striking against the
king side wow he plays the same idea
just a different order but I think again
if this bishop check isn't scary as we
just showed it's just a one move threat
black just Dodges then Wesley has the
time just grab a pawn be greedy and
David just complete that line because I
think it's that's the key point this
threat on G2 that after if you do grab
the pawn bishop check on H7 only move
for the king to h8 Bishop C1 would hit
the queen and the bishop on H3 but it's
got to be Queen G5 G5 F4 and queen takes
C5 yeah know everything is defended but
I actually I think I understand just to
finish this line the queen trade is more
or less forced and black has just stolen
two pawns but I think I understand what
nck missed he's not going to play Bishop
C1 in this exact sequence that we going
down he's going to try Bishop H7 check
and then Bishop to B4 but after Bishop
B4 Queen Queen G5 F4 there's no more
Queen takes C5 the bishop defends the C5
Pawn now your Queen's under attack but
Queen takes G2 check is the problem that
the queen trade his forc Bishop takes G2
and now all the Bishops are hanging for
both sides that White's Bishops and
Black's Bishops are under attack and
your rook's under attack on F1 so if you
take this bishop in front of the king
black simply takes this bishop on B4 and
how many pawns are you going to be up
three no two in the end but it's uh just
going to be a winning Advantage for
black yeah just simple calculation here
and I think this is well within Wesley
so's wheelhouse he does take the pawn
he's gone up material and nck has no
good way to justify his sacrifice it's
not just any old pawn as well those two
connected black pass pawns on the queen
side are simply going to roll down the
board unless you have something now wow
Wesley with speed and accuracy goes Pawn
hunting it looks like he's calculated
this line to the end n in big trouble
and we've got our crew joining us from
Toronto Danny
n back's got to be feeling the heat
right now things have gone very wrong
for
him yeah we were all debating uh about
whether we would see a repeat of the day
before when Wesley so won the first game
but Notre Beck came storming back when
he had his first chance at the white
pieces but it doesn't look like that's
what we're going to see and instead if
Wesley wins this game are we already
planning on a very long day of chess if
we want to remind the fans he would need
to win this set then they would move to
a two game mini match and then we would
get Armageddon if they're still tied
after that so for fans who wanted a lot
of Chess today we might be we might be
looking at
that if Wesley so gets a two-point lead
in this match especially when you're
playing against a guy like Wesley I
think you can give up pretty much all
practical hopes of making a comeback in
a match you'd have to win two games on
demand yeah I mean I don't know that all
practical hope would be the case and he
is he is Young right and what is this
what is the saying too young to know
better right I think that Notre Beck
plays one game at a time and I wouldn't
bet against him winning two but yes I
mean you only need two and a half points
to win the set of four so at this point
we're looking at two pass pawns on the
queen side I'm listening to I can tell
when Robert's voice is getting nervous
it gets a little bit higher pitched I
don't know if you've noticed that Tanya
and David that Robert when he gets
nervous that happens to him um and I can
tell he's getting nervous right now
sorry what am I getting nervous about
Danny I I just had one question for you
on a serious note if you're nyback and
you lose this game you're down two
nothing really you're likely to lose
this second set do you almost make a
quick draw to conserve your energy for
the reset or do you continue fighting it
out because we know noty backck he never
wants to make a quick draw what would
you advise him if you were his
coach and I knew you weren't getting
nervous I just wanted to hear your voice
for so sorry for for uh for the call out
um you took the bait though now we're
having a conversation cuz I miss you um
I don't know that nottock would ever
think like that Robert I think he's
going to play one game at a time and I
think that's what you should do right
because it's still chess no matter what
at the end of the day um I think Magnus
Carlson has led this generation with
that mindset where we've seen him push
for wins when he only needed a draw
right or complete you don't complete
epic comebacks by not winning one game
at a time right so I don't I don't think
that'll be the case I think he'll be
focused on the next game and um and deal
with what comes if I had to guess yeah
and Danny at the start of the show you
mentioned that Wesley's been in a good
mood we saw his interview as well
earlier and despite the loss in set one
it looks like his spirits are high he's
enjoying himself in Toronto have you
been feeling that as well that despite
what happened in set one Wesley's
feeling
good I I think the spirits have been
high for everybody I almost I almost
feel bad because the conversation that
happened out in the lounge after after
Notre Beck lost the first game was all
of us debating on what his nickname
should be I said this is really serious
work cuz you're going to be dominating
chess for a very long time
what is your nickname we got to figure
this out and um that was literally what
we all engaged in I'll keep it hidden as
far as where we're landing on that so
the fans can await with baited breath
but uh no I mean honestly everyone's
having a good time uh players are
hanging out I think it actually helps
their mindset to really feel relaxed and
uh and uh casual um but uh yeah I we'll
see we'll see how not's feeling if he
loses this game he might he might not
engage with us on uh on the the content
that we're doing for uncovered for those
who haven't checked out Fabiano and
Christian chill's podcast and the things
he's doing here it's actually pretty
cool stuff so check out shout out to
Christian's YouTube channel sorry I
don't even know what is off the top of
my head the C squ podcast go check it
out and uh Danny I want to pitch in my
idea for the nickname it should be no
dear comeback and because I think he
will come back later but uh on a serious
note what about the other matchup
between Magnus Carson and Fabiano Carana
which is much more KY uh what do you
make of that has it altered your
predictions uh in any
way
no I mean I well I guess my overall
match prediction was that we will have a
Magnus Carlson a Magnus Carlson playing
in the final um I think he's the
favorite I although I did talk to Fabby
I was like man get us Armageddon today
let's go so rooting for him to get us
all the chess he can um you know this
position actually looks pretty tame
although we did just see Fabby play F4
that's new since the last time I looked
and the the first thing that jumps out
to me is that Magnus is also down
significantly on the clock so okay maybe
maybe this is the start of Fabby press
pressing and you know you have to you
have to get aggressive against Magnus
Right Wesley sacked a piece against
Magnus that's how you beat him right you
got you got to uh swing at the king and
don't miss so I think putting pressure
on Magnus with white look at this I'm
liking it you see the advantage growing
here and Magnus down on time Dy you get
a wood Harris video and suddenly you're
just going to be coing the wire the
whole time but uh you know you just said
that he has to come after Magnus and
what would you make a Fab's play
yesterday not just what would you make
did you speak to him I know he lost set
one but how was he feeling considering
he beat Magnus two games in a
row yeah I mean I I think we can say
this now there was um day two of this
event Fabby was actually feeling pretty
under the weather and if you remember
that was a day that he did not play well
he started out 2 and0 and then went 0
and2 on day two with around Robin didn't
want to talk about that especially if
Fabby didn't recover but he said he's
feeling much better now he was sipping
some tea and he seemed in good spirits
and I think that from a from an athletes
mindset right you're always focusing on
a narrative that can get you to perform
your best and I think Fabby knows he
lost but he lost to Magnus Carlson who
is known for doing things like that but
objectively did Fabiano play just as
good a chess if not better chess than
Magnus in a lot of the positions right I
mean it was Topsy Turvy Fabby kind of
beat himself too so so yeah I think I
think he did play well and look at this
now I mean he just actually as I'm
talking about the mindset I don't think
it's going to matter I mean I think he's
just about to blow Magnus off the board
is Knight of five coming how do you stop
this Donnie five is about to blow Magnus
off the board and it looks like Wesley
is about to blow nbec off the board
crazy crazy action going on we're going
to Deep dive into this and check in with
you really soon but guys take this away
over the last couple of
moves beep has hit the fan sorry yeah a
lot has gone down just in the last few
moments Magnus Carson has lost control
uh I don't want to say blunder because
it's been a series of small inaccuracies
for Magnus Carson but he's allowed
White's Rook to penetrate to infiltrate
to the seventh rank on the left board on
your screens right now look at that
white Rook it's got the black king in
its sights it's got the black queen in
its sights the bishop is pinned not nf5
as Danny mentioned is just Lights Out
it's Unstoppable pretty much meanwhile
On The Other Board Wesley so's given up
his Queen what has he got in return for
it he's got a rook bishop and two pawns
and it's the power of those two pawns
but I'm going to say that actually the
Wesley so board is far from decided for
now because a queen is the queen White's
Queen is active and uh there we see the
evaluation B rising up slightly Abdus
Tor not not dead yet but Magnus I think
he's busted still some life for nck on
the right hand screen although um Wesley
is in the driver seat but I think Magnus
is busted because he had to break the
pin towards his Queen now that allows
the White Queen to slide into the E6
square and those light squares in front
of the black king are super vulnerable
that Rook is active I think that you can
bring your knight to the rim of your
Fabiano on the left hand side of our
screen bring your knight up to H5 then
bring your queen into E6 and all three
white pieces are attacking and black I
don't think is going to be able to fend
it off yeah we talk about it all the
time Queen and Knight combo the the most
devastating attacking Duo out there but
he has a rook as well and uh Queen
Knight Rook Black's King is be not going
to
survive I've never seen Magnus get
knocked out this kind of smoothly
Fabiano hasn't even done anything too
special he pushed a b to F4 at the right
moment broke open lines and Magnus has
collapsed pretty much he just needs to
put the finishing touches on but six
minutes for Fabby one for Magnus yeah
just a few minutes ago just a few
moments ago just a few moves ago it
looked like everything was fine for
Magnus Carlson and then suddenly the
position just explodes Fab's winning D
I'd love to see what happened where did
Magnus go wrong and it looks like the
moves are coming in really quickly
Magnus with about a minute minute on the
clock so perhaps you'd show show us
later what really happened there because
I I don't know what this turnaround is
about how did he get here it just seems
easy now I mean that Queen just slid in
The Bishop's under attack if the bishop
slides back to defend the king then the
Knight just hops in so all three of
whites pieces are going to go for the
black king I don't know how could
possibly survive yeah you need a miracle
now there's just zero counterplay
against whites King however whites King
uh in the kowana game has a beautiful
hiding spot a beautiful Safe Haven on H2
and uh normally in these positions you
will not be able to defend passively
here there's no active defense either
look at magnus's pieces how sad is this
the black Bishop black queen black Rook
all on their uh back rank two of them on
their starting squares and White's
Knight is going to join the party this
one looks almost over there's already
some really nice checkmating patterns in
the air it's looking so strong once that
Knight lands on H5 or F5 the only thing
that I think you need to watch out from
White could be that not allowing Black's
Rook to that check on C1 and perhaps
Black's Queen jumping into an attack
from the G file are those resources
resources available to Black in these
positions they are and that's why I'm
advocating on the left hand side of our
screens every that Fabiano's Knight goes
to the right hand side of the board
instead of hopping into F5 you go to H5
so you can deliver a vicious check on
the F6 square and get the black king in
a m it I actually think Knight F5 which
is maybe the more natural move if you're
playing on seconds you go towards the
center but I think that's wrong because
it doesn't afford the Knight a check on
the next turn I just want to point out
that Wesley so I mean he's doing
everything correctly he has those Bishop
rook and two Pawns and for now nybeck is
stopping them but I think if he as soon
as he gets his Rook behind the a pawn he
can just throw that pawn forward close
his eyes and get a new Queen yeah and
that bishop and C3 it is such a strong
piece controlling that A1 Square once
that a pawn starts moving forward
there's nothing that's going to stop it
and I think we're going to see that
happen Wesley does it at the cost of a
pawn but this Pawn's going to turn into
a queen yeah and uh he's trying to fight
Abdu satov he's going to try and
blockade blacks past Pawn on that right
board with his own Queen but Queens are
the worst blockaders in chess Knights
are the best blockaders Queens are the
worst Queens are simply uh just too
powerful too valuable you're essentially
wasting the best piece with white for
just a black porn and eventually the
queen will be get booted out of A2
anyway so uh Wesley he's just made it
look simple I've got to say Wesley at
his best makes chess look easy if white
was to put that Queen on A2 you simply
Slide the other Rook to the bile and get
it down to the second rank kicking that
Queen out of that defensive Square Rook
B8 Rook B2 and it's happening it's
Unstoppable and also no dearbeck is down
to his final 15 seconds Rook B2 Pawn A2
it's just game over it's so simple as
you said I mean Wesley makes it look
simple but n helped him out by playing
very ambitiously in a moment where he
should have signed the P treaty and I'm
really uh I think it's very in and this
one ends Wesley so resigns and hardack
Strikes sorry I'm going to take that
back Wesley strikes again with the black
pieces and that is a 2 to0 win for
Wesley so he's striking back in the
match and looks like he's about to take
set two two games for NC to he has to
win both to take it to Armageddon and
this one it looks like Fab's ready to
strike back a very critical moment and I
was just about to say before that game
ended that Fabby he makes the wrong
knight jump that he slowed down and now
the queen comes to G5 and this was the
idea that we were advocating for Wow and
suddenly black is alive there's some
counterplay white is still doing well
but big big threat in the position black
wants to drop a queen into F4 with a
check he Retreats his Knight Fabiano
he's setting a trap of his own this
Knight is poisoned Untouchable if black
plays Queen takes Knight right now White
Queen slides back to the F5 check F5
square with check and black gets
checkmated next turn Rook takes Bishop
will come with a deadly blow wow this is
really crazy this is what Fabian is
relying on but it's not the best maybe
black can hold on he opened up two
things at the same time the F5 Square
for his queen as you were saying with
check also The Rook now covers that F4
Square so the bishop jumps out for
Magnus Carlson he's still in this game
if that Bishop can wrap around because
there are no checks against the black
king unless you want to trade Queens
which I don't think you do that black
Bishop is about to wrap around and go
harass the white king o 12 seconds for
Magnus though Fabiano it's as if he's
trying to be too clever he's trying to
find some really sophisticated way to
knock out his opponent when he could
have just done it Brute Force One Night
jump the other direction and probably it
would have been Checkmate within three
or four moves but uh now Magnus is alive
yeah and he took a good three minute
think for that one and it just felt as
if fa's going to find the right way
forward and the big difference was that
the knight from H5 could have arrived on
a check on that F6 Square it probably
would have wrapped up the game by now
but again now Fabby with the advantage
but he has to find it all over again
Magnus has got a brutal idea of bringing
the bishop onto an attack a check on F4
would actually be game over for Fabby o
yeah I think he has to act quickly here
Fabiano the White Knight is just on a
bit of an odd Square he's done a little
dance around the board he should have
just been uh using his inner vision and
trying to plant it on the F6 Square its
ideal post and now it does drop back but
allows the black queen to offer a queen
trade and I said no Defenders around the
black king suddenly Black's Queen is
doing a great job of holding the squares
he's going to trade he's going to
liquidate right now because after the
queen TR he can take that Central Pawn
with his Knight with Czech while
protecting his Rook so it may not be
easy to convert that Advantage
especially with the white king being a
bit vulnerable on that B2 Pawn when
their pawns on both sides of the board
Bishops usually are better than Knights
but Fabby he can steal a pawn here I'm
looking at his face though he doesn't
look that happy with his decision and I
wonder if it's because he missed the
bishop move because his retreating
Knight to H4 he played it really quickly
and if you just think about it in the
last three moves that white knight from
G3 has just landed on F3 instead of
delivering Checkmate it's become a
defensive piece now Fab's best chance is
to go into an end game with an extra
Pawn but he'll have to show some good
technique when in fact he could be
checkmating Magnus right now yeah that's
the thing he knows he would have had an
inner feeling he had three attacking
pieces he knows he could have got close
to Checkmate now an end game against the
world's best ever end game player yes he
might have an extra Pawn but it's not a
stable extra Pawn Black's Rook is so
active Black's Bishop is active White's
B2 Pawn over there on the queen side
might well drop off in the near future
and rook and Bishop do do uh they do
kind of a great job against rook and
Knight in general so uh I think it's
momentum black right now and look at the
clock times from six extra minutes it's
now almost level I was about to say that
before magus was playing bullet while
Fabby was playing Blitz now we're about
to be in a Time scramble Fabby he needs
to be careful here he should take that
Queen take the pawn E5 and try to work
that endgame magic because he's really
spending so much time at this stage he's
about to hit 30 seconds and he needs to
make a decision fast and when Queens are
off the board your decisions can be more
intuitive but if he decides to keep the
Queens on the board he'll have to rely a
bit more on calculation and he doesn't
have time for that he finally takes a
decision he should have taken in seconds
grabs that pawn on E5 all right Fabby
Blitz out the move now yeah there's a
big threat Black's Bishop is actually
trying to slide back to D6 the white
king White Knight are on the same dark
Square diagonal so he has to stop it he
does brilliant move there from Fabiano
caruana but again he's looking a bit
slow with his decisions when it's pretty
much forced moves and Magnus creating
counterplay White's B2 porn is weak is
going to drop off it might become a race
and I see the evalar give white a big
Advantage but I think from a practical
perspective it's not clear to the
players it's going to be a race between
Fab's East Center on and magnus's B Pawn
down the board he doesn't grab it
immediately comes back with the bishop
threatening a big check on F4 which
would have picked up the Knight and now
he's going to grab the pawn so Bishop
was uh you know in the rook's line of
sight so oh gives a check first but now
the white king can just step I think
forward at any moment here he's going
into the center so as long as Fabby
doesn't walk into any kind of Bishop F2
check which would win The Rook he does
have these two Pawns in the center so
move your Rook out the way start
throwing your pawns forward now it's
level material White has two connected
pass Pawns in the center but they take a
while to mobilize one of them is running
up the board now but Black's B Pawn
looks like the quickest of all and uh
okay the white Rook stops IT advancing
for now but the bishop drops back this
one is anyone's game yes the evaluation
bar say is winning for white but Magnus
he's saved a far worse position this
feels like the best he's had in a while
but it is even material if we just count
the pawns but white has two unopposed
pass Pawns in the center and look at the
Evo bar it's Skyhigh how do you actually
stop these pawns he brings a king out of
the pin then the Knight now is free to
move and he pushed E5 and now both of
the pawns they're rumbling down the
board one of them is going to become a
queen for a John in this match Fabby has
to finish this job he is so close to a
game win which will put him in a great
situation to make a comeback in set to
and he blunders with the most natural
looking check on H4 wow now black can
give a couple of checks from behind and
the white ewn was actually dropping
while Magnus even gives a check with the
pawn stronger perhaps he gives another
check second wh Pawn are collapsing
Fabiano has he blown the win oh my gosh
Fabby with the night moves it's just all
gone wrong and now Magnus grabs the pawn
on E5 White's King can take it but
Black's Rook takes the Knight instead
he's threatening to Queen Magnus comes
back with the bishop defending the d8
square and for Fabiano he needs to be
careful not to lose this game at this
stage if somehow he drops that deep Pawn
that would be a disaster and Magnus he's
pressing for some winning chances of his
own he's pushing his pawns up the board
this is so reminiscent of their game one
Fabby with the white pieces up a queen
lost in the end with the black pieces
with this one as well he was winning
throughout and now it's him who's
fighting for a draw yeah white is
fighting for his life but white does
have a threat white is threatening a
rook check on B5 and then to slide The
Rook across to D5 to block the black
Rook magnus's King Dodges Fabiano living
on the edge here and okay black
sacrifices a rook for the pawn can
White's Rook stop the black pawns this
should now be a draw I think but barely
because Magnus is playing for it Magnus
playing for win but white has a check at
some moment so it looks like the black
pawns are unstoppable you push the H1
off the board but he gives that check
right now so the black king it can go to
H2 it's shielded by its own Pawn but the
PIN along the second Rank and if you
immediately if you go King H1 Rook check
and promote the white king is just in
time to scoop up that final black pawn
it looks like it will be the case but
Magnus makes Fabby sweat he doesn't go
for the direct draw line as Robert was
pointing out pushes the pawn but now
Whit King is in time to pick up the last
remaining pawn and a king versus King
what a fight even Fabby can't believe it
both players with a smile on their face
that was an up and down battle and
Magnus survives against Fabby the max
stays level wow their heart rates must
be Sky High right now Fabiano feeling
frustrated disappointed for most of the
G uh the game he was dictating things we
saw a bit of a raised eyebrow from him
there Magnus he might not be showing it
but he is relieved and there was a smile
but it's like that Meme with the guy in
the corner and he's smiling on the
outside but it's a mask inside he's
crying Fabiano Carana has had so many
chances in yesterday's match and today
against Magnus Carlson but as Fabiano
himself said unless you put Magnus away
he will fight to The Bitter End and he
just Salvage a half point and this is
the fight to get to the finals it is the
final day of the semi-finals the players
need to uh make it to set three and it
means that Wesley so has to win his
match meanwhile Fabiano kirana has to
strike against Magnus Carlson to take it
to that final set it's going to be a
tough one what matches we've seen thus
far Wesley so he's become flexy so once
again today he's back but for Fabiano
Carana he needs to somehow put Magnus
Carlson away when he's ahead that's a
completely winning position he wins that
against anybody else in the world but
Magnus Carlson isn't anybody else he's
the number one player and he has been
for over a decade Wesley so with a 2 to0
lead in his match against nag it looks
like that one is most likely headed to
the set three but David Fabby was so
close to getting that win and it all
came down to finding the right night
move exactly and I'm going to highlight
that one moment Tanya it was all about
one move it was a golden opportunity but
Fabiano he went wrong it was a coin flip
he flipped and uh he landed the Knight
on the wrong Square it was here he could
have knocked Magnus out on the spot
White's Rook supremely strong on F7
White's Queen supremely strong on the E6
Square it's just improving the remaining
piece bringing it to join the attack he
actually leapt towards the center which
90% of the time is the right idea a
knight on F5 normally does thrive but
here he needed to go towards the rim the
idea is that this is the quickest route
towards the black king this check is
potentially deadly if for example black
tries to preemptively dodge the check
then white can renew the threat by
moving the queen putting pressure on
this black Bishop pinning Black's pieces
to their uh Bishop's defense and Knight
F6 is pretty much Unstoppable next turn
Umble no matter what black does say
makes a move Knight into F6 threatens
Checkmate you cannot take this Knight
because of this kiss of death and
therefore you have to sacrifice The
Black Queen this would have been winning
for Fabiano it's so sad because as Ben
FAL likes to say a knife on F5
unfortunately that choice may it a
dagger to Fab's chances because Magnus
Carlson was able to survive it's one to
one Magnus gets white once again and
fabbi he's going to be kicking himself
wow get those puzzle rush in it's all
about tactics and Wesley so was also so
sharp getting his tactics in for that
win against nbec Wesley so once he got
an opportunity he leapt on it he was
decisive he was brilliant with his
calculation and he even sacrificed his
Queen and it was here that nbec Abdu
sator lost control maybe reeling from
the tactics that had already occurred he
did not find the safe move the safe idea
of first giving a check and then simply
capturing this black Bishop if he' taken
the bishop off the board we would have
been left with a position of it color
Bishops and most likely the game would
eventually have fizzled out towards a
draw white should be relatively safe
here instead however he got ambitious
Abdus satoro he played a tricky move
Rook a to D1 but Wesley caught his bluff
who cares if the black queen might
eventually fall black wins too much
material in the meantime Wesley grabbed
a pawn and after this tricky move Bishop
to B4 he simply said give me he took
another bishop and yes there was a Check
Yes the black queen fell to the white
Rook but if we do a quick count at the
very end here black has too much
material it's about these pawns
especially but the rook and Bishop guide
them towards the end goal he eventually
got the pawn down to A2 and was about to
promote when he won the game it's the
unfortunate nature of match play where
you feel like you have to play for a win
but chess is an objective game not a
subjective one we don't play for results
nbe if was the start of event he
probably would have just peacefully made
the draw unfortunately he was going for
gold and he's the one who
lost but we know nbec can get the gold
in we saw that happen at the Olympiad as
well well he's got two games to strike
back and now it will be all about about
his mindset is he just thinking about
conserving energy going in for that set
three or does he want to fight this one
out till the very end n's got some big
questions to answer and we've got some
uh big surprises for you with uh 33% off
on our very cool displates you can use
the code chess for that discount on
displate.com chess every move matters
fundamental chess calculation skills I
mean this stuff is exactly what this
round was about getting that calculation
in and the players did make every move
matter but there is a big game coming up
Fabby almost got the job done in game
two in a winning position Magnus Carlson
how do you beat this guy we will be back
soon subscribers stay with us there is
cool content coming just for
[Music]
you
[Applause]
[Music]
a
oh
[Music]
n we are in Toronto for the CCT finals
here with Fabiano Carana on fire these
days and you had a great run in the CCT
2023 as well how will you describe your
journey through the season poby uh I was
really motivated from the beginning so I
played all the events I think I was one
of the few players to play all the
qualifying events and it was a bit up
and down for me some disappointments but
overall a lot of really close ones I
think they were all close I don't know
if there were any um any uh you know
wash overs one way or the other and and
some disappointing ones because
when you lose and it's really close that
also is is a bit uh painful now we are
here with the top eight players in
Toronto what makes you excited about
being here now oh I'm excited for the
format it's going to be really um I
think unusual I don't think I played in
a format like this and also I think it's
going to be a very close fight yeah it's
going to be very exciting what are the
fans in for this week it's it's going to
be exciting that's all I can say um
there there will be a lot of tough
fights and I hope that I'll be able to
to um to keep the form that i' I've been
having recently but uh I'm yeah I'm a
bit nervous it's going to be really
tough and also excited can we get you to
describe your playing style I don't know
if I'm the right person to do that I
think probably someone else would be
better I was sort of known at some point
for my
calculation um so I I've uh generally
been good at very good at calculating
like because I I'm I'm sort of a
perfectionist in some way that I I
always want to to calculate to the end
and sometimes after that my um I I Veer
away from my initial assumption about
the position which was more correct so
I've noticed that at times that my
instinct is actually better than what I
achieve after I start to calculate
things what would it mean to you if I me
to win the Champions chest T 2023 yeah
actually that that would be amazing I
mean it would really Crown off the year
for me yeah for me this is like a rapid
and Blitz World Championship I know that
we'll we'll have that later this month
as well but uh this has really all the
all the best players or nearly all the
best players in the world including
Magnus and Hikaru and yeah Maxim and Ali
Resa and so it's it's such a highlevel
event that winning it is is such a
Prestige awesome well we hope you have a
great time in Toronto best of luck Fabby
thank
[Music]
you
back
Fast and Furious chess action continues
after the Champions Chester finals it
will be the Fay World rapid and Blitz
where Magnus Carlson will try and defend
his Blitz and rabbit world championship
titles it starts on 26th December mark
your calendars and Robert you will be
calling out the action it's going to be
the Dream Team you and Peter Leo uh on
the world rapid and Blitz what are you
most excited about it's such a fun
tournament the action never stops in the
Chess World so it go from here to the
world rapping a blitz I'll be have the
call with the legendary Peter Leo who
himself almost won a world championship
title against Vladimir chromic so I'm
super excited fast-paced energetic play
and so many worthy contenders I don't
even know who's going to win well three
out of the four semi-finalists are going
to be there Magnus gson Nur Abdus satro
Fabiana Karana amongst others the
world's very best so that's one that
we're really excited about and one
player Wesley so he may not be playing
at the world rapid and Blitz but watch
us he is bringing to the board today as
he takes the two and 0 lead and kayak
caught up with
Wesley Wesley so has just come out
swinging today up two zero now in this
match how are you feeling well very
happy because yesterday he was playing
like a total computer just like perfect
chess like he didn't give me a chance so
now at least I got some chances like uh
I thought the first game was very good
he probably made like one or two
mistakes in the opening but I was very
pleased with how it went and the second
game he just blundered Bishop takes A3
which is nice so it's good to know that
another back can still blunder well how
have you mentally been able to come here
and play play like you're doing today
after losing the match
yesterday well I'm I'm I'm good you know
I'm fine I mean
I'm you know I'm a Christian so I let
God uh I know let his will be done in
all things you know it's a job you know
I I love playing chess I'm not the best
of it I had some hopes in the past but
uh you know I love showing up giving my
best and
just um putting him some work every day
and uh you know I don't really I mean I
really appreciate that they have a large
price fund here so I'd like to take the
opportunity to take the sponsors which
many especially the shinberg family and
also Puma like okay many others too but
I really enjoy the the shoes and the
clothes that I got from Puma so I'm it's
much appreciated yeah looking very cool
um game three here you're only going to
need a draw to take it to a third set so
what will be your plan for that game uh
well to look for a drawish
line but the match isn't over until it's
over
uh if I can if the match continues like
the way I'm playing and then the way
he's playing then I think I'll win very
easily but if it's not guaranteed he
could suddenly play like a machine again
so I have to be on my full force um I
hear you keep saying that that he's
playing like machine playing perfect you
know um what everyone is talking about
in chess these days um is is that what
you are insinuating no no no not I'm not
insinuating that I just just want to
check yeah no it's not not not like it's
just I'm actually praising him because I
know how great a player he is like not
making any cheating allegations I'm just
saying he's a really really good player
like I'm very confident with the
security checks here like there's so
much Security check here like this is
the strictest tournament I've ever
played in they check every single pocket
uh it's just I've seen how nyre plays
when he's in great form like the the the
match that he played in the or the games
that he played in the Olympiad also at
Tata steel were really
impressive so uh it's uh it's it's
nothing like that he hasn't reached his
full potential yet and uh you know he's
a he's a great player but hopefully I'll
win today so appreciate you saying that
Wesley and and finally okay something
more fun so this board shows Magnus
Carlson's top three goals for the CCT
this season one of his goals was to win
a game with 1 B3 he hasn't been able to
so far this season but you have won a
game with one b three and actually I
hear that's only the second time in your
rapid career that you play 1 B3 with the
first time something with leevon ronian
could it be CCT 2021
season oh interesting yeah but how cool
is that to win a game with 1 V3 yeah no
I've been practicing a lot nice yeah
like I know adiban made the course on
chess B well I actually didn't see it
but I've been analyzing some one B3 like
I played a lot in title Tuesdays
especially first from B3 also I played
in some Blitz Games Berlin and then some
rapid games in the Ilia levitov
tournament in Amsterdam so I've been
practicing it a lot I didn't think it
would work I just wanted to you know E4
hasn't been working well at all like I
don't want to I don't want to lose with
you know with white so I decided to play
something else and also in the second
game like I don't usually play the semi
SL I just thought I'd play some new
opening and it seems to be working well
um if I had a bigger repair tour like
Magnus maybe I could play something
different every game but we'll see
fantastic well congrats on your
performance so far today and good luck
in game three yeah a lot of games to go
yeah thank you for joining us Wesley so
he won a game today with one B3
amazing that was quite an amazing finish
after the cowboy opening and indeed we
do have a lot of chest to go and
potential set three potential armagon
coming up as the players are fighting
the semi-finals battle on this board
only one of them will survive to move on
to the finals and for Fabiano kwana he
was so close to getting that comeback
victory in game two and now it's back to
the black pieces how much of this will
be about getting out of the opening
without any trouble well the that's
always step one in any opening
especially when you have black you just
want to survive you just want to ensure
that you reach a healthy position step
one you equalize and then you start to
outplay the opponent later but uh
meanwhile we'll try to get those moves
on our uh electronic board very shortly
I don't think it's 1 B3 I'm just uh
looking from the side angle of the board
here on the camera but uh okay we want
those moves as the players they're
really rattling them out now on the
board and here we go it is wow the
Berlin of 1 D4 as they call it Robert
that's a really good way of putting it
and Magnus himself has been known to
compare openings one another if they may
have a mirror image and we see that the
Knight jumps into E5 in this game and I
thought that Knight usually has the G5
square that when the bishop the light
School Bishop slides out here you'd be
able to capture it so I think that
Magnus is the first person to deviate
from uh the main line the main
continuation here but is he going for
some aggressive intentions with the
queenside castle with check the black
king after all has moved that last
developing move by Magnus definitely
signals that he wants to put that King
on the left side of the board bring that
Brook out with a check on that black
king on d8 meanwhile Fabby still has to
finish his own development the Bishop
from f8 the knight from B8 needs to come
into the game uh that what Knight on the
center of the board would be the TA for
me if I was playing black and I would
start thinking about ways of trying to
trade it off with either Knight coming
on to C6 or to D7 at some point and
Fabby goes into a think uh so he's the
one taken by surprise here yeah I feel
we need to just forget the moves for now
we just need to talk about the
psychology this is one of the most
topical openings in chess seemingly
everyone pretty much plays this opening
these days and Magnus forces Fabiana to
think this early brand new move whether
it's good or not is another question
Advantage Magnus in the Mind Games
Advantage Magnus and it feels like
objectively whatever it might be it's
worked for now and can nck make his
moves work against Wesley's King Pawn
opening and he starts with E5 no more B3
I'm disappointed I wanted to see Wesley
continue with that strategy but here we
see the scotch game another rare guest
at the top level a scotch is uh B
basically a trade of Pawns in the center
this early on and nobec bit of
hesitation there but he gave a check
with his Bishop dropped it back giving
white a free move essentially but that
free move is White having a Pawn on C3
blocking a nice development Square for a
night so uh I'm not sure exactly what
Wesley so had in mind in the main lines
of the scotch nobec is trying to choose
a less explored territory here smart
decision from nck because those main
lines of the scotch if you look through
the top players in their history against
one another very often you'll see half
half they draw all the time in that
variation it's well studied this should
be for check it looked like a mistake
because you allow white to push a pawn
the bishop has to move a second time in
a row but it takes away that Square from
the Knight as David was saying and that
does not allow Wesley to go forward with
his typical development so Wesley likely
will develop his dark Square Bishop
protect the Central Square but black now
has a chance to muddy the waters because
Wesley's not in familiar territory he's
the one thinking first and David you
spoke about psychology in the Magnus
Fabby matchup and uh the opening
approach there and how that would affect
Fabby what about in this one now nbec is
trailing 0 to2 he's down by two points
he has to win this game on demand he has
to win the next game on demand what is
going on in his mind knowing that his
shot against against perhaps the hardest
player to beat is this essentially over
I'm not sure I think psych psychology is
one of nbec strong points in general he
just seems uh unfaced unbothered
undaunted I can't even remember the quot
right now but uh he is the Iceman nerves
of Steel nbec Abdu satov and I already
feel like he's tricked Wesley in this
opening Wesley chose the scotch and
black has three or four main variations
there nck says no none of that for you
you cannot rely on your homework your
opening preparation I'm going to play a
rare variation and as far as I know this
night move is a bit dodgy I've played
the scotch my entire life as well with
white and this last move has a bit of
bad reputation for Wesley so it feels
like nbec has surprised his opponent and
might be able to profit we see the pawn
push it's a pawn sacrifice a pawn given
up with check this is brilliant from the
USC youngster Pawn sacrifice not my
favorite movie but a great idea in this
position because he is giving up this
Pawn on G7 with checkm do the king will
have to step to the side but white isn't
spending so much time with just one
piece you're supposed to develop in
supposed to get your king to safety and
castle and when we'll dive into the
details that pawn I don't think it's
really worth it for all the trouble that
you are going to face afterwards black
gets such a rapid initiative with the
queen jumping out the Knight developing
and I feel like there's going to be too
much pressure against the white king so
easy to feel that when you're playing
against a player like Wesley you're down
two games in a match how do you make a
comeback but looks like nbec already
creating a bit of chaos on the board
exactly what he needs to do with the
black pieces and if nbec is able to get
this game win I know it's really early
to talk about any score but at least
he's been able to create a chaotic
position right now asking Wesley
questions if this he gets in the bag
then we've got a proper match on our
hands anything can happen in game four
and what n derbe does best is when he
has a lead on the clock he uses that as
the 17th piece our buddy James keny
loved to say the the clock is the 17th
piece and he did it against Hikaru
Nakamura it looked like Hikaru was
stabilizing was finding the way out but
he didn't have enough time and he had to
play some moves quickly when thought was
required so I think that nybeck with a
about two-minute lead coming up on the
clock with a better position more
development already I love his chances
right now in game three Wesley so has to
be so careful right now and he's also
been the victim of the death stare I
keep seeing nock's eyes just kind of
stare off imagine Superman with his
laser vision there just peering deep
into the opponent's Soul at this point
and uh Nock dream start and Wesley takes
the bait is this porn poisoned or not
Wesley's a pawn up but yes the uh black
king has had to move that's irrelevant
it's all about the White Knight now
stuck on the edge of the board The Black
Queen comes out threatening Checkmate on
the F2 Square Wesley so is in huge huge
trouble unless he defends accurately and
he's already living life on the edge the
Knight makes yet another move 1 2 3 4 5
six six Night Moves In the first nine
turns for white this is crazy look at
the black pieces pouring out this is
trouble for white is this like an
actually good Stafford Gambit so Eric
Rosen yeah don't play the Stafford
Gambit but play this this is a dream
come true look at all your pieces
developed that Knight on F6 is about to
come out to G4 with more of an attack so
Wesley plays his Bishop out to E2 and
now the pawn on e4 can be captured and
once that pawn is gone it's material
equality that Rook on h8 it could slide
one square over on any turn just to put
pressure against the white kingside if
you think you're casting there to safety
not so fast so I think that nordbeck he
can restore material equality and to can
continue his initiative from there and
look at that focus of nck Wesley he
continues to play fast though the last
few moves Knight H5 Knight G3 Bishop G2
Bishop B2 made really quickly is Wesley
do you think he knows what he's doing or
it's that okay I'm in trouble out of the
opening at least I need to just play
Fast to put the psychological pressure
on yeah I think Wesley's just using all
of his experience to kind of bluff his
way through here just to survive and
Wesley is one of the best players in the
world with when it comes to defense when
it comes to just stabilizing positions
manageable kind of control type
positions so he won't get checkmated at
least not yet but uh he is having to
give back his extra Pawn I'm just
counting the pieces I mean it's just so
many active pieces for black I think
he's actually done everything wrong on
the board wesle so but the fact that
he's actually survived quite quickly
he's only one minute down uh despite
being hit in the opening by this
surprise uh it means that he's got good
prospects if he can survive and weather
the original storm yeah I'm looking at
this position and the idea that you
mentioned right you equalize the
material you pick up that pawn on e4 but
with those trades of Knight does that
also ease the pressure of Wesley a
little bit can he go shot Castle get his
King to safety or also look at a move
like Bishop F3 as a defensive resource
the knight from B1 jumping on to D2
developing with tempo and is this the
reason why nck has slowed down not
immediately capturing on e4 trying to
figure out another way to keep more
tension on the board yeah he doesn't
have to take this Pawn he can instead be
down a pawn and he does just that he
brings another piece forward he did not
have to just say let let's let my
opponent castle and as you said t Bishop
to F3 I think there would have been a
second wave but why not keep the first
wave going there's no rush to capture
this pawn and if White Castles now oh
goodness the knight's coming to G4 and
you could take it once but a second
Knight replaces the first first and then
you can play H3 the only way to stop
checkm this is we saw something just
like this yesterday I don't remember
which game it was David but taking on F2
Queen takes G3 to follow black is
winning material and just winning the
game Deja Vu Robert you said that exact
sentence basically about another game
you're right the exact same Motif um I'm
trying to recall as well which one that
was but either way it's a decisive
attack for black this is going to be
Checkmate and aut material material gain
the black Rook is going to join the
party as well this one is over so do not
Castle you're only worsening your King's
prospect on the king side right now but
if you don't Castle what else I'm
already kind of seeing this idea being
powerful in a bunch of variations if for
example you try to bring your knight to
the rescue again Knight G4 collapse on
the F2 Square it's already really really
kind of critical for Wesley so one or
two moves and he it could be lights out
he could be knocked out on the spot and
the only way that you could say oh let
me take away the G4 playing H3 but then
Bishop takes F2 hits you where it hurts
you take and Knight takes E4 now two
pawns to the good I'm getting my
sacrifice piece just right back your
king is going to be checkmated I don't
actually know what Wesley should do here
I see the Eva bar still in the middle
but the players are probably looking
this like white might just already lose
a miniature and nck made a similar
mistake against Hikaru actually I
remember that first game they played
where nck allowed attack on F2 and he
couldn't safely defend it I really like
this idea by nck of going Knight E5
keeping the tension a big threat on the
board you said you need to stop that G4
Square take it under control H3 was a
suggestion is F3 also on the cards right
now to try to make sure that black other
at least doesn't get in the Knight to G4
and I see the albar luckily doesn't
react though I hate making this move
simply activating that black bishop and
making it a Monster yeah now you can
never ever Castle King side uh that
square is protected the black Rook could
add itself uh to the party the Black
Knight can come to put pressure under
the White Knight that's suddenly self-
pinned along this diagonal I mean yes
might survive but it still looks scary
F3 never play F3 as they say it just uh
I think this would be a last resort for
Wesley so if he plays it he won't be
happy about it and it will cost him a
bunch of time uh in the meantime and
yeah I don't envy him at all it's such a
tough choice right now if he doesn't
play it it might cost him the game I
mean Knight G4 if that Knight lands on
G4 I'm not finding a way to actually
defend the F2 Pawn I would just resign I
think F3 yeah and maybe you get away
with it what is the idea though after
Rook to G8 threatening this Knight I
think you might be forced to run with
the white king and uh this is just too
big a threat the Knight is attacked due
to a pin on the H file only move here as
far as I can see King D2 Run for the
hills hide on C2 but how tough is this
first of all to just imagine how how
tough is it to come up with this
creative concept of running with the
King and uh how happy are you about it
even if you do see it a beautiful line
though that the king can actually run
out of the center towards the queen side
Black's forces are concentrated over on
the king side that's a lovely line here
if Wesley plays this he certainly
deserves to win this second set it's not
going to be easy playing F3 opening up a
diagonal for that dark sore Bishop it
looks too dangerous and I'm looking at
the clock as well the attack will rage
on and nck I said it before I'll say it
again he punishes people when they're
nervous when they're down on time and
when he has the initiative so this is
the exact type of play that nordbeck
wanted and F3 on the board Wesley so
he's back in form in Toronto and will we
see that King march the white king
running to D2 to C2 next he's pretty
much obliged to he's committed to it
right now black has four attacking
pieces maybe a fifth with the Black
Brook joining but White's King will hide
in plain sight yeah and you could tell
Wesley hated making that move he played
F3 and just shakes his head once again
head in hands and it looks like Wesley
is in big trouble and uh also not just
in the position all the CL and on the
clock as well he's going to be need need
a little bit of uh chilling out to do
right now so good news for him that
we've got a Loi collaboration and I'm
sure he's been listening to some of the
LOI Girl music and you can check out all
the cool tunes that you've been
listening to at the start of the stream
at the end of the stream when you decide
to play some chess uh it's a great
playlist a great tracks to play on uh on
your favorite platforms YouTube Spotify
and
SoundCloud Robert do you have a favorite
Loi gold track oh putting me on the spot
uh maybe sandpaper oh yeah I've actually
heard that one and uh definitely check
out the tunes and talking of sandpaper
it looks like nbec is quickly removing
all of Wesley's defenses here Rook G8 I
love it Rook takes Knight it's a move
that David you pointed out putting more
pressure getting another piece into the
attack Robert I'm just thinking how you
know sandpaper I could listen to that
but this this uh position feels like
sandpaper honestly where it's going to
be rough Wesley's going to have to run
away if if he plays King to D2 here it
just shows the type of form he's capable
of he's lost his match in the seventh
match of the round robin to five minut
Carana he lost the day yesterday to Nock
who he said was playing all the best
moves and that was meant as a compliment
I do actually want to talk about just
that very briefly historically when you
say someone's playing like a machine it
was meant as a compnent now it's taken
to meet something else I know Wesley
meant well when he said that about no
deer backck and
King King D2 how is he playing like this
this is
incredible how does he find these
defensive resources I think he had to in
that position out of necessity otherwise
he just had to resign black was
threatening Rook takes Knight so the
idea behind this is actually for the
White Queen to protect her rook in the
corner uh on H1 and now Black's Rook
cannot take the white Knights now black
needs to find another uh way of attack
another route in but yeah the creativity
behind finding F3 first of all then King
d to almost superhuman the attack rages
on for no dearbeck there's a king and a
queen in line I want to get rid of the
pieces that still remain on the defa I
would play D5 throw that pawn forward
open up another file I'm still worried
about Wesley's King he'll probably move
his King on over to C2 but files
diagonals lines they're all going to
open up and the queen side for white is
completely undevelop The Rook the Knight
and the bishop on their starting squares
I just can't imagine a better looking
position for blacking at the EV bar is
completely unimpressed it's right there
in the center not a best player abrasive
like the Sandpaper as you said Robert
but David you know you said that it is
out of necessity that you find these
resources but I I just feel 99% of us it
would be still so hard to make this move
King D2 on the board I see your threat
Rook takes Knight it would at least take
minutes to find it but Wesley played F3
you only play F3 if you have seen the
idea of marching up the board with your
king yeah exactly and this is when the
top players they're backed into a corner
uh they find the best moves if you give
them a narrow path to survival or Narrow
Path towards winning a game 99% of the
time they do uh find those critical
ideas even if they look counterintuitive
he's sandpapering over the cracks here
with uh this last move but he's
surviving he's still alive for now he is
uh alive and surviving a very difficult
opening and some more critical decisions
are coming up for Wesley so and at this
critical moment we've got Danny joining
us from Toronto Danny were you having
foral about this madness that we're
seeing on the board and what to jump in
on the
analysis yeah well I was listening to
you guys breakdown this game between
Wesley so and Notre Beck abaturov and I
wanted to give a little bit of the
opening breakdown or at least give some
pause or question as to why Wesley maybe
chose the line that he did David if you
bring up the analysis board Wesley
actually chose a line that is a little
dubious to begin with when you start
with this Knight F5 move instead of
Bishop to E3 uh as someone who plays
this opening and admits that the scotch
can at times struggle I'm surprised that
Robert hasn't already made fun of me for
that um for Wesley to play this line not
that often in his career and then to go
9 F5 Notre backck to his credit was
ready because the main move here is G6
which then white can transpose with this
move Bishop to E3 which is actually
probably what Wesley was hoping for and
the idea is you can't take the Knight on
on F5 without the bishop on C5 falling
which means that black will trade on E3
white will recapture with the Knight
retreating and in this position white
actually has a very comfortable position
that's the line that white usually hopes
for if we're talking about a line that
can give white a draw and if you back up
a couple moves that line is normally
reached with white playing the move
Bishop to E3 instead of Knight to F5 and
this is probably what I I I guess I'm
saying now in hindsight Wesley should
have done if he didn't want to give
Notre Beck a whole bunch of fighting
chances but after Knight F5 shout out to
the kid who somehow guessed the uh the
opening maybe that that Wesley might
play he was ready to play the D6 line
which again isn't the most popular but
actually is the engine's favorite line
these days and this variation we're now
seeing play out on the board is actually
perfect for black to get exactly what
you need in a must-win situation right
Notre Beck has to win this game or he's
or it's uh already moving on to the next
round of tiebreakers so anyway just
interesting anecdotes I wanted to give
because rarely is there an opening on
the board I guess that I have some
knowledge or insight about uh
self-deprecating International Master
over here and just wanted to just wanted
to say that and again I'm a little
puzzled as to why Wesley chose this line
especially if he wasn't prepared in it I
guess is my my point yeah I was going to
mention actually Danny that I remember
you being here in Oslo with us a few
months ago and this Scotch came onto the
board so uh yeah we got the expert with
us just at the right time thank
you Danny coming in with the updates
there and uh we really needed that
because this opening I think for many of
us is such a new Fresh position that we
have in front of us it really breaks
down what happened in those first couple
of moves Wesley meanwhile has managed to
sidestep with the king so opening up
that Bishop vacating a square for his
own Knight to jump into but he's
delaying development further he pushes
the pawn on B4 hitting that Bishop it
really looks like only narbeck is
playing like he's been uh taught to play
chess because white is not developing
any of his pieces finally we see the
dark Bishop go out and as soon as he
gets that Bishop out you see the eval
bar plummet it's amazing position for
black we knew that but there must be
something concrete here I think it's uh
what you were alluding to earlier Robert
just blow open the center Pawn to D5
explode the center White's King still a
Target White's still behind the
development but uh we'll check back in
as Abdu satov tries to build that second
wave of the attack he's managed to get
all his pieces out but let's not forget
that Abdu satov has sacrificed a pawn so
it is all about getting to White's King
opening up those files he can't play
slow here give white a couple of moves
give him time give Wesley time to take
out the Knight develop it to D2 develop
it to B3 and white will be up a pawn so
Wesley momentum is key right now and he
needs to make those decisions fast
forcing uh Wesley to take difficult
decisions with less time on the clock
but the move seems very straightforward
for not pushing your Pawn in the center
your Rook typically wins a stown With
the Enemy Queen and trying to open up
more files and lines towards the white
king the one bit of good news for Wesley
is that the Rook on d8 is not protected
for the moment but that doesn't matter
on N debeck he holds nothing back he
strikes with D5 he might strike and win
game three and then suddenly this set
isn't over then we've got a match on our
hands if nbec Abdus satro gets the job
done in this one and so far with the
black pieces he's done everything right
we will check in with this Wesley has a
think meanwhile there's a very different
dyn white in general having the bishop a
in an open position you feel it's better
but to me the lack of development in
White's pieces would compensate for that
I'm just hating that pin on that Knight
on F6 yeah black needs to break the pin
that's uh the most urgent factor in this
position look at Fabiano his body
language right now it looks urgent in
itself and it looks like he knows this a
critical moment he needs to get rid of
White's Dart Square Bishop you need to
kick it away simply Black's Knight on E6
cannot take it there's a pin on the E
file there's a pin on the diagonal and
therefore move one of the Rooks across
or use a pawn use the black H6 Pawn to
kick away White's piece and if we do see
a bishop for Knight trade if white
starts squ Bishop has to trade off on F6
Fabby will breathe a s of relief he
needs to act quickly though I'm looking
at the clock I'm looking at the position
it's definitely momentum white right now
it is and I'm with you that you have to
get rid of the Dark Sword bishop and
even after that still better for white
because the healthier Pawn structure
that Tanya men is the opposite color
Bishops when there are no other pieces
remaining ofense going to be a draw even
if one side has an extra Pawn but with
Rooks and a knight on the board as well
we could see an attack especially if
that black king is drawn out to the F6
Square so Advantage Magnus on the clock
Advantage Magnus on the
board it's going to be an endgame grind
will Magnus Magnus his way through this
one even if the bishop a are gone as uh
Robert you're pointing out and David you
as well that white will be able to get
that second Rook into the attack from
the f file really quickly once black
king is pulled forward after the trade
so this end game it might look level for
now the evalar says it's level but it
does have more poison than what meets
the eye it does certainly Fabiano did
not make the decision we were talking
about now on the left Board of our
screens he moves the black Rook across
instead but this only encourages wh King
to park itself on a much safer square
and I'm assuming that Magnus Carlson on
that left board will Shuffle the King
closer to the corner whites King will
step to B1 and then it's the quick
comparison whes King safer than Black's
King wh's pieces more active than
Black's pieces Advantage Magnus Carlson
and uh in the meantime on the left Board
of our screens Abdu sattorov throws
another porn into the mix all of blacks
pieces at work in that board Whit's King
Whit's pieces they look like easy
targets it's still Wesley so in big deep
trouble and Wesley was able to win n's
Queen EXC me sacrifice his own Queen n
took Wesley's Queen in earlier game here
it looks like something similar could
happen that if on the right hand side of
our screen Wesley takes this Pawn on C5
which he just does look at notc he's not
taking that pawn back he's taking the
other Pawn the center but this isn't an
imitation of game two unlike that one
Wesley's King is in trouble so it's a
similar peace Dynamic but it's not
peaceful because White's King is unsaved
yeah really interesting that queen
versus rook and a minor piece we see a
similar thing and now nck has made a
move which the bar disapproves it's the
most natural looking move to me does
this give Wesley the opportunity to
capture that A7 Pawn which you can
easily forget about I think he's relying
on a trick here Abdu satov but he's
missed a trick of his own if Pawn takes
Pawn if white Pawn captures on A7 on
that right board Black's Queen can slide
the whole way across the board to A4 and
deliver a check Black's Queen will check
the white king and actually save the day
the a file is covered but white can
prevent that by first playing Rook to D4
Rook White's Rook sliding up to the
center here and now in this position the
fact that Wesley has paused means he's
likely to see this and once the black
queen is kicked away from the fourth
rank then Pawn takes PA and white is
about to make a new Queen Abdu satov has
lost control this is a critical moment
if Wesley so finds Rook to D4 blocking
out shutting out that Queen on the
Queen's King side and he does find it
Wesley so is missing nothing today great
find from Wesley and a horrible
oversight from nybeck it happens to all
of us but look at how much time notbe
has left on his clock I've talked about
how he punishes his opponent by keeping
control on the clock he played too
quickly there and now Wesley has a
fighting chance and maybe not just a
chance he might be better I actually
might prefer the white side if I can
take that pawn on A7 the next turn
that's an annoying pass Pawn that
Black's have to deal with and Black's
King itself is not safe and black will
have to move up with the King to stop
that pawn from promoting to A8 once the
queen moves back white captures the A7
Pawn black will have to stop it from
promoting to a queen which will give
Wesley time to capture the F3 Pawn yeah
abaturov this is his uh bigger strength
but maybe also once more weakness in his
game he relies on calculation he backs
everything up concretely he always wants
to play the most active ambitious moves
he didn't need to though he'd already
pocketed Wesley's Queen he could have
just simply captured that white Pawn off
the board the white Pawn that now sits
on B6 that's about to go closer to
promotion he could have taken it two
moves ago we would be arguing about the
same position but with black in full
control instead we're talking about
Wesley about to make a new Queen about
to promote just as he did in the
previous game and a material breakdown
white has a rook white has a bishop and
White's about to have these strongest
Pawn on the board yes black has a queen
but that's not the most important factor
anymore Abdu sattorov inside he's going
to be kicking himself and Black's King
will not be safer than whites on the
right hand side of the board Wesley's
King has been running now it's hidden it
has some shelter the black king will not
receive so many pieces in front of it
because you've already traded off many
and on the left hand side of our screen
we just saw a trade where Fabiano he
gives up his Bishop for a knight so it's
an advantage for Magnus healthier Pawn
structure on the left hand side of our
screens here where black has those three
Pawn Islands isolated pawns and the f&h
files and the light score Bishop that
can start poking at him I've seen Magnus
wi countless positions with a small
strategic Advantage better Pawn
structure better minor piece Magnus in
control it's what we would call a two
result game really flashy move here
Magnus on the left board moving his Rook
up swinging it across the Rook is
Untouchable because Black's Knight in
the center is pinned Magnus he's having
all the fun if Fabby defends well it's
going to be a draw but almost zero
chance of black winning that one and
with that Rook lift what Magnus wants to
do is try and provoke more weaknesses on
the queen Side by sliding it all the way
across Fabby preempts it makes the move
B6 meanwhile nck still in the think it's
clear that Rook D4 was missed by him
yeah not a doubt Abdus sator took a long
think there the black queen has moved
away the only black queen remaining on
either board right now and Wesley is
about to establish a monster porn look
at that white a porn now the new a porn
about to promote about to land a
touchdown black king has to move but the
problem is no matter where the black
king moves on the right hand side board
that the king is walking into a dark
Square diagonal that the bishop on B2
it's been a bad piece all game but it is
going to have its fun because if you go
to G7 we have a full diagonal from that
Bishop on B2 all the way to a King on G7
but no he gives a check and he eval bar
is going up up and away why can't white
just move the bishop and block that
check oh maybe the answer is you can
move the bishop even if you sidestep the
king I'm not sure what Abdu satov is
aiming for with this check Wesley so
doesn't have too much time under two
minutes but he has for the first time in
this game a superior
position I mean I'm just thinking about
what you said Abdu satov what does he
have in mind if the bishop does move
forward he's threatening to Queen on the
next move he's attacking Black's Queen
on the other side of of the board the
only trick you can set up is of discover
checks by grabbing that Bishop with your
own Knight and relying on the tactics
that when white promotes and I think
we're going to see this play out Knight
takes Bishop white promotes the queen
move up with your king attack the White
Queen and your threatening this discover
checks Wow abdor might have tricked
Wesley so lured him in with the bait
white has made a new Queen so I said
there was only one Queen remaining on
either board suddenly white has a queen
and that right board but the queen is
attacked in the corner on A8 by black
rook and the threat of uh this discovery
against White's Kings could be terminal
Wesley's new Queen drops back walking
into the firing line here something is
lining up look at that white king it's
about to be checked left right and
center but Wesley is he surviving
question Wesley on the right hand side
is up a rook at the moment but that
Knight can actually deliver a check on
F2 and then it the queen hits the king
the Knight hits The Rook on H1 so I'm
just trying to keep count of all the
pieces on the right hand side and quick
note on the left hand side as Magnus
just made his move Fabiano is defending
this perfectly every square that Magnus
puts pressure on Fabiano has it covered
the H5 Pawn is defended the E6 Knight is
defended so Fabiano is doing everything
correctly on the left hand side and he
still has a minute on his clock but
Magnus is going to continue try to
squeeze water out of stone there with
the bishop versus knight complex pawns
on both sides of the board he's going to
play this on Fabby down to a minute he
needs to keep those defenses up can nbec
find the big check here and he decides
to go with Knight F2 uh attacking that
Rook first question where are you moving
with your king you got to slide to the
right or you got to slide back and he
slides back to C1 a safe square and
White's Rook disappears in the corner
I've got to say all the drama is
happening on the board between Wes Leo
and abdor it's one of the craziest games
you'll ever see new porns promoting
halfway through a game Rooks
disappearing in the corner we do a
material count we see suddenly it is
almost level white is up a cor after all
of that mess but the attack continues
against the white king potentially and
the black king is really not that safe
either because if you could imagine the
C3 Pawn on the right hand side of your
screen that was thrown off the board
that Bishop on B2 it's just lurking back
there and there could be threats but I
think that not can just take this Knight
on G3 the pawn will recapture and the
queen can take that pawn it's becoming
messy the material will be even but I
like nbe's clock the most no that was a
that was a dgt error there's no way
Wesley would push upon instead of
recapturing that sometimes happens and
look that Bishop's alive I love that
last move by Wesley he pushes the SE
pawn it doesn't aim at queening or
moving forward but it's all to activate
that Bishop on B2 which to me is a very
scary piece I don't care what the evalar
says that Bishop on B2 eyeing that black
king on G7 I'd be Ved in this position
yeah Wesley forgot to play B3 on move
one fing King his d square Bishop but
finally now on move 28 he's activated
that Beast that monster that Archer uh
that sniper from afar that white Dart
Square Bishop is the most valuable piece
right now but it's all about the checks
it's all about the mutual attacks and
black king steps forward hiding out in
the open on a light square and Wesley
drops back with his Rook whose King is
weaker it's so difficult to tell the
players are now down under the
two-minute mark this one is chaos it's
going in any direction what a move from
no Deb abusar King up to G6 I was not at
all looking at that I think he can just
steal this Pawn on F3 and then he can
always block a check on the gfile with
his Knight so I believe that not Beck
can he can take the pawn F3 get a bit
closer to the white king and what a
brave decision by him he gives a check
instead did we see him move that was
Magnus Carson I think he's still
thinking about it I was thinking give a
check and get the Queens off the board
your king is on G6 if NC Abdu satov he
can grab a pawn he can give a check he
chooses a third option he doesn't care
his king is up in the open he's going
for the C Pawn Wesley rightly sidesteps
any checks on the sea line moves away
and nbec goes Pawn hunting no Queen
trades he's a pawn up nobec here adds
black both Gams are equally weak right
now but black also has two pass porns on
that board Abdus satoro I think he's a
big favorite the black H porn will just
start running meanwhile the Magnus
Carson versus Fabiano Carana board still
Level still Magnus trying to probe away
for weaknesses still looking to dominate
the Black Knight with the white Bishop
but wow W so let's focus on this one
right because that's where the money
matches oh my goodness Queen G7 check is
the thr that Knight cannot capture the
queen that's why Wesley slid his King to
the corner so the black queen can't
deliver a useful check and I think that
for n he to bring his Rook back he does
just that that H Pawn is really
dangerous it was a one check threat that
has been stopped nik's about to run that
pawn up the board and this is White's
moment to try to perhaps get more pieces
into the attack that Knight on A3 only
if it lands on the king side it will
give Wesley the chances that he needs
and he starts with his journey Knight B5
heading to the center of the board with
Knight D4 coming in wow the computer the
evaluation bar might say that black is
better Abdu sator has the advantage but
in Practical terms the white king
suddenly safe in the corner and Wesley I
think he's got great chances of turning
around both players around the 42 Mark
and uh now big threat against White's
Rook he gives a check first Wesley so
but the bishop can block it Brave check
there forcing the White Queen into the
corner and meanwhile on the other B the
evaluation bar shoots up Magnus Carlson
is he winning can Magnus trade off the
Rooks he's one upon PA Magnus Carlson
karan's defenses are cracking yeah the
Rooks are gone and that's an extra pawn
it can run up the board so while all
attention was on Nordy Beck's board
suddenly Magnus Carlson steals a pawn
and I think he's going to win game three
just do not play Magnus Carlson in end
games it is bad news and he does it he
creates his magic but let's focus on the
right side of the board right now Rook
to E8 Queen E4 putting that Queen back
on H1 by Wesley so to me that was a
really surprising call well Danny knows
all about that playing the scotch and
then you're getting your queen stuck on
H1 so Danny there's your shout out but
right now n dearbeck deserves a huge
shout out the way he's been playing and
Wesley's down under 10 seconds wow this
is dramatic stuff Wesley needs to keep
the momentum alive he Forks the black
rook and black Bishop the black Bishop's
defended however and Abdu satov bit more
time on the clock he'll just move his
Rook out the way meanwhile Magnus Carson
has gone two pawns up on his board on
the left board we're seeing right now
it's the final stages Magnus is going to
win but what about the other one so much
drama I think it's the final stages of
that one as well as the players are down
to seconds absolute chaos is the black
king going to March up further on the
board but you have to stay connected to
that H5 Pawn what is nbec thinking about
is he going to capture the bishop on B2
wow he does it and Checkmate within two
moves is threatened Abdu satov going for
the white king now Wesley keeping things
alive with a nasty move what a sick move
from Wesley on the right hand side that
Rook looks like it's free but if you
take that Rook Knight back to H4 with
check we're seeing a repetition I don't
think not has better Wesley so what a
find Rook togu that has to be the move
of the day but right now 3 seconds and
he captures the night not is going for
it he doesn't repeat because that's not
an option on the table wow nck a draw
and a loss is the same thing so he keeps
the game alive he doesn't repeat but now
it's a material imbalance white has a
rook meanwhile okay Magnus does take the
win in his Game Pass Pawn running
through but Wesley has a rook for
Black's Knight and two pawns that one
anything could still happen our
remaining game and look at that not Beck
throws his Pawn even further please take
my Pawn your Rook is hanging on J wesy
down under 5 seconds he slides his Rook
to help defend his Queen but those pawns
are looking awfully scary o and another
check the white king advancing I've
never seen two kings do more exercise
more work than they have in this game
still black on the attack and his King
advances as well and the pawns keep
rolling down the board n back with the
determination is going for it he does
give a check is he going to pick up the
C4 Pawn as well well it stays defended
with the King moving back nbec has to
find a way to start pushing those pawns
look how visibly nervous both players
are on the camera both shaking back and
forth Wesley fiddling with pieces Queens
off the board it's a race it's a pawn
race those black pawns are really quick
but look how quickly Wes is going after
the B7 Pawn if he can grab that he's a
passer of his own and nbe said he
believes Wesley Shak in time trouble and
there it goes and blunder White's King
going back White's Rook taking a pawn
but Black's pawns are too strong black
can push the E Pawn perhaps right now
black can give a check with the Knight
first he's running through he's
promoting he's going to make a new Queen
not a back on the brink of victory in
this one but he's got only 5 Seconds to
make it happen and now he can promote
can he go E1 Pi up The Rook he he can
and but he's worried the the white Pawn
will also go and promote so he keeps the
Knight on E5 to cover that C6 Square I I
think that was a great Try by nck here
and Wesley was stuck Wesley had no good
moves the white porn kept under lock and
key and O some drummer there touching a
pawn Abdus satov but he drops his KN
back is he going to be able to break
through the white Rook White's Rook is
holding two Pawn simultaneously and N
making moves with just a second on the
clock gains some time gives a check now
but if he goes back that could be a
third time repetition but if he goes
Knight F3 Knight G1 he gets the queen
with check so the white Pawn steps
forward twice but black queen first wi
check and here it comes he's found it
he's found the winning idea and Wesley
knows it yeah frustration from Wesley so
and resignation from Wesley so what a
fantastic game I've never seen anything
like that NCA dusro scores a win with
the black pieces and he can't believe it
we can't believe it what a
game what a game the players discussing
this is nice to
see there really are no words but
somehow these players are talking about
the game yeah I think they're analyzing
so many critical moments and you can see
them pointing at the board and they have
got a round to play I think they're
discussing the end game the final stages
could white have saved the
game it looks like notak found some way
to actually convince Wesley of his
Advantage there and they've got a fourth
game coming up and we have got a match
on our hands oh my goodness no dearbeck
Abdus atar he brought the heat Wesley
was so close to surviving found a
brilliant tactic by stepping his Rook up
but just what a gain from no de up duara
unreal The Chosen One Strikes Back
taking the match to the fourth game and
NC has to do it again to go into
Armageddon meanwhile Magnus Carlson as
well bounces straight back after that
loss to Fabiano Carana in classic Magnus
style yeah Magnus grinding away we
didn't pay that game as much love as we
would like to to have done but Magnus
essentially doing Magnus things it was
equal for most of it but in the end just
broke down eroded uh car's defenses yeah
it was all eyes on nbec Abdu satov it
just
unbelievable stuff unbelievable tactics
a complete roller coaster David yeah a
roller coaster one of the most uh just
up and down crazy most fun Wild Games
you'll ever see in chess and it was
those two fantastic Warriors Wesley so
nbec Abdu I Want To Praise Black's
decision just in the next couple of
moves here nybeck in a must-win
situation decided not to retreat and
take this white knight maybe the most uh
kind of rational decision right now
instead he went for chaos Rook takes
Bishop threatening to take this Pawn
followed by a swift Checkmate on the
white king and Wesley found a crazy
defensive move deciding to block on the
second rank control the black queen
because this Rook is poisoned if you
ever take it you walk into a nasty shock
the night Fork on the king and queen
nybeck here he took a pawn with check he
gave another check with the black rook
and ultimately he decided okay I have to
gamble after another check he took the
White Knight we saw a crazy material
imbalance and later down the line nbec
was rewarded for his courage in playing
on the Black Knight and porns combined
turned out to be superior to White's
Rook just unbelievable we've been
talking about NC's Steely stairs but
that looked like nerves of steals to
allow white to keep that Knight and
queen with the King out in the open I'm
just thinking about the chest that we
witnessed on that game but meanwhile
Magnus just outclassing Fabby in that
end game yeah there were too many
weakness unfortunately for fabbi on a
Carana he had split pawns his opponent
had a bishop staring in both directions
and fabbi was doing so well covering all
of his bases but without time on the
clock it's hard to cover the left and
right hand side of your boards and
Magnus he was relentless he was able to
First grab a pawn then a second and then
the
game and he did just that and with that
that he levels the score which means
Fabby has to now do it all over again to
take it to set three Fabby needs to win
the final rapid game he does it's going
to be difficult to come back from that
but if we just dive into the specifics
of that game that we just saw Magnus
Carlson he did his vintage stuff there's
a Pawn on B5 that's under attack there's
a Pawn on H5 that's under attack the
Knight can't go in both directions it's
not a bishop if that Knight were a
bishop then it could actually defend
both of the pawns unfortunately the
Knight has to choose where to defend if
it defends the queen side then The Rook
slides right back over across the board
to H4 it picks up the H5 Pawn that's
what happened and Magnus first won the
H5 pawn and unfortunately for fabbi he
was not able to recover this is beyond
hope at this stage classic Magnus
Carlson Going Back to Basics this is how
he kind of rose up uh within the chest
scene originally just grinding down his
opponents tiring them out in almost
level positions and unfortunately for
Fabiano there's not much you can do
against the best player of all time in
these types of positions yeah sometimes
I look at and just wonder how does he
play chess so well in these end games
that many of us would just agree to a
draw or bail out of he really gets the
job done just literally squeezes water
out of stone I don't know how the guy
does it but he does it time and time
again and we've got a big four game
coming up and both Fabiano Carana and
nbec Abdu satov have to win on demand to
take it into the Armageddon and there's
big chest coming up and there are big
things coming up for our subscribers
nonsubscribers subscribe what are you
waiting
[Music]
for I'm here with well two of my
favorite people in the whole world this
is Baby Max attending his first ever
chess tournament and this is Mike kly
known as fun Master Mike who actually
taught me a little bit of Chess we met 9
years ago at the sinkfield cup my first
ever chess tournament it's so good to
see you again Mike you too I know I had
to do some handholding at that
tournament but I think you've gone on to
be the real Pro so now you're kind of
showing me around and thank you for
putting me in company with your son I
don't think I'm quite equal to him but
uh I'm glad to see the Next Generation
yeah look at that he's very interested
in in looking at you as well oh yeah
that's a microphone Max and well so
going back memory line uh sinkfield Cup
2014 it was such a cool experience uh
obviously Fabiano Carana went seven in a
row that's very memorable but for me
also you gave me my first chess set you
taught me so much chess that was an
amazing experience for me Mike uh yeah
that's back when having Magnus on my
home soil in America was like a huge
thing um I have to also say I made one
of my biggest blenders of my
professional career at that tournament
really yeah Fabiano had won seven games
in a row and was about to be white
against Magnus in game eight and while
interviewing Magnus in my brain I wanted
to ask Magnus if he felt like maybe an
underdog he was playing a guy who was 7
and0 but I think I accidentally called
Magnus an underdog that did not go well
we've patched up our relationship we all
make
mistakes yeah I also did my first
interviews with with Magnus back then he
didn't like uh Fabby winning seven in a
row there are you peeking at the camera
yes and well now Mike you're known as
fun Master Mike it's all about teaching
kids chess for you right now yeah I've
kind of moved on from the chess
journalism world and mostly retired that
except for a couple of gigs uh I'm now
mostly the the face and the content
creator and the bizdev guy for chess kid
in fact I see a potential marketing
opportunity here can we get Max his own
little peska that's for you Baby Max oh
no that's not squeezable this is much
more fun do you have grasping yet now I
know you're teething I have no frozen
waffles but I do have this yeah oh it's
working Uncle Fun uncle funmaster oh
look at that and I can also kind he's
kind of a little bit more interested in
the microphone maybe he's GNA walk in my
foot yeah exactly there we go hold it no
no no Max you're going to be a chess
player don't take mom's job she's very
good at it but that's very kind Mike
thank you we going to have a a peska to
be biting on and Mike you have to tell
us a little bit about what's happening
with chess kids uh these days yeah so
we've got a big Festival coming up
February 16th to the 19th 20124
Charlotte North Carolina our first I got
to talk into that our first ever in real
life tournament we're going to have KY
we're going to have Gotham chess we're
going to have Danny me Jen Shah da nitki
if I forgot anybody because we invited
so many people so it's going to be a
chess event unlike any other there's
going to be a main competition we're
gonna have Jen shahadi hula hooping
we're gonna have Danny wrench doing a
puzzle B against Jen shahadi kids are
literally going to be able to throw a
pie in my face it is going to be fun
Festival family entertainment how can we
get tickets for this awesome event
actually you can just go on to
chesskid.com and there's all kinds of
articles about how you sign up for it
also just go search for chess kid
national festival we've done our job on
the Googles and you're going to find us
uh tickets are limited uh but it's going
to be uh I hopefully a groundbreaking
historic event wow sounds amazing Max
are you
going maybe a little too soon next year
we will be there definitely Mike thank
you so much and everyone go check out
the the chess kid Festival it doesn't
look like much but neither would a
Sicilian Defense to the untrained eyee
this is a performance enhancer you don't
see it how about now manage your air
quality sharpen your performance change
the game with air things a new opening
for your wall is here capture new major
pieces on unique metal posters from
displate now with the official
collection from chess.com Mount them in
seconds with a toolfree magnet kit and
swap them whenever you like make your
move get an exclusive discount on all
metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
and we are celebrating the holiday
season it's time to get smart and you
get a very very cool 20% off until
December 31st for the chess kid gold uh
go to the website go. chesskid.com /
ck20 it's all up in front of you use the
code use the command ck20 in chat for
all the details and you get a 20% off
and that's not all we're celebrating
we're also helping you decorate your
walls with these very very fun posters
that we've got and there are so many of
them on display.com you get a 33% off
with the code chess and you got three in
the studio which ones uh which one's
your favorite Robert you know I want to
get a Coe display is there a calculation
over everything display with James KY
just flexing out there I would get that
in har right now it's the Champions
chest or Finals over everything is we
got a big game four coming up David I
also know there's a grind like a grand
master displate there is go out get it
everyone you get my face on your walls
what more could you want uh I must admit
as well I haven't yet shopped for my
friends all my family for Christmas so I
know what I'm taking home later after
the show oh yeah well you can get yours
is on display.com chest so check it out
and right now we're going to check in
with Magnus Carlton who's taken the lead
in his set two against
Fabby Magnus Carlson is getting very
close to the final now and Magnus did
you feel confident throughout this
game
um not really uh I felt good about the
opening it felt that I had a slight bit
stable Advantage but I think he managed
to activate his pieces and then for a
moment uh for a while I was just moving
around but I was hoping that um his
expansion on the queen side would only
lead to weaknesses for for him so I was
sort of trying to provoke that a little
bit at some point and then yeah
eventually um eventually I managed to um
to win one of his pawns um even after
that it was not easy at all um but um
yeah managed to pull through how are you
feeling about the way you're playing
today actually not too bad
um yeah even the even the last game
where I was completely outplayed I
didn't I didn't feel that bad in general
I just he just played well I think and
this game yeah it was nothing special
but I think it was okay and a game four
now to secure your spot in the final so
what can we expect from that one well
it's an armor get in game where I have
15 minutes and increments so that's um
that's something
um good you expect this to go to
Armageddon no I'm saying that this is an
Armageddon game where I have 15 minutes
cuz I just need a draw but um you know
we'll we'll see I haven't managed to be
so solid so far so I'm sure it won't be
easy good luck in the next one armag
thank you thank you Magnus that's uh
back to you guys thanks gu it wouldn't
be easy but that end game Magnus did
make that look easy and he takes the
lead in his match which means that Fabby
with the the black pces like an
Armageddon which white has has to win on
demand uh as Magnus said he gets white
he needs to just he needs just a draw
it's all jumbled up right now but for
Fabby and nbec nothing's jumbled up only
one score suffices and that's a win they
have to win nck did just do that and
it's tougher for Fabiano because nbe's
feeling it he just played a great game
but for fabbi you feel like you just
collapsed you were holding on for dear
life for so long but when you're playing
Magnus Carlson so long isn't good enough
it has to be forever yeah different
mindsets for the two players now in
must-win situations Abdu satov he's on
the back of that great great Victory he
knows he has another life he won the
first match yesterday even if he loses
this next one who cares more chess today
but for Fabiano this could be the last
game of his tournament it's all or
nothing he has to burn his Bridges he
has to go all in against Magnus B faabi
starts with white and that gives him
some hope to try to get those positions
out of the opening what are you
expecting what kind of an approach is he
going to go solid wait for Magnus to
make those decisions or will he go all
out from the start whatever he did in
game two do that again because he had a
winning position against Magnus Carlson
he couldn't convert and I think that's
been the theme of his match yesterday
set one and today in set two he's had
winning positions he's outplayed Magnus
but Magnus will not back down he will
fight on forever and he will not lose
unless you punish him and beat him and
Donnie there with Wesley and a little
mascot uh Wesley
he lost game three he needs a draw to
take the match for nck with white he
starts he's got so many positives from
the way he just took down Wesley so in
that last game not back if he wins it
goes into the Armageddon in just a few
moments we will have the first move it's
really cool to see the players in such a
good move right before the start of a
critical game yeah maybe trying to get
some inspiration from mittens there
Wesley so uh from the mittens uh kind of
toy but a mittens plushy I think it was
a mittens plushy I was going to say
plushy but I've never literally never
said that word before in my life so I
didn't want the sound natural thank you
Robert and you can get your mittens
flushy but for now let's get into the
chess as we've got one D4 on the board
one D4 on the board and will we see a
repeat of a game from earlier today
Wesley so mixes it up he pushes a pawn
to A6 earlier two games ago we saw him
put a Pawn on E6 and despite winning
that battle that game Wesley so is the
first to surprise his opponent white
takes some space and if I'm not mistaken
this is called like the chameleon
variation because you're not exactly
making it known what your plans are
gakamsky has played this from the black
side for many many years with great
success it's a situation where white
expands on the queen side you see those
Pawn on C5 carved out some good dark
squares on that side of the board but
black will eventually try to strike back
either in the center with an E5 push you
want to break down a pawn chain you
don't want to allow someone to have a
connect for without fighting back so I
think that Wesley can strike with B6 or
with E5 depending on the moment he
understands the nature of these
positions yeah and things are getting
hot out there in Toronto especially hot
right now for Abdu satov and kowana and
uh is it getting warmer I see two red
rings there on the air things devices
the air quality uh getting uh really
dramatic for the players meanwhile on
the board Wesley he's well prepared he's
fast he's Furious he's uh probably
Furious about that last game that defeat
and he's now hunting down white Dart
squared Bishop the bishop on F4 will be
traded off within the next few moves and
to me it looks like opening success
Wesley
so uh for Wesley he does get that Bishop
air early on if white was to move it to
that square one step towards the right
will we see a kingside expansion by
Wesley in that case putting that Rook
Pawn 86 G5 in early on we definitely
will because in a closed position it's
not the worst thing in the world to
advance pawns where you're King may
eventually end up the King still is in
the center thus far so it's not like you
are forced to Castle to the king side
but for Nur he actually doesn't mind if
that Knight captures his Bishop because
white will have a true clamp in the
center one of the pawn breaks I
mentioned was E7 E5 if there's a pawn F4
and D4 good luck to you you're not
breaking through there it's going to be
a strategic battle in the opening in
this one while nbec thinks about what to
do with that Bishop situation let's
check in with our final fourth game
between the world number one and the
world number two Fabiano Karana needs to
strike in this game otherwise it will be
he will be knocked out of the Champions
Chester final and we see a repeat of
what we saw between these two earlier
yeah going back to his Italian Roots
Fabiano caruana he's playing the Italian
game and uh we saw this position as uh
Robert mentioned he's pretty much
sticking to what was almost a winning
recipe on the brink of victory in the
second game of of today and again
pushing his Pawn forward gaining space
on the queen side it's onus on Magnus
pressure on Magnus to switch things up
uh because it went wrong for black very
very quickly and here we see Magnus
still sticking to this tried and trusted
uh kind of idea of trading off Bishops I
really fear for Magnus Carlson unless
he's got something up his sleeve and
this is the moment that Fabby stopped
and he went shot Castle is he going to
switch it up is this when we get a new
move and we're talking about that game
two action we had this identical
position I think fabby's going to play a
new move now well I'm bit a bit
surprised that he goes down the same
exact path and now is the person who's
sitting and thinking because uh
Christian Trilla his good friend maybe
he looked at this and gave him a little
bit of advice but Fabby he's going down
the same path and yet he's not the one
who seemingly prepared so either he's
just trying to recall something or he's
just going to change it up on the Fly
there isn't much time between games to
be fair to the players but Fabby does
not count Castle he plays that pawn push
to C3 and creating a threat as well on
the board the Queen from D1 if it
arrives on B3 you will put pressure not
on one Pawn on B7 but two pawns the one
that has just been doubled up as well on
the center and Magnus literally doesn't
care he plays B5 anyway an idea we
debated in detail earlier today on pass
on or no on pass on um it does look like
it's forced in some positions but here
white can very much maintain the tension
if he desires why not just Queen B3 I'm
attacking B5 I'm attacking E6 because
the B5 Pawn Magnus saying is a bit
Untouchable because even when you
capture let's say the White Queen grabs
that pawn on B5 the black Rook will
slide one file over hit the queen and
the loose B2 Pawn behind it so this Pawn
can be won by white black will have to
defend the E6 Pawn but in doing so sets
up a rook B8 so the pawn on B5 is
actually protected just tactically
rather than directly and we were
surprised with this move B5 which
happened in game two between these two
not in this exact same position but a
similar one it looks like this is some
kind of a preparation by Magnus that
he's just decided to go into this
opening with this thematic idea of B5
and he's sticking to it what must have
happened is that in the break uh the
players they don't have too long they
have a few minutes here and there Magnus
got on the phone he called up his uh
good friend his second Peter H Nelson
what should I do and Peter's saying do
the same thing yes you had a bad
position later but your uh mistakes
weren't to do with the opening and uh
just stay loyal stick to what you know
don't burn too much time on the clock
and here we do see the switch up this
exact variation you mentioned with Queen
to B3 probably in that phone call Magnus
discussed it with a second and uh it's
Fabiano deciding now whether to go and
grab the pawn as uh Robert mentioned
Queen takes B5 White's Queen going up
taking the B5 Pawn would walk into a
skewer on the B file uh blacks Rooks
would switch across switch Focus kick
the White Queen away and who knows who
that profits Fabiana has to work that
out I think it's a little too direct and
I don't love what we're seeing here from
Fabiano he's going down the same exact
line and the first time you can be
surprised by this B5 now that it's
happened before I'm going to expect it
every time it's available black can play
B5 and what it really was doing is then
Knight on B1 it wants to Dart out to D2
and then up to C4 and saying you're not
even going to get there so Fabby brings
his Queen out attacks a pawn doesn't
takes it doesn't take excuse me instead
castles his King I feel like Magnus can
simply defend the pawn and he's doing
just a
okay and we see a decision there with
the kingside castle Magnus on the think
we are going to go to our crew in
Toronto Levy is joining us for more
insights Levy we got a very similar
opening as the one we saw between these
two players in game two Fabby a must-win
situation what do you think about what
we're seeing being played out will Fabby
be able to create his chances in this
one well it's not a matter of will he be
able to I he doesn't really have a
choice it's just is he going to go for a
long positional out grind type of game
or is he going to get frustrated at some
point and lash out but the truth is in
these E4 E5 these rues lashing out could
just be punished right I mean we're
looking at the game right now Magnus
applying some pressure with his Knight
there on the king side I don't know I I
I'm no expert in E4 E5 positions but if
you tell me you have to win this with
white it is it looks like a bit of a
struggle I don't know what are we
thinking uh we thinking he's going to
try to push D4 is he going to try to
reposition his Queen off of B3 it's nice
where it is it's pressuring E6 but it's
tough to add pressure I do believe he's
he's brought his Rook so is the idea a
knight F1 guys and then reroute the
Knight to the
center yeah and Levy before we Deep dive
I want to ask you because we were
discussing in the studio what the
players are getting up to between rounds
how are they preparing did you manage uh
do you have any update on that on that
for us uh have you seen the players
between rounds between
games yeah I've definitely seen them uh
there's only one way in an out which I
suppose is a bit of a fire hazard but we
do see all the players that we we see
them getting fair play scans uh nck and
Wesley are surprisingly chatty with each
other you know considering they're
playing for something like $50,000
either way that could go if one of them
makes it to the finals or not uh but
Fabiano just sort of comes out he's
always very chill it's actually quite
difficult to read if Fabby won or lost
you only kind of get a sense once he
starts analyzing he's sometimes
discussing games with with Maxim who is
here mvl uh and Magnus just sort of
maybe goes off refreshes and come back
and uh comes back but uh I mean there's
a lot on the line here and so they have
to gather themselves very quickly
whether they win or lose but now we see
Magnus is actually playing G5 on the
left side of the screen there so pause
that conversation and how do we feel
about this actually taking the fight to
Fabiano rather than sitting and waiting
I must admit Levy I quite like it for
black the uh Center for now is not quite
open so why not play on the side you're
stronger black has an KN on H5 semi-open
f file um and I will admit I'll make a
confession of my own Levy I spent a
bunch of time this morning watching one
of your YouTube videos about meeting
Magnus in person in the flesh uh can you
tell us about how that experience was
for
you yeah well I haven't had a chance to
uh actually meet uh David Howell In the
Flesh which I mean I mean once I do that
that I might just completely melt so we
got to we got to set that up at some
point David no it was super cool um and
I and I tweeted about it earlier today
or posted on X or however we call that
nowadays um it's uh it's Sublime for me
because you know four years ago I was
just a a chess teacher in New York City
and um okay I don't want to just you
know undermine that profession just the
chess teacher but that was I was
watching these tournaments as a
spectator and a fan and uh that sort of
never goes away uh also much taller than
I thought and if anybody chess boxes
Magnus they are going to have a serious
issue I I I get where all the hype from
and the athleticism uh claims come from
so that that was pretty cool um got a
little bit of a Gucci cologne spell no
I'm just making things up at this point
um back to the chess cuz you know we got
to focus here we've got a hanging Knight
on H5 in the Wesley so game and
meanwhile Magnus put his Knight on the
F4 Square so both these matches are
great I just have to say lot of tension
totally locked position on one side
and on the other side we've got I don't
know we got Magnus coming in with an
attack I
guess sorry goad DAV I was going to say
if you had to pick right now uh which uh
player you prefer on both boards Levy
who would it
be I really like Wesley's position I I
generally don't like being cramped like
the position ner backck has because you
have to time a Counterattack and that's
not a skill that I have at all plus you
have to play on the queen side in in
Wesley's game uh if if you're ner back
and uh I I really don't know how I feel
like being under kingside pressure and
well if I apply that same logic to the
left side I would rather play Black
obviously because you have the open f
file close Center good attacking chances
what about you guys yeah Levy I was
going to say on the left hand side of
our screen here Fabiano at least he has
an opportunity to initiate a pawn break
and I often say the side that controls
the pawn breaks is the side with the
advantage black has some Pawn breaks of
his own for Magnus Carlson he can push
his G Pawn to create more threats in
front of the white king but I I'm with
you that I feel like Nock that
position's too closed for my liking and
Wesley seems to be having all the fun
over there on the king side
oh absolutely actually why don't we pop
over to that game as uh Fabiano has to
make a decision there with magnus's Rook
on F4 we can take a look at uh nck
versus Wesley so that match has
gone uh I mean it's been a crazy back
and forth battle so Nock has just moved
his Knight we see Wesley has a critical
decision to make it's it's a weird
position guys right because Wesley has
to basically not lose this game that's
the reality cuz he's he's up 2 to one in
today's set so the position however is
demanding violence of the highest order
isn't that a really difficult tight RPP
to cross right because you know white is
going to play A4 B5 as we see these
beautiful blue arrows drawn there from
Oslo I am not doing that look at that
the F5 F4 very very tense position who
do we uh who do we favor I know computer
says black but computer's like 800
points higher rated than the highest
human so how are we feeling well uh the
computer normally loves Connect Four I
was going to say but the E4 Pawn
suddenly gets traded off on passant
apparently is forced but uh e takes F3
wow I'm not so sure about this one uh
for Wesley so as he clears his throat uh
Rook takes F3 Pawn takes Bishop
takes at least he's broken the head of
the pawn chain oh you couldn't pay me
money you couldn't pay me money to take
with the pawn but Bishop takes yeah now
a knight is coming to E4 I mean once
again I I'm just saying it's a situation
where Wesley has to not lose but he's
taking the fight to NRE I mean someone's
probably going to lose this game and
there's a chance it could be Wesley and
then it's two to2 and then we have to
play Armageddon for today's set so uh
but anyway I will let the uh I will let
you guys live broadcast in Oslo take it
away great listening to you thanks for
checking in with me thanks uh Levy we
will uh we will check in with you again
soon uh and I agree with him that you
know in this game Wesley needs only a
draw but he's going all out there's no
backing down from the position once
you've Advanced those kingside pawns
you've already declared war with G5 F5
on the board there's no way to go solid
or passive in this position and even if
Wesley it's Advantage Wesley at this
particular moment that's also in some
ways good news for nbec because he knows
that the position will open up there
will be opportunities for both players
to go wrong yeah well the power of the
dog was a great movie from Jane campy I
think the power of the Knight has been
the theme of this match we just saw nbec
Abdus win by blocking a rook with his
Knight so he could promote here that
night on D7 for black that's going to
hop right into the center Knight F6
Knight E4 you have forward progress
allowed for that Knight he start the
queen E8 you have an open diagonal
because the F Pawn has been pushed so I
feel like White's play A4 B5 this kind
of attack on the queen side it's really
slow and it might not amount to much
whereas black can actually throw pawns
forward as well F4 or G4 you have to
time these things correctly but with the
night Maneuvers with these Pawn pushes I
certainly like Black's chances I've got
to agree uh the top players in the world
they like space they like uh having
access to weak squares and that's
exactly what Wesley does right now and
yeah I'm loving your night maneuver
Robert I would take black here every
time and also ahead on the clock as well
uh for nck it will come down to having
those extra seconds because this
position will get very demanding and
will require a lot of calculation at
some point from both these players
Wesley looking really relaxed and chill
right now he we've been talking about
Wesley from the start is being this
extremely solid player is uh the hardest
to beat in the circuit doesn't take the
fight but waits for the fight to come to
him when you give him the opportunity he
takes it but this event the Champions
Chester final from the very start we've
been seeing a very different Wesley
we've seen him get aggressive without
being provoked well here I think he was
provoked a little bit because if he sat
passively he understands at this high
level that if you kind of just wait for
your opponent to do something you don't
have a plan of your own so he created
some plans he pushed his Pawns in front
of his King to force White's pieces back
and if he had given nybeck all the time
in the world we would have seen an
avalanche on the queen side that hasn't
even started yet there's not even a
snowball over there and on in the middle
of the board you see all the blacks
pieces and the Knights coming to the
king side I really like his position and
you know the position is one where he
kind of had to react and he's reacting
perfectly and quickly that's maybe the
most important element here yeah you can
tell how uncomfortable NC is here just
his clock consumption here his use of
the time it's really uncharacteristic
normally we see NC when he's confident
when he's on form just blitzing out the
moves hustling his opponents on the
clock happy to play kind of uh kind of
not the best move but wanting to play it
quickly and here he's down three and a
half minutes he's retreating his Bishop
back where he came from I think
regretting the decision to take on F3
with his Bishop now he wants to park it
on D3 but either way nbec is suffering
if you give him the chance to turn the
board around and take blackside I think
he would every day of the week so Abdu
satov right now needing a miracle to uh
win this game he puts the bishop on D3
but Black's Knights are coming in
Black's pawns are coming forward King
side the right half of the board black
is dominant well swapping colors isn't
an option so n has to try to create
something out of what he's got right now
uh the one the one positive in the
position for white is that there are
still a lot of pieces on the board very
few trades have happened very few things
have been simplified so far and even if
Wesley is in Drive seed I'm I'm going to
say this again that this position when
it does explode because Wesley has
expanded the king side I think it does
have potential to go in NC's favor as
well at some point it does and I think
if notbe can successfully push his pawns
up the queen side that's how he get
chances he's got no play no activity no
threats until he does just that and we
know he will and that's why Wesley he
just can't sit around all day he's going
to try to improve his pieces uh maybe
he's going to push his H Pawn like David
said maybe he'll just bring his Knight
up to that E4 square that was vacated
when he took on pasan but no matter what
he needs to play in the center of the
board here I don't believe in the
queenside pressure that even if you get
A4 and B5 in for white just feels a bit
slow and let's remind everyone if nck
wins this game this match goes into
Armageddon if it ends in a draw or in
Wesley's favor Wesley gets the set and
we will move on to set three between
these two players and of course uh
there's also Fabby who is fighting to
stay in the Champions Chester final
against Magnus Carlson he needs a win in
his uh in his game and he plays with the
white pieces this is the current
position and at first side you see that
blacks Rook magnus's Rooks have lined up
on the file and whenever that happens in
these Spanish in these Italian positions
there's always this sacrifice on F3 that
comes into my mind you're always
thinking about Rook takes nine blow open
White's King all of wh's army is on the
queen side very few defenses uh Magnus
right now preparing for it he goes H5
he's preparing for a G4 that's coming up
I would say there are big threats on
Fabby right now in this current position
big threats and I just want to point out
as well a small trap that Fabiano did
set at least for Magnus on the last turn
he dropped his KN back looks like a
blunder o free porn up for grabs but
White's Queen would have slid back this
was a poison pawn and suddenly Black's
Rook finds itself awkwardly placed If It
Moves if it shifts out the way White
Queen pounces and sneaks in Behind Enemy
ranks this would have been Advantage
white but Magnus Carson yeah H5
motioning down the board push those
pawns and it's because the center is
blocked that he's able to do this Robert
mentioned this earlier when the center
is blocked you can advance on the flanks
uh at will and right now yes there's
tension between these two pawns but
Fabiano never really wants to release
that ion because even in an end game
black has the advantage black here has
full control weak Pawn to look at
massive pressure down the file F2
hanging Black's Knight coming in this
would be almost over oneway traffic at
least uh so H5 Fabiano has to be really
creative to stem the tide G4 looks so
ominous right now I would quickly be
playing a move like Rook to D2 right now
because I see G4 is coming and if you
play G4 now I swap off pawns then move
my knight probably back to H2 and that g
E4 pawn it does stick out there's not
another Pawn to defend it so I'm not
sure if black can ever take on e4 so
that is something that you have to keep
an eye on but I do believe this gives
white legitimate chances T was asking in
the game between nybeck and Wesley is
there some long-term potential for
nybeck I don't see it in that game but
here I do see it for Fabby because
that's an isolated Pawn there's so many
tactics up in the air the black king
isn't perfectly safe either so I think
that with White's position solidifying
he will then be able to turn it around
it's uh really interesting to me that
Fabby is uh almost touching the
two-minute mark because as we've been
pointing out G4 is such a big threat on
the board you can't possibly give up
that F2 Pawn you have to defend it but
are there some tactics is there another
creative way to go into the offense
because if not Rook D2 you play it
really quickly yeah maybe this is just
symptomatic of Fabiano not being
confident not liking his position uh
I've been there so many times in my
career I hate my position even if
sometimes there's a forced move or one
move that's clearly superior to the rest
you just sit there kind of wallowing a
bit down philosophizing and he has to
just speed up play Rook D2 defend this
Pawn okay he plays Knight to E3 wow
provoking G4 he's actually going for a
similar idea to you mentioned uh Robert
there Knight to H2 he wants to actually
forfeit this Pawn in return for the G4
G4 Pawn to activate his Knights and
actually I quite like this idea um if in
the current position black ever allows a
pawn capture and the White Knight to
pounce into D5 suddenly there's actually
access squares so Fabby spent a long
long time in that move maybe too long
but he did in the end find a creative
idea and uh I like the fact that it's
not too submissive either it's not
reacting to Black's threats it's uh
trying to leap forward with his Knights
I prefer his move for sure not just
because he's the person making it
because it's ambitious and he's just
trying to create an imbalance and that
G4 push that we keep talking about white
does lose a pawn very close to his King
but he actually steals a pawn that's
getting closer to the black king and
with lines opening up with pawns being
being removed from the board we may just
see this very variation that with pawns
being removed that means that there more
open lines more chances to trade some
pieces and if you take this G4 Pawn
white has the outermost pawn and why
that's important as we get fewer pieces
on the board having a distraction a
decoy and far away from the other flank
that can be very very useful in an end
game yeah really nice move that creative
idea from Fabby and I think this wasn't
on magnus' radar we were struggling to
see it as well but he's found a creative
way to keep the balance but uh by
playing actively often if you have a
choice between active passive moves if
they uh both look roughly level play the
active one put your opponent Under
Pressure surprise them and one more move
by with the white Knights taking the
black G4 Pawn off the board serious
threats against the black king you can
tell on the body language Magnus a bit
frustrated and uh just a bit bemused
perhaps because he must have loved his
position until this last uh this last
last little sequence yeah Fab is
definitely dragged the Magnus into
complications in this one with this uh
creative resource that you were talking
about very difficult to find but we've
seen him do that time and time again in
this match moves like Queen B4 earlier
in their set one and Magnus is going for
it he takes the F2 Pawn he's giving the
G4 Pawn the one thing in magnus's favor
is that it's very difficult on that left
side of our screen for Fab's major
pieces the queens and The Rook to
transfer over to the king side so he's
got some time to try to get Harmony
within his own pieces before the queen
and the Rook I think C4 is a big threat
for white it absolutely is we're talking
about the left hand side he takes with
the E3 Knight that's actually bit
counterintuitive usually you like to
capture with your less active piece
pieces closer to your own territory but
he's opening up the third rank for Tanya
C4 push and the queen sliding on over to
G3 ignoring the queen side so watch out
Magnus Carl in some trouble on the left
and the right hand side it's more of the
same Wesley so he's played a perfect
game thus far far with the black pieces
he's just opened up a diagonal from his
Queen towards that E3 Pawn he's blasting
open the white king side not down to 2
minutes 24 seconds tick tick tick tick
he just doesn't have time and you see
the Eva bar all the way up now wow Abdus
soro's position is collapsing in front
of our very eyes simply the white King
on the right board there is going to
come under heavy fight Wesley so quick
so confident Retreats Black's Knight two
monster threats firstly to eliminate
White's Bishop in the center of the
board secondly to attack White's H Pawn
nobec is not long for this world his
dark squares are falling apart Wesley
playing aggressively but also keeping
all the Strategic points under control
in this position n back in big trouble
on the position with a big threat of
losing that H4 Pawn also down on the
clock uh and for Wesley with black he
has made it look easy in this game so
far never in trouble out of the opening
nbec did not even manage to get that a
pawn up the board creating a potential
threat on the queen side while all hell
breaks loose on the other side of the
board it looks terrible for n Beck and
he knows it and it's sort of the
opposite of game three where narbeck he
was just waiting and Wesley was playing
this very ambitious provocative chest
that completely backfired here n had no
choice he needs a win in this game he
couldn't just play quietly make a draw
and say that's okay he needs to win to
take the set head to the finals but it
looks like Wesley so is about to take
this one and that means we'll have a
reset a third set for all the marbles to
get to the finals and we'll talk more
about the format of the third set later
right now Wesley needs to finish the job
that he started and is well on his way
so we see a trade on F4 which opens up
the e-line for counterplay but is
counterplay going to happen with the H
Pawn falling and not just the H Pawn
falling the G Pawn potentially moving
forward and checkmating ideas on NC's
King yeah White's King is doomed it's as
simple as that he's trying to create
some Escape squares here nbec Abdu
satoro wh King will try to run for the
hills but unlike Wesley so King in the
previous game it's not going to get very
far and uh I think we'll shortly see a
checkmating pattern occur on that board
but uh yeah Wesley so he's done
everything right we're guaranteed more
chests no matter what the result in that
match at least what's funny about the
position on the right side he does bring
his Knight in I was going to say he's up
a pawn so even if he doesn't deliver a
Checkmate he can just plant a knight
into the E4 Square clog up that lane and
if that Knight's ever captured on e4
because checkmates will be threatened
The Rook on f8 suddenly stares into the
white position it looks really really
bad in the right hand side from nir
abdar in the left hand side Magus
Carlson's Frozen he's under three
minutes on the clock because that Queen
on B3 that left-and side Queen it's
going to slide on over the same line as
the enemy King and that's going to spell
some serious danger for Magnus and
that's not the only thing he needs to
worry about that pawn on A5 can become a
big Thor in magnus's position if he
allows Fabby to capture on B5 suddenly
Fabby will have an A5 pass and we've got
a result coming
in WoW Wesley so it looked like they
spoke to each other it was a draw Wesley
offers a draw in a totally winning
position because that secures him this
set of the match and Wesley gets it done
there was no hope in NC's position he
accepts the draw with this gepon moving
forward with NC's King Under Fire he
takes the draw which means there will be
a set three between these two players
and to me it looks like Fabby has made
great progress Robert you pointed out
that the Queen's sliding on from the
queen side to the king side I'm looking
at that A5 Pawn if Magnus allows that
trade I think that's one more thing to
worry about for black and he doesn't
allow it he was choosing between two
evils either he goes and protects his
king or he allows an a pawn to be passed
with few black pieces to stop it so this
queen it can take a pawn back on C4 I
would not be caring about material
Fabiano doesn't he slides it over to G3
and if he could get a rook to the H file
it's going to be a lad Checkmate so if
Fabby could bring his Knight to F3 King
to F2 Rook on over to H1 that's actually
going to be a check I don't know if he
has time for it but I'm already looking
at that direction yeah look at that
black king magnus's king sitting on the
edge of the board literally has no
shelter around it uh the black king
drops back of course Fabiano won't
repeat the position but it feels like
there should be a knockout punch the
white Rook can come up via A3 G3 the
third rank is totally open as well I
love that idea David Rook A3 Rook G3
looks extremely strong here maybe
there's something even better Black's
Rook on F4 so short of squares feels
like Fabiano on the verge of a knockout
punch and it's no surprise you need
Pawns in front of your king it's as
simple as that in chess and Black's King
has zero right now the might of the
White Queen and the white Knights
leaping forward should be decisive
Fabiano he has kind of lost control of
with a position similar to this before
though that's the one doubt in the back
of his mind but I love that Rook A3 Rook
G3 maneuver because Rook lifts are
always fun but especially when the black
king has no Pawns in front of it and
little has separated these two players
historically in match play their world
championship in 2018 12 draws in classic
chess Rook A3 here Rook G3 next the king
it just doesn't have pieces to defend it
beautiful awareness from Fabiano and
Magnus looks like he's not just in
trouble I think he's toast and it's so
easy to forget get about these Rook
lifts cuz you're focused on one side of
the board you're looking at ideas of
improving your knight getting that into
play going Knight F3 and then suddenly
from the other side of the board this
reinforcement a really big reinforcement
into the attack and now Fab's one move
away that Rook lands on the G file and
Magnus could be busted yeah we know
Fabby loves going to the gym he loves
working out yesterday was leg day today
is Rook lift day and he's lifted that
Rook yeah it's simply three four
attacking pieces for white I'm going to
count both those white Knights because
they mo they most likely will play A
Part soon the White Queen and with the
added spice of that white Rook against
the naked black king how can you fight
off uh that amount of
ammunition even if we calculate
variations I'm struggling to see a way
for black to cling on and even if the
evaluation bar wasn't through the roof
saying white is objectively winning with
less than a minute on his clock how do
you defend a position like this I know
look at Magnus he's looking away he's
pretty much giving up he's shaking his
head he knows he is lost oh my gosh but
he's going to fight he's not going to
give up at this very moment I think the
biggest problem in magnus's position is
what you want to do is you want to get a
rook on the G file but Rook F7 isn't
even possible because there was a check
on 86 forking the rook and the king so
no way to get the Rook into the defense
he tries to block it with the bishop
after Rook does slide over to G3 I think
Magnus wants to bring the Knight over in
front of the Rook to defend that Bishop
on G5 I think that white can even there
just win a piece quite simply you can
always throw in like a rook G3 Knight H6
check and Black's position is collapsing
so Rook G3 is step one if he does go
Knight F7 I actually think Knight H6
check just ends the game so he blocks
with his queen that way well Knight H6
is still there I does that work I think
Knight H6 is strong but Magnus does love
giving up his Queen in general and the
number of times He suggests giving up
his Queen in analysis it's uh it's crazy
I think Fabiano doesn't want to cash in
too soon for an attack that's worth more
and uh Knight 86 check is not going away
anytime soon first he's just going to
eliminate that Bishop that black Bishop
I think the problem is that black is
frozen Magnus Frozen on the camera
Black's pieces are stuck the attack is
incoming it's all about the G file and
black is collapsing under 20 seconds now
he gives up material to fight against
the threat on the G file he's trying to
run away with the King but the threats
in the G file continue because that
Bishop on G5 is still on the pin I don't
even know where that King thinks it's
going I guess E7 but that's not going to
run all the way to the queen side if you
could lift that King up and then
teleport it to a squore like B7 maybe it
starts to feel safe but that's a long
journey away mag is doing the right
thing though his Rook on f8 it coulds
slide on over to the H file and maybe
the white king could feel a bit of the
heat for now Fab has everything under
control he's also doing really well in
the clock and he just needs to put
Magnus away which he couldn't do two
games ago yeah and he has to be careful
about that because exactly with the
white pieces in game two in a winning
position there were a few imprecise
moves made and Magnus was all over in
that game then uh so for Fabby he needs
to still finish the job he's up in
exchange to me it would make a lot of
sense to just draw back with the Knight
and try to capitalize on the pin along
the G file Knight F2 would be the move
of my choice here because I also stopped
the check on E3 is there another way to
probably just with a stronger blow here
right now I like it Tanya you've done
the hard work you've won material white
is up a rook for Bishop so why not just
create smaller threats why not regroup
your pieces um I think you don't
actually need to do anything too special
there might might be stronger moves
might be more direct moves but
ultimately Fabby needs to play quickly
the only time it's gone wrong for him is
when it gets super messy he loses a
little bit of control and he has no time
on the clock so just keep the time
Advantage the win should be relatively
straightforward if you play moves such
as Knight F2 he's about to decide he
reaches out for the Knight and it's on
the board and one thing I'll note that
if the Queens do come off and maybe
Queen H6 for black at least you're not
getting checkm for mag you have a bishop
and one Pawn for that Rook so there is
quite a lot of material and he's I think
about to go for this I don't think the
task is that simple for Fabby if the
Queens come off and the thing when
you're playing against magnus's you have
to be so precise even when you're ahead
in material we've seen Magnus turn
around in this very match itself in this
against Fabby itself and it looks like
this is a big brunda can he is there I
was going to say Rook takes Bishop but
Queen takes Rook is with a check yeah
the problem is there's a pin on the G
file black is also collapsing on the
other flank Fab's now going to INF on
the SE line and actually the E6 Pawn is
hanging with the check wow Magnus is
really really Fallen apart these last
few moves it was lost anyway but this is
really bad but what a smart thing Fab
did he put his Rook on C1 in The
Bishop's line of sight it couldn't be
captured because the queen was behind
now he's taking this Pawn the Knight has
to move the Knight moves the Bishops off
that's a resignation and that's a tide
match that's a tide match that goes into
Armageddon as Fabiano caruana does it he
Strikes Back leveling their score and
this one goes into sudden death which
Fabby needs to win to stay alive to take
it into set three but he will be feeling
confident Fabiano caruana right now he
is a wow One of a Kind beating Magnus
Carson so many times and did you see
that David Magnus he was so angry on the
screen he can't believe it that he
didn't finish this off well do you know
why he's angry cuz Fabby hasn't beat him
not once not twice but Thrice in these
last two days in Rapid chess the only
thing separating the is that armagedon
game yesterday I'm curious what their
bids will be today yeah Magnus will he
be confident taking black yet again
after experiencing that nightmare in the
previous game Fabiano crushed him wiped
him off the board with that Killer
attack Magnus Carlson is an angry man
right now and he's angry with himself
with what he's let happen he has to
fight it out in the Armageddon right now
and he's got to forget about what has
just happened wow that's going to be an
exciting battle but Fabby he really kept
his nerves in those final moments and
wrapped it up as quickly and precisely
as he could and this is where we are
Wesley so Strikes Back Against ANC Abdu
satov will take it to set three and
Magnus Carlson has to win the Armageddon
to go into the final if Fabby wins that
one goes into set three as well Fabby
needs to take this one in Armageddon I
think the reason why Magnus he so just
displeased himself is not because he
blunders because Fab's just outplaying
him and Fabiano may be the only player
in the world right now who can take down
Magnus in these series of games like
this it's going to be an exciting battle
to watch World number one and world
number two in the sudden death spit for
Wesley so it was a quick uh quick match
he took it he did not need the
Armageddon and he was impressive David
with the black pieces yep Wesley so
impressive in this last game and with
black never looked in doubt the way he
closed it out as well really really
cynical and it was in this position
where we were talking about Black's
Advantage we were talking quite
theoretically here we were saying okay
black has a space Advantage black has
these beautiful pawns clamping down on
the center but it's also the fact that
the black pieces have swarmed towards
the king side and here he broke through
Pawn to G4 opening up this black Queen's
diagonal yes this Pawn is defended but
watch out for it later first of all
going for the white king and after H4
trying to plug the king side Wesley
simply took a calm step back opening up
an attack against the H4 pawn and also
trying to eliminate this key piece the
H4 Pawn now is doomed the piece was
traded off and actually Wesley Now by
infiltrating with his Queen and then
bringing his Knight in could have gone
on to win this game but here a draw was
agreed if black had wanted to Black
could have played on the idea of G3 and
bringing the queen in would have been
powerful and just a decisive Advantage
ultimately though a draw was enough and
Wesley was happy to offer one and not
never got off the ground in that match
his pawns they were stuck because black
had this clamp Wesley played really well
in that game to seiz the initiative the
upper hand and a pawn and in the other
game the way Fabiano Carana played I
mean so brilliant the it looked like he
was the one under attack but he was able
to strike back and in this position it
looks like the black king is unsafe the
white king not feeling too safe either
but you need more pieces in the attack
and C4 was a great strike because that
queen wants to head on over to the king
side and not just that if you just try
to put all your your piece Defending
Your King C takes B5 is a huge threat
trying to get an outside pass Pawn that
black will not be able to stop so Magnus
took the pawn on C4 the queen was able
to slide over to G3 and after a few
moves Magnus was forced to give up his
Rook for a knight because he couldn't
stop all of the threats and with the
extra material Fabiano was able to
convert quite
handily yeah beautiful win Fabiano I
love The Rook lift followed well
actually the queen lift first of all
just swinging across the board Fabio did
everything methodically just and kind of
turned it into a decisive material
advantage at the right time Magnus
barely got a chance in that game just
Flawless play from White yeah just
amazing chest there start to finish by
Fabby in that game with the white pieces
and he gets the win and he breaks the
Magnus spell and we saw Magnus react
when that game finished while he was
sitting down to put in his bids and look
at that he is just maded himself for
what he let happen on the board David
how's your Norwegian what do he say um I
will not say it it's it's a kid friendly
show here but it wasn't nice what Magnus
was saying to himself there and uh he's
frustrated more chess for him is not
what he wanted yeah and if Fabby is able
to get the job done in the Armageddon it
will go down to set three so we've got a
big big fight coming up between these
two you don't want to close your eyes
you don't want to miss a thing as it is
sudden that it is the Armageddon and
Fabiano kaana can he finish the job that
he started with his win in round four
against the world number one these two
face off in
[Music]
armagan oh my God I can't believe it we
are here with Gotham chess he's our
headliner VIP at the chess kid Festival
yeah that's you and I just found out
he's going to be streaming from the VIP
room are you saying there's a chance I
could be on your stream no
no not not not you but the kids the kids
can be on my stream Mike and that's
what's important oh man I guess I got
too old for this event I'll be there but
if you're a kid in elementary or middle
school you get a chance to be on the
biggest stream in all the land Gotham
are you worried any of these kids are
going to come for your
job uh maybe one day but I have over 4
million subscribers so you guys got to
start today practice up chess kids you
may just get to be on Gotham chess's
stream sign up for the Gotham chess VIP
package and we'll see you at the chess
kid national
[Music]
festival a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a tool-free magnet
kit and swap them whatever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things another one of the VIPs from the
chess kid national festival we have the
OG Papa Bear here I am Danny wrench and
he's going to be starting a very
Innovative concept what do you got yeah
I'm going to be facing off against
women's grandm Jennifer Shaha in our
first ever puzzle be we've actually been
excited about doing this for years and I
think it's going to become something
special so solving puzzles against Jen
let's go and what Danny doesn't know is
that we actually have a new prize we
have a golden peska we've been working
on this and the winner gets this peska
want to hold that guy yeah it's real
gold what is going on it's real gold my
friend was this in the budget I don't
know so it's worth a lot come find out
who wins the very first golden
[Music]
peska
take
[Music]
like
w
[Music]
[Applause]
and we're back in Toronto where all the
action of the Champions chestar finals
is happening and it's been a dramatic
week and it's a dramatic day of the
semi-finals as we've got a big
Armageddon Clash that is coming up for
day two we see Sports on our screen and
it's ice hockey and there is going to be
more chess coming up as well as Sports
Fever takes the city right now it's
Armageddon fever that's on and Ka is
with Fabby and Magnus revealing their
bids we have another Armageddon between
Fabby and Magnus you guys go ahead and
turn your boards to see those bids we
have 958
10 minutes okay that means black pieces
for you Fabby how do you feel about
that I don't know I've played so many
harmageddon I have no idea I'm just
happy to uh to have gotten back and I
promised Danny Armageddon so that's I
guess what we got super close uh bits
Magnus how do you feel about playing
with the white pieces here yeah it's
okay I mean obviously like losing out by
two seconds is not ideal but I had no
idea what to write so that's okay
armagon is coming up back to you guys
a smiling Fabby a not smiling Magnus
Carlson as Fabby does get the black
pieces and he beats Magnus with just a
two second bid and we are going to have
the first moves really quickly he beat
magnus's bid with two seconds has he
outsmarted Magnus to get black maybe but
will he live to regret having the black
pieces that's the big question the games
are
beginning five extra minutes for Magnus
Carlson could be decisive he needs to
win however Magnus with white plays the
Spanish it's the Spanish on the board
and we're going to quickly jump into
Toronto with Levy and James and their
thoughts on the bids we saw and the
opening that we are seeing right
now thanks Tanya yeah the opening
definitely a bit of a surprise I mean we
have some sort of weird uh we have an
open Spanish which I think is definitely
in Fabiano's wheelhouse I just want to
say something we were going to stand
here as commentators and say wow Magnus
bid 10 that was his max he knew Fabby
was going to bid 958 and then he said I
had no idea what's right it was funny
yeah you know I was going to be like oh
that's so so such a brilliant read by
and then he just goes yeah I had no clue
they have so little time to make that
decision that's true bro it's very quick
I mean and of course 958 usually you see
Magnus is the one that does it like
Magnus is the one that always outbid You
by one or two seconds here so Fabby may
have a little mental edge here you see
how Magnus was pissed basically you can
just tell this is not the friendly
Magnus right now he's trying to close
out and I do just want to say this open
Spanish as we're about to throw it back
there to Oslo for them again to the ex's
nose this is an open Spanish this is not
a closed Spanish white has black has
taken the pawn on e4 lots of theory here
so Fabiano despite the time disadvantage
is going to get to play a ton of moves
that he already knows 100% And then
after that it's just maybe three or four
critical decisions correct he might be
in good shape I think it's a great
choice as well open Spanish you get a
lot of moves in as Notre backck said
before when you're going to you know you
need to get get to like move 60s you get
that extra time and stuff like that so
this is going to be exciting especially
we have an open Spanish so yeah man we
might have we might have two tiebreaker
matches today all right hlo take it away
thanks guys uh James you're right no
increment until move 60 for the players
where they get after which they get a 1
second increment now Fabby gets the
result odds the draw odds starts with 9
Minutes 58 seconds on the clock and to
me that's a pretty good bargain yeah I
think he's done everything right in the
opening uh Levy and James there kind of
referred to it the open Spanish it's one
of the most forcing lines as well in
chess in general like fabul know he gets
black gets draw odds gets an opening he
knows in and out tension will be minimal
here it feels like everything's gone
right for him still early stages but uh
I'm loving what Fabiano has done with
the bid and with the opening FAO does
have one unhappy memory though on the
black side of an open Spanish and that
occurred in Madrid last year against
hikaro Nakamura it was an open Spanish a
forcing line a material imbalance five
Ando lost that game and with it his
chances at a world championship title
but we see in this game he is solid in
the center that Knight on e4 looks like
it's under attack but that just leads to
a series of exchanges that black is not
unhappy about and after Knight to D2
I've been wondering can at some point
black push the F Pawn that looks a
little bit risky maybe instead he should
put his Bishop out on F5 and it
resembles what nybeck and Wesley had in
their match this tension on the E4
square and to release that tension you
can trade pieces and you can start with
trading the knights and then put the
bishop on F5 as you suggested trying to
get rid of as many min minor pieces as
possible a draw would mean that Fabby
wins the match Magnus with white has to
create his chances
he has to but how he pauses now when the
most obvious recapture would be by
developing White's Bishop the white Dart
Square Bishop on C1 hasn't moved why not
take back this Black Knight but Magnus
he's looking for something creative
because at some point he'll need to
surprise Fabiano he'll need to switch it
up maybe hit him with a an kind of
shocking unexpected move and maybe he
takes with the queen to try and bring
the White Queen closer to the king side
but either way I still love Black's
position and Black's chances in this
game the clock different differential
has now reduced to only 4 minutes and
material might reduce if he takes with
the bishop on D2 just developing his
undeveloped Bishop then black pushes the
pawn the center up to D4 and suddenly
it's not that things are blowing open
that the white King's in any danger but
pieces are leaving the board and Fabiano
still has so much time on his clock 8
minutes 34 seconds a reminder to
everybody that once they reach move 60
then there's 1 second added for each and
every move you make so this move Queen
takes D2 I think it's trying to meet D4
with that Queen escaping over to the the
king side perhaps trying to initiate an
attack well I've played these positions
with black as well and you're absolutely
right there are two ideas either black
tries to trade off the light squ Bishop
with the move Bishop F5 we see Faby go
for that I think the problem with the
immediate D4 is also you have to
calculate what happens if the white Rook
slides onto the open D line and that's
why Magnus chose to vacate that square
and capture with the Queen Bishop F5 to
me it looks like Advantage Fabby out of
the opening he's already managed to uh
to swap off two pairs of minor pieces
and that's good news when you're
fighting when you looking for the draw
yeah I simply don't see anything wrong
with Black's position and Tanya you made
this uh I mean this exclamation Because
a queen trade in a must-win situation is
counterintuitive right that's what I
would think Robert Queen F4 and I would
grab that Queen if a draw is what I
needed for the match Victory but going
into an end game against Magnus Carlson
is always a scary thing and it's not
just Magnus the type of position that we
have here because while Black's position
does look healthy a few things stand out
to me that pawn C7 I see a diagonal
opening up and that pawn on C7 can be
attacked if the pawn goes up to E6 and
he just goes forward with D4 and look at
Magnus that C7 Pawn really is a weakness
and look at the advantage bar it's going
up for white the evaluation bar is
showing an advantage for white what does
Fabiano have prepared once this C file
opens I think he's planning to move his
Knight unfortunately you don't have time
to come out with your bishop and skewer
the white Rooks because uh ultimately
the white Rook on E1 is defended by
White's Knights so this would be a poor
choice white would be up two pieces for
one black rook and uh two pieces better
than the rook in this case instead I
think he's banking on Knight to B4
coming for this Pawn but also trying to
head back into the middle of the board
what he might have underestimated or
only now realized Fabiano is that after
Rook takes Pawn the Knight dropping back
yes this is a fork yes it's a double
attack but if the white Rook just moves
suddenly black is stuck this bishop is
attacked so Knight takes Bishop Rook
takes would just be a trade and white
would emerge a pawn to the good and if
you move your Bishop out the way to try
and gain time against White's Rook
White's Rook can save the day swoop up
and defend its Bishop either way Magnus
is winning a porn and he goes for it and
maybe this is the moment that you stop
and the idea you pointed out threat is
better than the execution stronger than
the execution do you just simply defend
that Bishop on E7 with the move that
you're pointing at and now I'm attacking
your A2 pawn and Knight D5 a big move on
the board coming up it's a tough call
though because there's a lack of clarity
here so many pieces remain so if Fabiano
spends some time right now and realizes
that if I start with this Knight D5 in
the live position and TR up P instead he
does go for Rook E8 I think it is a good
call but I say you have to assess do I
actually go down one pawn and that's
okay because all Rook end games are
drawn it still would have been a tough
sledding ahead but he decides to go Rook
E8 and now the A2 pawns threatened
Knight D3 Knight D5 all sorts of Knight
jumps that white has to worry about I'm
liking Black's position uh right now
there are all these threats on the board
I'm planning to equalize the material uh
for Fabby he hasn't burnt that much time
on the clock although I do see that
Magnus is still ahead by 5 minutes what
do you think how would you evaluate this
position David it's tough I don't think
we can make generalizations here I think
it's very concrete if white isn't able
to fend off one of these threats or if
white isn't able to save this Pawn then
black is safe black is fine and will
easily make the draw so Magnus should
spend as much time as possible here uh
as much time is as is practical and
decide what to do next the biggest
threat of all is Knight to D5 we should
mention hitting the Rook hitting the
bishop so you need need to move one of
these two pieces essentially uh I think
there's simply no other option Knight to
D5 is a winning threat so he moves the
bishop out the way maybe he could have
gone in a different direction but he's
aiming to trade off and go for the F7
Pawn Magnus I'm really surprised he
didn't invest much more time there
because uh there were options available
but still testing Fabiano I think he's
going to continue testing him because if
we just go down one move Knight D3 looks
like it solves all of Black's problems
hits The Rook hits the B2 pawn and the
E5 Pawn all at once is there E6 can you
throw in that move just causing chaos
because if you take the Rook on E1
that's not a free rook because e takes
F7 is check I get the Rook right back
and you see the evaluation is all the
way at the top because white is not just
one p and will likely win a second at
the very least so this is something that
maybe Magnus is going for it's not just
a trick I think it is just objectively a
good decision and then the black king
isn't feeling so safe yeah and if you
take this Pawn suddenly there real
Targets later in the game and okay
Fabiano Dodges this he plays F6 and big
question for Magnus do you drop back and
maybe lose your winning chances or do
you go in and hope to muddy the waters
Magnus sitting back in his chair looks
shocked he's reaching out and he does go
in he's going for the aggressive
approach The Rook on d8 is hanging is it
time to start stepping up with that Rook
to Target White's queenside pawns how is
Fabby going to react to this and let's
also point out if Fabby loses this match
he is out of the finals he needs to get
this game to get to a third set like
Wesley so was able to accomplish and
this is such a critical moment because
our first Temptation probably for
everybody to save The Rook but all the
way up to D2 putting pressure on the
pawns but I'm realizing that once white
pushes the pawn forward to E6 we have a
protected pass P from The Rook behind it
and that black Rook can actually take
the pawn on B2 it's stuck to that D6
Square because if the Knight you push a
pawn then get your knight out suddenly
black is not able to deal with all the
threats and after E6 I don't really know
what black does I mean this as we're
showing is just going to be losing I
don't know how Fabby holds on here I
think he just simply forgot that Magnus
could keep the ewn alive he wanted to
trade it off at all costs but he didn't
have enough time Fabiano and suddenly I
mean this Pawn is just a monster there's
always tactics actually even on the back
Rank and I don't even see a good move
for black you cannot move this Knight I
mean if you go in for example Knight D6
I think your idea Robert still on the
cards if you remove this Rook remove the
blocker White's Pawn will just motor
through and
promote faban in big trouble suddenly
and four minutes on the clock this
turned in the space of one or two moves
he was on the brink of safety but
suddenly letting it slip Magnus with the
ewn big favorite and everything started
so well right you start with this open
Spanish you quickly Blitz out the moves
you're able to trade off the pieces
really quickly the pressure is dissolved
and then these last two moves just
inaccuracies by Fabby big trouble can't
take the pawn on B2 can't put the knight
in the way of The Rook the most
important move to stop for Fabiano
Carana right now do not allow mag to go
Knight to D6 that E Pawn will become a
queen yeah but how do you stop that
eventually happening if you keep your
black Rook on the defile it means you're
unable to go and grab pawns Black's
Knight can never really recentralize
because uh then you block the defile
allowing it to happen again okay I have
a question what if Fabby just doesn't do
anything makes a move like A5 I'm
waiting how do you improve his white
hair stop pushing pawns to the king side
Queen side yeah there are going to be
some options there at some point if I
get my king off the first even Rook D7
uh comes into mind but what I'm looking
at right now is black I think is one
tempo short of Knight C2 back to D4
going right after that E6 Pawn because
David made an excellent point they're
actually are back ranked Checkmate ideas
just to show Knight C2 Rook to E4 and
then Knight to D4 and you go Knight D6
here it looks like you just blunder this
Pawn E6 with let's say even Knight takes
E6 or Rook takes E6 just grabbing that
pawn but I can just take you on E6 and
then I back rank Checkmate you so of
course they're going to be moments where
you can get away with something like
this but not here not when your king
doesn't have any Escape squares
beautiful beautiful tactics and this
type of thing if not is this exact
variation this type of thing will keep
recurring it's all about the black king
being stuck right now and uh at some
point I guess this Knight just might be
booted out he gives his King some
breathing space so guarding against
those motifs we mentioned the black king
now can at least mobilize but how does
Magnus continue that is the big question
is there a way forward can he eventually
brute force it and push this Pawn to
Glory still some work to be done for the
world number one a much better waiting
move a kind of a waiting move by Fabby
the move H5 like you said just giving a
lift to black king and now ideas of
Knight C2 or Knight D3 are in the air
Magnus putting pressure on the clock
reaching out to make his next move Fabby
does hit the under three minute Mark
still far away far far away from meeting
move 60 getting that additional second
so it's not only keeping it on the board
but Fabby also has to avoid getting
flagged 2 minutes and 55 seconds in this
position you have to reach move 60 just
to get that bonus time with every move
made and this is such a tricky moment
for Fabiano Carano but Magnus is doing
the right thing investing some time here
because perhaps you could put the game
away not caring about the clock even if
you gave five a day you see the
evaluation bars all the way up here I'm
already looking at ways to go after the
H5 pwn if I can land a rook on h8 my
coach always taught me about dream moves
that that would be checkmates a rook
back to C5 at some moment that looks
very enterprising to me trying to go for
the black king yeah I love it Robert or
pick up the white Rook on E1 somehow
plunk it on h8 Rook E4 Rook H4 take the
pawn uh yeah all these ideas popping
through Magnus Carson's mind right now
he must sense that he's doing well and I
think the moment it became tactical he
banks on his chances uh both on the
board and on the clock but still he
wants the accuracy these top players are
perfectionists they don't want to let
any any opportuni slip and okay he's
pausing what to do first does he push a
pawn kick away the Black Knight does he
lift the white Rook up the board does he
I don't know push White's kingside pawns
forward there's so many options for
Magnus Carson critical moment he's in
the tank now 2 minutes once he starts
playing I'm expecting a quick flurry of
moves it's where players often go wrong
though when there are too many choices
you think this one looks just as good as
the other but there could be a flaw and
you could give black just the necessary
time to get back in the game and black
does have some threats a knight coming
into D3 that hits the Rook on E1 hits
multiple pawns and for Magnus he paus
and he does bring his Rook up to E4 so
any knight jump here doesn't come with
an attack against that rook and Rook H4
Rook takes H5 Rook h8 Checkmate not out
of the question yeah far from out with
the question and first of all posing a
difficult question to Black's Knight
three possible squares I think you
simply have to move that night perhaps
you can defend it with Black's Pawn but
uh there's downsides there's pros and
cons to every single night jump and
Fabiano it's basically a 1 and three one
and4 I even forgot that this was
possible but it's so far offside now
that black knight it's not coming back
into action anytime soon Magnus
therefore has the luxury of a few turns
to really uh close in either push the
pawn or go for that black king as we've
mentioned Fabby levels the material for
now but in that deal he does put his
Knight completely offside does this give
Magnus enough time to try and go for the
check mating idea that you pointed out
sliding The Rook to the H line the one
defensive resource that Fabby has is to
push that g Pawn to G6 to make sure that
the H file remains blocked and at least
for the time being Rook h8 will not be
Checkmate bobbly definitely does not
want to open up the seventh rank but it
may be a sad necessity just to avoid
that immediate demise so G6 at any
moment for black does defend that pawn
that's sticking out there but that
seventh rank being open is very
dangerous so I'm looking at this for
Magnus everything does look good but if
if you go Rook H4 Pawn I actually don't
see how to end the game and that's good
news for Fabiano he may believe he's got
a Fighting Chance under two and a half
minutes right now he doesn't only have
to fight the board again he has to fight
the clock as well it is what is that
it's 35 moves to make it to move 60 and
that's a far way off with complications
still on the board the E Pawn two steps
away from from queening so there are
checkmating ideas on the king side you
have to avoid White's Knight jumping
onto D6 the pawn promoting further to E7
there's a lot to fight for in this
position how is Fabby going to manage
this it's not going to be easy I think
Fabiano's moves will be influenced by
magnus's moves right now the Black
Knight simply fixed on A2 no retreat
squares Black's Rook stuck defending the
D6 square and uh actually I'm looking
for mag Magnus just manifesting just
imagining perfect pawns perfect pieces
if white could land a Pawn on F5 protect
his Advanced E Pawn he's simply winning
so maybe push the pawn to F4 he actually
defends that PN with his rook and the
eval bar slides slightly down uh this
idea I think is is a dual purpose threat
firstly attacking Black's A6 pawn and
secondly creating that D6 Square for the
White Knight to hop back to and it free
up the E4 Rook as well to go on over to
H4 but Fabby he backtracks with his own
rook and the A6 Pawn can be captured so
white will be a pawn ahead but then that
black knight it survives it goes up to
C1 and then may back around to D3 if
Fabby could pick up that Knight and
place it on E5 to trade off a pair of
knights he will have better chances but
his Knight's been offside it's not a
good piece and Magnus he maintains this
uh momentum and I just feel like for
Fabby every single move is so
challenging and to make it a good piece
Fabby thinks it's worth giving up upon
is Magnus going to allow Fab's Knight
back into play he is reaching out I
think for the Rook to capture that A6
Pawn but hesitates pulls back Magnus
does not look happy though he does not
look uh so convinced that it's totally
winning we see the eval bar but I think
it's deceptive as white you know the
stakes are high if a set of Rooks
disappear if the knights ever disappear
drawing chances only increase so you
need to still continue being energetic
and accurate to maintain this Advantage
he tries to trade off the Rooks now
because that would allow the White
Knight to come back to more active
squares the White Knight ultimately is
the one that will remove the blockader
of the ewn I think this was a key move
for Magnus Carlson yeah and that white
knight will not only jump to D6 but if
black Rooks Rook moves forward to E7 it
will attack it further from that F5
Square eventually getting that E6 Pawn
rolling down the board Fabby canot
afford to let that happen side steps
with the rook and The Rook is back on
the seventh rank Knight D6 once again a
threat on the board that's the killer
blow for Fabiano the death now because
he wants to bring his Knight back into
B3 he does just that but once you get
Knight D6 in here the the only thing
that Magnus need to be care about is if
that black knight gets a C5 that Forks
both of his Rooks so Rook C1 check
followed by Knight C5 at some moment
unfortunately after Knight D6 his Rook
on8 is under attack so I don't think
he's going to survive this one ooh watch
out there's a threat of a draw right now
Perpetual check Black's Knight if it
comes down to F1 checks the white king
and uh the white king cannot escape and
Magnus with a headshake he was not
expecting to move Knight to D2 he
thought he had it in the bag when he
played Knight D6 and Fabby throws a
curveball with this one big threat he's
lucky he's still winning Magnus Carson
after missing this nasty sneaky move the
white Rook is attacked but you cannot
move it if you move the white Rook or if
you capture the black Rook draw on the
spot the Black Knight comes to F1 check
forces the white king back and we'll see
a yo-yo the black knight move discover
check and uh this dance will last
forever Magnus needs to give some space
to his King it's the type of move that
completely rattles a player you can see
Magnus he needs to regroup right now and
just like yesterday when he's one who
sacrificed his Queen Fabiano finding a
desperate try but he pushes the pawn
does Magnus Carlson he trades off a pair
of Rooks G7 is now loose so Magnus
despite the initial shock he still found
the best continuation and that's where
having time on the clock is such a
lifesaver here Fabiano simply doesn't
have enough time down to just over 1
minute we're only at move 33 increment a
distant dream it's going to be a race on
the clock even if he weren't losing this
position but it does unfortunately look
like that white ewn is going to decide
matters Whit King now given enough air
to survive on its own it will take care
of itself the other white pieces will
get job uh get the job done and okay
he's sliding behind good try from
Fabiano trying to put his Rook behind a
pass Pawn that's what we're taught in
all positions but it's just collapsing
the G Pawn is now up for grabs but don't
take it with the Rook because if you
take that pawn with the Rook the king
steps the side hitting the Knight on E8
the Knight can't move because the it's
the only piece defending that Rook over
there so Magnus still has his work cut
out for him faos creating a challenge
but now that pawn is one square away
from promotion and I think it's going to
get to the other side and Magnus gson
taking his time this could very well be
Fabiano kanan's very last moments in the
champion Chester final and you can see
it in him and Magnus knows he's close to
victory in this one Fabby pushes the F
Pawn is there a night jump Knight moving
to C7 do you do you have the path right
now to get that E Pawn to E8 perhaps
although the Black Knight goes back to
F6 and holds things for now that's why
Fabiano has vacated the F6 square with
this Pawn thrust but it is desperation
Magnus doesn't need to break uh kind of
this formation actually black is stuck
black can barely move anything at all
the white knight jump out the way you
can play that at will later on U maybe
he'll play it now maybe he'll move the
Knight he can even take the G7 Pawn if
you want to be really flashy with the
white knight but uh I'm expecting Magnus
to just take a calm approach not allow
any counter play or any tricks at all
five is down to 42 seconds and this may
be the last 42 seconds of his entire
event here if he loses he's eliminated
look at that move G5 taking away that
Knight's backtrack beautiful move from
Magnus Carlson there just removing any
defensive hope at all yeah look at
Fabiano in pain oh he's got no time
simply under 30 seconds now oh and I
think he's just coming to terms with
everything that's happening because it
is not just about losing this game
Fabiano Carana will be eliminated he
will be knocked out of the Champions
Chester finals he takes a break he does
pick up the pawn but now that Knight
will not jump back to F6 to guard that
e- pawn from promoting there's a check
on F3 but I think it's only a check and
Magnus needs to pause calculate he does
it he realizes that Knight F3 is just a
check grabs that G7 pawn and it's
handshakes Fabiano Carana is eliminated
Magnus Carlson stamps his ticket to the
finals and what a great game there from
Magnus he even missed a tactic he was
shaken but he was able to regain his
composure he eliminates Fabiano Carana
but congratulations are in order to
Magnus Carlson he moves through to the
finals without a third set being
necessary and you can see the
disappointment on Fabby it was was quite
the start to the Armageddon he got the
black pieces he had enough time and he
got the opening that he was hoping for
then Magnus Carlson gets the job done
and there's a spring in his step yep
he's in the final he's relieved after a
bit of an up and down day but
commiserations to Fabiano who put up
such a good fight who's such a warrior
beat Magnus several times in this
semi-final Clash over the last two days
and it's unfortunate he had to go home
yeah there day one had five decisive
games that saw Magnus if eventually win
and day two Magnus takes the lead
against Faby but Fabby Strikes Back to
take it to Armageddon but Magnus with
his end gamees end game touch do not
trade Queens against Magnus gets the job
done wins in the armagen and he is our
first finalist who will play Magnus
Carlson to fight for Championship will
it be nbec Abdus satro or will it be
Wesley so there is a big big set three
coming up with a lot at stake there's
more chest nobody should go anywhere
because we have more chest ahead of us
to today and while Magnus Carlson he
deserved to make his way through to the
finals as David said commiserations to F
A Carana because very few people can
force Magnus into Armageddon two days in
a row when trailing in the match winning
on demand Fabian a Carana proed to
everybody and hopefully himself and he
can hang tough with Magnus Carlson yeah
and Magnus Carlson there in the end did
eventually take the end game and it was
just due to Fabiano not having enough
time on the clock to find the correct
defense in what was a tricky position
and I wanted to highlight one moment
that Fabiano went a bit wrong he let an
equal position slip out of his hands it
was tricky uh we will add that he had
sacrificed a pawn earlier wied up here a
pawn and there's an attack against F7 he
reacted very naturally with Pawn to F6
but if instead he'd first played the
move Knight to D3 attacking a bunch of
Pawns and attacking this white Rook he
might well have been able to hold the
game Robert earlier mentioned E6 the
best try here for white but if for
example The Rook had moved then simply
Knight takes pawn and a level position
this would have at least gave him a
safer position better chances but
unfortunately after F6 white was able to
keep the pawn Al life first with a
threat and then pushing the pawn to
E6 so close and yet so far for Fabiano
Karana he had almost equalized that
position and got that JW but in the end
it is Magnus Carlson who makes it to the
finals and we've got more chess coming
up as we will have set three between
nbec and wesle so and our crew in
Toronto is ready to take it away he is
with our first finalist and we'll be
right back with Magnus
[Music]
Carlson I am beyond excited to announce
on February 23rd through
25th we will be hosting the first ever
chess.com Invitational presented by
Discraft at the famed course in
Brooksville Florida we will be kicking
off this year's disc golf pro tour in
style with not only incredible disc golf
but many more activities there will be a
one-of-a-kind chess disc golf crossover
you won't want to miss as well as an
exclusive chess.com fan Zone I
personally couldn't be more pumped to
bring epic disc golf competition and fun
hope to see you all there
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things hello come come so this is where
the magic happen happens and this is
where all the magic has already happened
yes that's a good way of putting it
that's my world junior
[Music]
87 it's difficult to tell you how many
doors that open for me and what uh what
historical moment it was and when I got
back the chess
Oscars very nice these five of them five
of them five and there's one on top that
is the sixth one so since he had already
got five they didn't want to give him
the same trophy so they gave him a
trophy of a king with the world in his
hand this is anand's first ever mention
in a newspaper
oh so this is his first ever he was
mentioned V Anand achieved a national
record by winning all the nine rounds to
notch a maximum of nine points in the
sub junior Championship imagine now TS
ri's daughter rakita is part of the West
pan chess Academy I mean it's so
beautiful to see how you know life comes
around so World rapid chess and mind
Champion so this was nit gave me this
nice prob why do I get the feeling that
ARA knows all the trophies and where you
w better than you remember it cuz I
cleaned the because it's true because
it's
true did you have a favorite thank you
so much Anand I feel this is extra
motivation for all the youngsters this
opportunity to actually come here and
witness these achievements and spend
time with you in this stunning room
Anand Aruna thank you so much for
[Music]
this a new opening for your wall is here
capture new major pieces on unique metal
posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
we are here in Toronto the first
finalist is now known know surprise
surprise it's Magnus Carlson the number
one player in the world he defeats
Fabiano Carana for the second day in
Armageddon Magnus you heard everyone
talking out there people were roooting
for chess it was like a predictions
right in front of you that uh you heard
us rooting for Fabby a little bit we
wanted more chess and you spoiled it you
sent him home I didn't no I didn't hear
I didn't hear that uh I mean I I always
I'm that way myself like watching if
games can go to over time I always root
for that I usually root for underdogs so
you're not holding it against us no of
course not yes okay we're good no no we
were but I was joking cuz you walked in
and we were all like me Wesley and
Maxine were like well we're all rooting
for Fabby we're rooting for more chess
and you walked in and it it was pretty
funny but anyway man talk a little bit
about this match obviously Fab's a beast
not many people can beat you in Rapid
chess he he beats you several times in
this match overall you did get the job
done obviously in Armageddon but talk a
little bit about carwan if you don't
mind and just how how tough this one was
yeah he's really um he's really strong
so it didn't feel like I was ever
outplaying him much I was mainly holding
on and to be fair
like
um yeah he could easily have won this
much like there's no doubt about that
with the chances he had that he could
have won this match so yeah I managed to
pull through felt that he was really
nervous in the Armageddon now
um uh
but um but yeah I mean of course he's
he's extremely uh he's extremely strong
and uh yeah not not an easy guy to um to
kick did you really have no idea what
you were going to write down for the
Armageddon like we were all out there
discussing if it was genius if you wrote
10 cuz you knew he was going to bid 958
or but then you answered like I had no
clue I just wrote something and yeah I
was just pissed after the
game I I had no idea what to write
really so uh
uh I did like the most my brain was able
to process was that he wrote like 958 or
something or 9 no no sorry like 10:01 or
10:02 or something yesterday so I
thought I'd go a few seconds lower which
is like the
most basic it's like if your opponent
did um rock the last time you'll do
paper you think you'll do it again so
yeah
uh no there was not much thought into it
but I've been I mean I've been
struggling so hard with black today that
I yeah that I thought I'm I was not
unhappy to to play White congratulations
you made it to the final so you got the
minus 10 on the goals we won through
there um of course maybe having some a
little bit of fun obviously in Toronto
too the B3 thing are we going to see
that in the final one B3 I don't know I
I don't know about that but I I haven't
uh I haven't thought about it I would
say there was there was one really big
moment during this Armageddon I I think
first of all he did fine from the
opening he was doing well then we
exchanged queens and he pushed the pawn
which is a little bit risky I think he
could have done other things uh but
anyway the key key moment was after I
played Bishop G5 it took it took and
after F6 I almost went E6 mhm cuz I was
absolutely sure that he'd play Knight D3
instead of uh
um instead of F6 so I was so shocked
that I I almost like played you almost
touched the wrong piece yeah I almost
touched the wrong piece cuz I was in my
mind he' already played Knight D3 and
then I looked at the board I was like
this is this is F6 which I thought was
not a good move yeah uh or at least yeah
it would give me great practical chances
so
um yeah it tells you something about
like sometimes we're just way too like
locked in on something this might be too
philosophical I don't mean to butt in
but second item on your list of
accomplishing you know you had the B3 in
the minus 10 what what is fun for you in
chess like how do you have fun it's just
winning is itun like every game is fun
what is fun when you feel flow in the
game that helps a lot uh and uh to be
honest like there was no flow in these
games like fa is too good um so uh yeah
there was little little flow I mean
winning is winning is fun but
um um yeah fun equals winning with flow
okay you you you talked about the
emotion you had going right from a lost
to Armageddon you don't have time to
collect your thoughts we obviously see
this in online formats a lot right where
you just have so many games to play you
don't have time to collect yourself if
if the momentum is going wrong right and
now here we have an over theboard format
that is also very very fast right you
don't have time from A Loss nor again do
you like this do you like the idea of it
of it being in a in a way that maybe
challenges the emotions the sporting
elements kind of the uh the toughness in
that or are you like hey I actually in
those moments would would have preferred
a moment to take a
breath honestly
um there seems to be some issue every
time that we're about to start the game
like I always get like two more minutes
three more minutes like it always seems
to take longer than it was supposed to
originally and good or bad when I've
lost the game big game I just want to
like take couple of minutes maybe go to
the
bathroom but or and have a little bite
but that's it then I just want to you
want to play yeah I just want to play
yeah well I mean we fix we got to we got
to fix the format guys I mean it makes s
i I don't think he's saying that I think
I understand what you're saying you know
but at least if you're U do you do you
feel like you play a little better if
you're a little on edge what is the best
Magnus right that's a great question uh
I really think the best Magnus is when I
play um with confidence without fear
when I take um take risks um that's
that's when I when I play the best yep
well are we uh are we going to have the
the best Magnus tomorrow you you you
feeling better you feel like you started
off today yeah I mean I I in general
felt a lot better today than
last couple of um couple of days so you
know uh hopefully that Trend can
continue and F is really strong so I'm
not too unhappy with the way that I
played today um in general I just face
the strong opponent
and yeah another time he might have um
definitely nicked this one last chance I
I got to ask it I think it's the normal
sporting thing to do you get to pick
your opponent at this point so or Notre
backck who you picking
um probably
um probably Notre back is but I
mean they both have great moments and
they both have extremely vulnerable
moments so it's very hard to say I mean
from game to game you cannot predict
what is happening next like it's there
seems to be a lot of nerves so I have no
idea what's going to yeah what's going
to happen there
and I think Notre Beck
like getting that win with black I think
is was important he saw that Wesley was
vulnerable even today uh so I don't
think he'll be
um feeling any less confident confident
than usual before the um yeah the the
third match all right well we're going
to see we're going to be watching with
as fans hopefully you'll be watching too
but congratulations man good luck
tomorrow thank you enjoy your night
and uh we we'll see it then there's our
first
finalist punching his ticket and this is
uh this is what it took for him to get
there a couple of 3-2 victories over
Fabian o Carana in Armageddon and like
Magnus said this match in some ways
could have gone either way right Fabby
did have his chances and just was unable
to get it done in some of those big
moments and that's why Magnus Carlson is
usually the last guy standing cuz he
does tend to get it done in those most
dramatic moments but all right Bano is
with Kaa talking about the loss and his
experience here in
Toronto he has given it an awesome fight
but it ends here in the CCT finals for
Fabiano how are you feeling right now
pretty disappointed uh I think I had a
good position in this last game I just
uh rushed a little bit when I probably
took on C3 or took on F5 I mean I should
be completely fine in that position um I
thought that I I thought I was okay
after night before when I took on C3 I
maybe it's already unpleasant after Rook
C1 but yeah I rushed at at some moment
in the opening um and uh and then I got
unpleasant end game probably very
dangerous end game and I don't know
maybe I could have defended it better
but it it started to look really
dangerous and I yeah looked looked like
a bad position do you feel though with
the game four here especially that you
do go out with
style El it doesn't really matter I
guess how how you lose um I left a lot
of chances on the table so I I do have
some regrets for sure what has been uh
your highlight from the CCT finals
2023 well I I enjoyed it overall quite
uh quite a bit but um yeah I don't know
maybe I'll when I reflect back I'll I'll
uh have a bit more perspective now it's
just a bit um disappointing I know
you're very disappointed right now but
can I get your predictions for uh uh
what will happen here now with Wesley
and order backck first of all of all I
think most likely we'll see Magnus
against Wesley in the final but anything
can happen now Fabby what's up for you
in the next uh few weeks here I'll play
the world rapid and Blitz championship
and before that I have some rest but not
a whole lot so it's about 10 days from
now and obviously uh there will be a
candidates tournament Happening Here in
Toronto um in some months do you feel
that you will come here with a good
feeling oh I I have to prepare quite a
lot for the tournament and I suspect
candidates will be very tense
but I am looking forward to it Fabby
thank you so much for all the
entertainment and for your thoughts here
in the mix Z thank you that was Fano
Carana for you back to you
guys there you see your heart goes out
to Fabi Carana not many people can take
Magnus Carlson to two Armageddon and
really have his chances but Bobby did he
couldn't quite hold on Magnus is a
little bit more accurate not even a full
point wow wow your thoughts thought on
that look how close that that chess was
I mean it's tough you know you can feel
for fabbi there cuz he's like bro I'm
getting I'm like this close like I'm I'm
here Danny I'm here but then you're not
at the end of the day it's really tough
it's really tough to see yeah I mean we
just saw world number one versus world
two okay I mean guess what we should get
right admittedly classical chess that
you could call that the real F it's like
when uh when the top two have to play in
the in any semi in any knockout type of
event that could have been our final
match noer backck versus Wesley could
have been you know like but but this
reality and unfortunately for Fabiano uh
his road has come to an end in the most
brutal way two Armageddon back to back
yeah and you saw him just kind of say
like hey right now right now I'm not
shaking this one off maybe everyone else
expects me to lose to Magnus but he
doesn't go into those matches expecting
to lose to Magnus he knows he can beat
Magnus and again we were a game in each
match from it going the other way as
Magnus said so how do you build on that
I guess yeah you know uh I think taking
obviously this experience and going into
his next tournaments with you know a
clear head if you saw Dennis got knocked
out and then one title Tuesday like who
does that just lose to everyone or lose
my matches and then Crush everybody else
in title Tuesday so I think he'll be in
good spirits actually after he lets his
settle in go and get prepared for the
next tournaments I I I say that Fabiano
takes the loser of Wesley versus nck and
just like grabs him we playing for third
like we're not getting no third before
split there is no he's like we're
getting a bronze medal match up on the
stage we should have done I mean damn
but that's not a bad idea we should have
done that and Fab's going to sucon right
he's playing in the world yeah he's
playing to yeah yeah so he has a chance
to still grab a medal and potentially
have a good event yep and I'm just I I'm
a Fabby fan I'm biased I hope ends the
year strong and maybe Fabby will be with
us on the show tomorrow I think he's
hanging out for the weekend so stick
around if you're a Fabby fan a lot of
people do love his commentary I'm sure
we'll get him on the show but all right
Wesley so has earned a lot of new fans
every time he seems to to smile or laugh
or throw down in some content whether
it's white elephant or some sort of
Rapid Fire uh he and I decided to to
have a little bit of a challenge a
little bit of fun and I played blindfold
Blitz with him he's blindfolded not me
here's here's a quick preview of what
happened it's pretty much impossible
these days to think of challenges that
are difficult for Wesley so but we're
going to we're going to try to come up
with one right here right now which is
that we're going to play blindfold blitz
so I'm actually going to get up right
now and I'm going to blindfold him all
right this is you know nothing weird is
going to happen here trust me there you
go close your eyes right no funny
business you going to move the pieces
for I'm going to move the pieces for you
so all you got to do is just say the
move and I'm going to move the pieces
for him and we're going to see how this
goes are you ready yes I'm going to
start your clock you just say your move
and hit your clock so okay play one B3
okay okay so he plays B3 I'm going to
play Knight F6 B should be
to
G6 Knight
F3 Bishop G7
F4 C4 yep yes yes yes indeed you got a
good position all right Knight takes D4
Queen takes D4 check Knight to F6 Queen
E3 I think you're doing great just so
you're if you're worried yeah thought it
looks like very boring position give me
your best Danny I'm
I'm my best but L I'm lacking a little
bit of a plant let me think here why am
I struggling so much with the right
thing to play here um my plan now is
just to try to flag you yeah which is
first of all a genius plan queen to be6
I a good move I have 2 minutes and 24
seconds you have 4 minutes and 45
seconds maybe I should have given you a
minutes right all right I know I know
I'm old and slow I'm all those things
you're not for the
hit all right I'm going play Rook to d8
I'll
play
herook
fd1 you play a lot of good chess moves
has any ever told you
that no h hold a freaking draw here come
on di all right Rook takes D1 yeah Rook
FES Rook
I got to do what I need to do to win you
got to do what you got to do to win got
to respect it Knight to F6 ah what are
you doing you training
something I don't know I
mean I was like uh King to
E3 why did you have to see it it was
one Rook to D Rook to D1 B D1 yeah how I
feel you daddy look good
ah you have 2 minutes and 15 seconds all
right I got a you're turning
something I'll play rope to
C4 okay Bishop to
D5 I'll play rope to
C3 Wesley this is your chance to blunder
you can do it Rook to G1 mhm Bush
A5 no more mate Rook to
G1 I'll play
B to
E4 oh man was an accurate move Bishop to
a
B7 okay I'm just kidding I like go on A8
I can't do I can't take advantage of a
blind
man I'm getting M I'm getting mated King
to G7 oh why why are you running that
was a good move by me it's not over yet
Knight E8
check I'm going to play the most boring
King to
F7 Arrow takes mishop A6 it Wesley yeah
King takes
E8 King
A6 King to f8 all King to
F6 oh wow that hurts actually that's a
big time oh I lost on time that was a
make I lost track of time wow good game
I almost feel okay about myself almost
yeah you're doing good for your first
game after a long time thank you yeah
all right well thank you for your time
thank D best of luck in the rest of the
week we'll let you go get some dinner I
got to get some dinner thank you so much
Danny we'll talk later
pleasure you guys think you would beat
him in that same
format uh probably not but I do better
than you 80% accuracy same same I feel
no the problem is he played this like
stupid B3 thing like play some Mainline
stuff yeah you wimp what are you you you
you absolutely come on Wesley he
purposely took me to some stupid
positional chess I don't have time for
that nobody has time for B3 what's wow
you 80% though not bad yeah well
speaking of Wesley he also played 1 B3
against Notre backck and that got the
job done in their first game first game
of that match and uh I don't mean to
butt in but I'm absolutely going to but
in like that that 87.5% I really feel
like from Norbeck was that first game
that B3 game made without that game I
feel like he's back over 90% that was a
crazy first game I don't know what
happened there but clearly really thrown
off by that 1 V3 unironically I guess
Wesley was inspired by
his I didn't even make that connection
but you're right3 right worked against D
A lot of people feel better about
themselves when they when they beat me a
chess feels like a really big
accomplishment let that
sit let that sit with the
cricket that anything about beating me
inspired Wesley but he did Play 1 B3
successfully against Notre Beck we'll
see if he does that again in this in
this next match up but all right we're
going to get to previewing this next
matchup here in just a second but before
we do wanted to uh a lot of you saw Paul
McBeth if you don't know that's the goat
we're here with the goat Magnus Carlson
the goat of disc golf I said it I'll
stand by it Paul McBeth for those of you
who maybe play might be wondering why in
the world is chess.com involved in a dis
golf tournament well um it kind of came
about organically and accidentally and
I'm going to I'm going to let the video
explain kind of how we got ourselves in
that sticky situation and then we'll see
you on the other side
ah what a beautiful
day what in the
world cheers is attacking they're
[Music]
everywhere we have to
fight take that
Checkers hey what are you
doing those are my discs ah do you work
for Checkers no I work for disc craft
why are you attacking me I'm not I'm
here at a disc golf course throwing
discs those aren't Checkers no these are
prototypes of new discs for Paul MC Beth
and you're in my way and you ruined a
bunch of
them who's Paul MC Beth oh my gosh PA
man first of all I'm a huge fan second
of all I am so so sorry the green pwn
can get a little out of control
sometimes and uh well you know honestly
in his defense there's a very long
history between chess and checkers that
I I could tell you about if you if
you've got a few a few hours Danny I
really don't have the time right
now okay no yep I get it I feel you on
that um can we can we replace the
discs right now with the holiday season
and the disc costing thousands if not
hundreds of thousands of dollarss I
don't think there's much you can do okay
um there's got to be something man
anything actually I think there is
something chess.com is a proud sponsor
of the inaugural chess.com Invitational
presented by Discraft join Paul McBeth
and chess.com Danny and Eric from
February 23rd to the 25th in Brooksville
Florida this is the golf tournament you
don't want to
miss so disc golf huh yeah it's like you
take a disc and you're just
like so that's basically what you do can
I try I mean
sure yeah it's like that but you're like
trying to throw to like that basket
hundreds of feet away it's not like that
I
mean I mean not really you kind of want
to like like you want to like behind you
you want to like explode through it's
like okay kind of like
that yeah
okay oh my gosh did they all go in like
that that was amazing Palms
[Music]
work first of all check out the special
effects in that video you see I mean
unless you believe I actually made it
that far is that classified as a real
sport disc golf yeah it is that's crazy
so either have you play Disc Golf
regular golf in fact regular well no
that we like to call it stick golf
you're discriminating okay it's disc
golf and stick golf I am not about to
get canc I play Real Sports guys Real
Sports fun fact Eric and I are huge huge
fans of disc golf we we do want to
continue to have chess grow into other
communities Magnus is actually a dis
golf player and I'm not going to out the
family member but he has a relative who
is actually one of the top disc golf
players in Norway just in the family
that's just we'll see whether whether
Magnus and and and anyone else can can
make it to that that event in Florida
but um anyway it's going to be epic so
shout out to the Disc Golf Community
Paul MC Beth and anyone who thought that
was the weirdest collab of all time it's
pretty much a personal selfish thing but
all right let's get personal real quick
before we send it back to Oslo you're
handsome two game oh wow yeah well you
said let's get personal you look super
good sorry okay
two games now okay so Notre Beck uhuh y
I'm not going to make you be on the spot
with a prediction but your thoughts real
quick about what what we're about to see
well the momentum is obviously in
Wesley's uh favor but again I'm just
going to go back to the fact that before
the semi-finals I said Wesley is going
to win the match now momentum is on his
side he's also probably the better
straightup rapid player by this much but
it doesn't matter he CHS noer back can
we we're not going to forget that he
chose nck nck punched him in the mouth
first not actually as far as we know
Wesley struck back he still a slight
favorite in my opinion we're about to
see who's going to join Magnus I agree
in fact I think uh Wesley actually when
you know what did they say when Magnus
has more games it's harder to play
against Magnus yeah I think with shorter
it's going to be harder to pay Wesley in
fact just having two games there notb is
going to have to bring his best and
Wesley is doing everything I mean he got
B3 you got B3 right so two games right I
do think we're getting Armageddon think
you think I'm hoping for Armageddon
we're hoping for the most chess possible
I think I I I would agree I also picked
a Carlson so final when we did that but
at the same time Magnus made a great
Point as my earpiece pops out that's
live TV I can hear you there in Oslo I
can hear you uh Magnus made a great
point which is Notre Beck wasn't upset
before emotionally when he lost to Fabby
and then rebounded to beat Hikaru so the
kid seems to have the stuff when it
matters most we'll see if he does it
this time on that note we're going to
throw across to Oslo y'all are ready to
take it away I just use y'all
correctly we saw that video Danny and
did y'all enjoy it but my first question
to you is did you really get that I
don't know if it's called a hole-in-one
in dis golf or was that special
effects I'm going to let the uh we'll
leave that one to mystery going to let
the dis golf speak for let the dis I'm
going let dis Lev's going to retire on
that one he's going to walk off camera
there he's going to let the disc golf
speak for
itself uh yeah there it is that's a
replay look at that the briali looks I
mean the
trajectory very nice I I think the
trajectory of the disc kind of go
ahead
yeah the editing was great we'd never
know if Danny actually got that one in
or not uh but right now the big question
for nck and Wesley can they get
themselves in into the finals and who
will it be it's a set three It's the
final set and this time it's a best of
two if it remains a thigh it goes into
Armageddon today one thing's clear it
was Wesley so who dominated set to he he
dominated the entire day against nck all
the games but nck has so much to take
away from yesterday as well where he was
the one who was just crushing through
yeah NC played a great set one a day ago
today in set two didn't start his way
hopefully he learns that if the position
looks a little bit shaky he doesn't have
to go all in there's only two games
we'll see who's in better form heading
to set three start yeah and uh here we
see nck in great spirits as he takes his
seat and hey guys can we get some help
changing the chairs thank you more chair
drama great chair quality out there in
Toronto nbec now just wow switching
things up we're getting some help it's
the most uh Manpower I've seen having to
move one chair in any tournament Hall if
anyone out there wonders what goes on in
venues this is it we're playing cherami
or something you know I don't really
know what's happening there but the
players they may be a little bit
superstitious they have their
preferences and those chairs they're
pretty bulky they they're good for your
back good support solid secret lab
chairs right there so uh they're
choosing they're choosing their chair
they've also got to choose their
openings and it's going to be so much
about who gets their kind of positions
because we saw in set two Wesley just
seemed to get really good outcomes uh
from the very start of the game yeah
Wesley start with B3 he mixed it up
because he said he wasn't impressed with
the positions he was getting out of
playing a Kings Pawn opening but not
back to his credit he struck back in
game three down two to nothing he played
a really nice game three with the black
pieces so he's showing that even when it
looks like he's about to lose a match he
can still climb back yeah back to B3 or
will it be back to the Kings Pawn for
Wesley so who takes his seat glasses are
off players just getting that Poise now
they look ready to go and we're ready to
go here as well o it all comes down to
this part and look at that death stat
the games haven't even started but NC
playing the Mind Games looks like he's
ready for that chess boxing match but
this this will all be settled on the
chessboard Wesley no more B3 Cowboy for
him he's back to his King Pawn opening
but which King Pawn opening will it be
no more scotch game which led to that
disaster in game three it's back to the
Italian maybe inspired by Fabiano
karan's success in this opening against
Magnus Carlson and Black's Knight comes
out the two kns defense here against the
Italian provocative stuff and look at
Wesley he was eyeballing his opponent
there and he goes in hoping for the
fried liver attack what will we see
Black's Knight Dodges there was a poison
Pawn in the center we see a quick trade
but this is a pawn Sacrifice from nbec
Abdu satoro and not one it can be I was
going to say another Pawn can be given
up if the queen moves up to F3 but a
different opening approach he does
retreat with the bishop the fried liver
attack it promises to have Madness on
the board very very early on what do you
think is going to happen will who is
better prepared here Robert in this
opening right now well no wasn't
expecting it and I don't think he is
pausing he's calculating and these
players they study their fellow top
players games woo Knight G4 jumping out
the Knight on G5 is not protected so
that Knight likely has to move away from
its current square but what I was going
to say is that they studied their fellow
uh competitors games and Hikaru Nakamura
has played the white side of this
position many times in important battles
so Wesley he moves his night away it's
going to be a real sharp game because
black has given up a pawn but White's
moving the those minor pieces numerous
times at this stage and he's got to move
them some more because very often in
these position black marches up the
board with that F Pawn it's all about
trying to create play compensation peace
play for that sacrificed Pawn F5 is on
the cards and David it can happen now it
can happen now it most likely will
happen now one thing I should mention is
that two years ago on the Champions
chess tour Wesley so was playing this
quite consistently he even played this
variation with the bishop back to D3
against Magnus car and got a huge
Advantage Wesley so created a Chesser
bow course in 2021 and it was about this
variation we talk about the top players
doing their uh research and wow F5 on
the board a quick flurry some Knights
disappearing black going for the white
king the F2 Pawn now is a big big Target
who cares about the pawn structure which
is crazy black is a pawn down but he's
going on the attack a clearly NC doesn't
care about his Pawn structure that is
the strangest Pawn formation I've seen
on the board we are on move 12 and look
at black spawns I would never play in
this fashion with either color it looks
too risky black has currently a pawn
down but there are so many open files
and diagonals you see that dark Square
Bishop that just developed it's staring
at the F2 Pawn the golden Pawn right in
front of the white king white is not
castling kingside in this position not
when the H file is also opening up so
Wesley needs to be extremely precise I
actually think that Wesley if he goes
wrong he could be losing in just a few
turns but if nybeck doesn't know how to
continue here and keep this initiative
he is down a pawn after all and his the
rest of his Pawn structure is shattered
look at Wesley's body language here he
was shaking his head quite noticeably
for a while then a bit of a kind of
brush of the brow there now he's uh just
nervously looking at his position
eyeballing his opponent there he is
flocked this was a surprise Knight to G4
it's a known move but it very rarely
happens at the top level and if you
haven't researched this recently if you
haven't refreshed your mind haven't
looked at what the computer suggests
here as Robert says it could be knockout
within a few moves you have to be super
accurate here you're treading a fine
line as white he brings his night out as
far as I know one of the main moves and
uh How Deeply does nbec know this
position and that's the big question
Wesley is the first one to Spring a
surprise with Knight to G5 the fried
liver attack but not about counter
surprises Wesley with his own Knight a
couple of moves later jumping on to G4
getting this absolute chaotic position
Wesley makes a developing move the E4
Pawn currently hanging also so much
tension on the king side with the hline
open Black's Rook pin behind the H5 Pawn
strategically Black's in terrible shape
right he goes Queen D4 Checkmate in one
is threatened now Wesley castles and his
next move if F2 doesn't come under any
more fire he wants to push his Pawn up
to D3 and develop his dark Square Bishop
he desperately needs to get more pieces
into the defense now after the castle
King said the F2 Pawn is hanging once
more Queen E1 slide that Queen over
bring all of your pieces defending the
pawn and only then push your Pawn to D3
I think Wesley knows this quite well
yeah Wesley pausing but he does
eventually play the only move in that
position the key move sliding across
defending stuff with his Queen and
earlier Robert you name dropped Eric
Rose and the Stafford Gambit this looks
like a variation of the Stafford Gambit
it looks like white is about to get
checkmated but if you hold things
together long term it is worth some uh
worth suffering for you do have extra
material potentially you do have all
those targets so it's all about this
initial storm if white survives most
likely wesle Lee will win long term if
not we might see a quick miniature
finish Abdu satov pausing here slight
surprised that he's pausing because he
was the one who initiated this craziness
by throwing the Black Knight to G4
surely he knows what's going on with
black and it is up his alley it is his
style he's looking away maybe he's just
choosing between two promising moves
here and eventually he takes the pawn so
level material yet again but it's all
the double pawns isolated Pawns in the
world for black and it does give white
the time to play your move but the
ugliest Pawn structure I think we've
ever seen like there are two sets of
double isolated pawns on E file and G
file then we have the isolated A and C
Pawn so it's really a hideous structure
for black but after D3 which was
necessary from White you can take this
Pawn on D3 and in the very near future
there is going to be G4 to G3 exploiting
the pin on this dark Square dle maybe
you play Rook takes F2 first even just
to trade even more pieces Rook takes F2
would be met by G3 and white escapes you
can see the Eva bar still hanging
towards the center but Black's getting
rid of that really horrendous Pawn
structure yeah and uh there we go he
starts trading off just before it's too
late I wanted to highlight this Pawn
structure one isolated pawn two isolated
pawns doubled isolated pawns doubled
isolated pawns yeah longterm uh this is
suffering for black so do not try it at
home unless you know you're going to
land a Killer attack he does trade off
and Moment of Truth Wesley pauses will
he take back with a pawn the bishop or
will he drop his own Bishop in I don't
think he should actually go for this one
because black would sacrifice the queen
and uh here is too much material one
Bishop will fall yes the queen
disappears but a rook will fall with
check and it's more about counting here
more about the maths Bishop bishop and
Rook for the queen too much material
Wesley continues with his headshake not
happy with the opening outcome and I
wonder if that has something to do with
the position that we have or the fact
that he was expecting nck to be
surprised by his opening choice but nck
on the other hand continues to Blitz out
the moves and now he's got to show more
in this position does he go for the
sacrifice on F2 because you have to be
quick long-term nyback doesn't survive
this one Rook takes Pawn is that the
only way to go forward I would
definitely be playing with that in mind
because I want to liquidate and get rid
of My Double isolated pawns the problem
for nybeck is even once the Pieces come
off there's still enough Firepower left
to go after Black's remaining pawns
they're all spread out it's like bowling
never want to split you never want pawns
split like this o this feels really not
fun for Nock and he's now spending some
time here because he wants to figure out
do I trade off pieces or do I have
something in this position going after
the white king we keep saying that it's
not fun for NAB back but there's only
one guy on our screen shaking his head
and it's Wesley so and what what's going
on in his mind because the position
looks defended for Wesley but awful for
black and we see nck is in with Rook
takes one why is Wesley constantly
shaking his head in this opening we've
seen Wesley's recent tweets or his posts
on X we've seen him in interviews he's
trolling people it's a red herring I
don't think uh nobec should read too
much into the body language here if
Wesley didn't know what was going on he
would have spent 10 minutes not just two
three minutes so Wesley's just trying to
recall everything maybe if he's shaking
his head it's just about the fact that
he didn't kind of check this line
recently he hasn't analyzed it with uh
the latest engines or not in the last
few months at least but Rook takes pawns
on the board fireworks Wesley has to
defend accurately but is he going to
take this Rook back with his own Rook or
with the queen that's the first question
Queen's on or off the board as nbec
stretches looking confident he's flexing
right he's showing that he's worked out
he's just getting in those uh those what
the traps and so you see that Rook takes
F2 it's setting up a bit of a trap
because black does want to push this
Pawn to G3 and go after the pin and look
at this decision from uh Wesley he gets
all the pieces off the board I get the
feeling he still knows what he's doing
he may be shaking his head grabbing his
face all that stuff I really think that
Wesley has studied this position and he
might even have more lines to go perhaps
the head shake is because he realizes
that nbec also knows exactly what he's
doing because it feels like he's managed
to equalize the position at least that's
what the bar says it's easy for us to
say but once again the position doesn't
look as easy as it looks and for now he
at least delays taking that F2 Pawn the
umbrella Pawn as you call it Robert
which keeps White's King safe so far in
the position not opening up the F line
for the black Rook to slide over yeah it
feels like one of those openings and
this is very common in uh modern chess
especially at the top level it feels
like a line where you test your opponent
you've both done the clicking you've
both checked the engine what the top
moves are you have to remember it of
course but if you both remember the game
does fizzle out towards a balanced
position but white is the one testing
black right now
yes Black's got an extra Pawn but
Black's Pawn's still ugly I'm expecting
Wesley to continue after a bit more
thought uh to kind of develop his pieces
once the white Bishop d square bishop
and Rooker into the game we will see a
roughly level end uh end game here and
let's remind everyone it's a best of two
so this is Wesley's only white in this
match so perhaps uh just a bit
disappointed that he didn't get more out
of the opening than he was expecting
from the surprise and to break down the
action more we got reinforcements coming
in from Toronto as uh Danny is being
joined by Maxim Vash lra uh take it away
Dan this opening this outcome of this so
what do you think uh will nbec hold his
game one with
black thanks Sonia I'm going to I'm
going to ask Maxim that question because
he's uh he's probably the one who has a
little more to say than I do in regards
to whether Notre will hold but I will
quickly say it does does look like
Wesley's a little frustrated maybe
because Notre Beck knew this line um and
the fact that the kid is up 2 minutes on
the clock doesn't help but Maxim we're
going to dive in and analyze this your
thoughts on what we see on the board
before we maybe talk about the story
lines off the board I think West land's
opening surprise very well uh I like his
position I was considering moves like
okay First bishop D2 of course get this
Knight back to B7 yeah I
mean no or later and then Knight G5 to
avoid Bishop E6 okay create some threats
around the king but of course the of
doing that is this Pawn on F2 becomes
very relevant so maybe it's a bit too
risky uh like Bishop G4 is possible
still for
black um yeah but in general of course
there are much safer ways to play for
Wesley like you can grab the pawn on F2
and is very slightly better but
um yeah he he can push somehow so so you
think Wesley it feels okay though about
his position right now right now I think
he feels okay he's just trying to find
if there's a way to to push for an
advantage like you can play C3 first you
can play many things right um so do you
think he feels pressure in a two- game
match to to push here with white
obviously Notre Beck has had some good
victories as white so
well first of all I think is we gained
confidence after this first match of the
day yeah where it was dominant he had
this sleep in the third game but in
general he was like uh clearly the best
player
uh today and so you know I don't think
he feels bad at all if he if it goes to
a second game with black of course when
it comes to Armageddon it's a different
thing cuz it's all relies on one single
game so uh but he knows that no back
will go for for a full fight in the
second game and then um maybe he'll try
to make use of that but right now he's
looking is if he has something to
actually put pressure maybe something
like very direct C3 B4 A4 to to play
A5 um so just Pawn C3 Pawn B4 Pawn A4
and just try to advance on the queen
side yeah then I'm guessing A5 will
happen but maybe it's maybe it's a way
to go cuz then you can go
with um maybe black plays A5 though yeah
yeah yeah that's what I was saying maybe
you go some Bishop A3 somewhere like I
don't know because the bishop on B6
becomes also a little V a little bit
vulnerable I don't know it's a very
complicated position I must say like um
you can easily make mistakes if you if
you try to over push with white or black
I like that even with the Queens off the
board that there's a lot of complexities
going here okay so we've seen inside the
crystal ball of a super Grand Master's
mind maybe some of these variations will
happen on the board for fans but I want
to ask you the same thing we just asked
Magnus I think a lot of us saw Wesley as
the favorite coming in for good reason a
lot of people I think feel that way but
Magnus said he thinks Notre Beck
recovered well the day before and thinks
not Brook's you know in form right now
so who do you think is uh right now we
had this discussion with Magnus uh I'm
still going for
wle um well you're rooting for
Armageddon first and foremost of course
like me because want more time on the
couch of course I was very disappointed
that we didn't get a sech set between M
and Bobby yeah yeah because we want more
chess we want more chess that's what
we're here for yeah uh but in general I
would say
uh so Magnus said that he feels Wesley
is a bit shaky so maybe he has more
inside because he's in the room when
when they're playing maybe he feels uh
more the tension that H bits Wesley but
yeah in general I feel
like um it should
be it should be the favorite it's funny
what what do you think about magnus's
comments about when he said he thinks
both players have had great moments here
but both players have also looked
extremely vulnerable at times yeah I
think it's true for almost everyone here
maybe besides Magnus or even Magnus you
think I would say Wesley was very
dominant in the r Robin
section um Magnus has been quite
dominant but against Fab didn't true he
had some moments yeah yeah yeah he
didn't show total control for sure so
yeah uh we'll see how it goes
um like wesler has been the most stable
player of the field but it's true that
you had this moments of um nervousness
yeah okay well there's about that stake
here I
guess okay um I think Tanya is going to
going to chime in here go for it yeah
really uh cool insights there Maxim on
uh the psychology of the opening that
we're seeing but I've got one more
question for maxim Danny that we here in
the studio we've been talking so much
about NC's Death Stare just the way he
look so confidently at his opponents and
I want to ask Maxim being on the
opposite side of nbec has he what's been
his experience with that has is that
something that he's noticed about n
back t t is asking about I was hoping
You' say could you repeat please turn
could you repeat please turn yeah go
ahead the uh the joh no um T is asking
what it's like to play Notre Beck cuz
they've been talking in the studio about
the fact that he's very intense over the
board he's got a death stare he kind of
stares you guys down obviously you've
played a lot of intimidating characters
in your time but does that bother you at
all or what are your thoughts about
about uh the way he can really gaze into
his opponent's eyes in general during
games I very ear look at my oppent I'm
completely un buzzed I'm focused on my
play I might be looking at the
ceiling more than their faces you think
that's true for all players though
or maybe just me okay yeah
yep all right when you're looking at the
ceiling are you like are you going full
Beth Harmon up there like what are you
looking at are you thinking about what
you had for breakfast I can be thinking
about any sort of random thing like like
a Nish giri probably not nothing all
right uh well we're we're having a good
time here anything else you want to say
before we head back to the couch and
just
analyze um no I'm good okay you're doing
good yeah all right we're gonna we're
gonna he's uh he's unfazed exactly
unbothered unbothered and we're gonna go
back to the
couch and chill out we're gonna throw it
back to you guys now yeah thanks that's
we're going to do that's what we're
going to do all right bye guys thanks
guys uh unbothered unfaced really
interesting because I think when you're
playing against a guy like n you need to
do that you need to just block out any
sort of eye contact with him he can be
really scary and I saw him give a little
bit of a stare once again there I think
the only thing Mak Maxim uncomfortable
was this conversation and standing next
to Danny so it was successful in that
regard they're going to head back to the
couch but for these two players there's
no taking it easy I mean that King on H7
right now for nirc Abdus satarov it
doesn't have too many squares if you
imagine a white Rook landing on the H
file it could fall victim to a
checkmating net that's not out of the
question and the bad Pawn structure
remains for black even material but
Black's pawns are worse so I do prefer
just like Max Team said White's position
I think Wesley has chances this end game
definitely and White's next few moves
are straightforward white would love to
for example land a rook on H1 as you say
Robert so maybe plant the King on E2 if
you want to focus in zoning on this E5
Pawn then you just shift your Rook to
the E file uh simple play there
beautiful Outpost for your knight if you
can land it and maybe even expand pawns
on the queen side for black it's far
less clear what you should be aiming for
you need to balance out the long-term
strategic deficiencies especially these
isolated pawns with Dynamic Play Active
play but how do you achieve that I was
looking looking for example at this
knight jump to try and hit the bishop
but the bishop just slides back with a
check and uh at the very minimum you
just move your Rook across pressure
black is the one certainly on the back
foot and uh I don't think nck is his
type of position yes he's great in end
games but this one is far more static
his weaknesses and unless he can gain
that energy that he loves and uh make it
more about calculation then I think he's
going to struggle but we know aack he's
so good when it comes to end games and
right now though he has pressure and
reasons to be worried about but the kind
of endgame technique that he's been
showing in this tournament I'm not
worried for him in this one I definitely
am worried I just hate his Pawn
structure and something that people
should remember is that we like our
Pawns in the center during the early
stages of the game because they restrict
the enemy pieces but in the end game
flank pawns can actually be super
dangerous because they tie your
opponent's pieces down to the side of
the board while you activate your own
pieces in the center and one of the main
moves we were just talking about David
was suggesting Rook over to E1 next to
that white king very logical going after
this Pawn on E5 I just feel like there's
so many weaknesses that black has to
keep an eye on and for nybeck here he's
a great endgame player but nobody would
be comfortable playing this from the
black side all right so nck needs to be
a little careful a little precise though
he can start thinking about his own play
we know he loves the initiative he does
take out the bishop The Rook eventually
hoping to land on the f file to try to
put pressure on that pinned eventually
pinned Knight on F2 but uh first if W
Ley gets in the pressure on the E5 Pawn
will he go passive with his own Rook or
is he expecting to continue more
development get that Knight to D6 hit
that Bishop on C4 is he going to look
for initiative in this one make it sound
easy Tanya that the black pieces can
flow forward and of course after T he's
an expert and making it look easy uh on
the board and I think you're right that
black knight will come in with gain of
tempo in the next few moves do you line
up uh the black Rook against the white
king first of all that's one question
not sure whether the tactics work out
there you need to calculate a bit very
minimum you just defend your ewn but no
he goes for that other option every move
with Tempo gain time hit the opponent's
loose pieces the night hitting White's
bishop and uh forcing it away to slide
back I think that Wesley can make a
quick move he's not playing this game
that quickly overall which I think is
worrying for him as his time trouble has
been really a problem in his match
against nck yesterday n was able to win
an end game where the Evo Bo was right
at the middle because Wesley was not
able to handle himself without too much
time on the clock but I think he can
slide his Bishop back to B3 next trade
the dark Square Bishops if he ever needs
to by putting that one on the E3 square
and Black's problems persist I'm not
trying to exaggerate the issue black
should be able to hold but should have
would have could have these are words
that are not so meaningful when we're
talking about Blitz chess which is the
time control we're about to enter and
the one thing I will mention today
because it's going to be a marathon day
of Chess is that the last time we had a
day this long on the Champions chess
tour finals it was when abdor took down
Nakamura just a couple of days ago so he
does have the stamina if he can survive
this game I think he'll be feeling super
confident now that it's just a two game
uh shootout essentially uh I think this
one it's just important to survive with
black you don't want to get too
ambitious if you save this you move on
you have white maybe an Armageddon but
you younger you have energy I think he
might become the favorite if he
holds that's the big if and uh again I
think he uh he would be able to do this
I see the pawn structure that you're
pointing at but I love The Bishop's
activity in this position The Rook
lining up on the F line but he decides
to First defend the ewn that can start
marching up the board and create threats
of his own right now nck doing
everything right and it's been quite a
journey for nck from the thought took
him seven days to get the visa done to
get his travel sorted to reach Toronto
so stamina is definitely not on his mind
because he's here a determined uh Nyack
a very determined n back such a
phenomenal player I think it's hard not
to root for him but Wesley so has many
fans out there as he trades off those
dark Square Bishops so minimal pieces
remaining that may seem like good news
for not because white can't attack the
weak Pawn without pieces of his own so
both players are handling this very well
whatever winning chances Wesley hopes to
have are in the long term but in the
short term it seems like nybeck with the
lead on the clock playing excellent
chess and now he has to worry about two
different pawns see Wesley he's poking
and prodding yeah
and the good thing in this position for
black is that the White Knight doesn't
have too many squares to jump into the
game to start putting pressure on that
black E5 Pawn so Wesley has managed to
maximize his pressure with the Rook but
there isn't another assistance coming in
to attack the weaknesses meanwhile nbec
his own Knight can start jumping into
enemy camp Knight C4 in the
air possibly yeah maybe he needs to act
uh aggressively and actively here
because suddenly you don't want to curl
up and be passive a big weakness on the
C6 square and critical moment wesle so
throwing a spanner in the works hitting
this Pawn your move Tanya I guess would
force the white Rook to decide do you
step back defend this Pawn do you slide
across with a check Suddenly It's
getting a bit tactical this check could
mean that you eat this Pawn you grab
this Pawn with gain of time next move
I'm not sure where the black king goes
but you can take this Pawn hit the black
Rook right now Rook C8 Rook C8 you have
to do something with this bishop yeah
maybe it's working out for black uh
maybe this Pawn will simply drop next
move but this is what they're
calculating right now and uh the
alternative I guess for Wesley so there
is to just drop back defend and say how
are you defending this one not too easy
because the Rook might get overloaded he
does play Knight C4 does Notre backck
and he's going to have a difficult next
choice because you bring a rook to C8
then you've lost sight of the E5 pawn
and I can kick your knight out of C4 go
right after that E5 Pawn thank you very
much for the material so these decisions
are really difficult for nck and that's
why I tell people at home that when you
have the eval bar it doesn't always tell
the full story because nock's on the
defensive here and Wesley knows it he
knows it he gives a check not the move
we were thinking not keeping control
maybe he's calculated something maybe he
realizes that this Pawn is Juicy he
wants to by force snap it off the board
so a check and uh the black king has to
decide you normally don't want to go
towards the edge of the board ever in
chess and especially in an end game
where you want to be centralized I'm
assuming the black king will step
towards the center but the question is
what happens here there's a tactic I
think at the end here Wy wants to play
Bishop to B5 and after Knight takes B2
there's Rook F3 and all of a sudden
you're being met by G4 or Rook takes F5
with Bishop B7 check but no I'm wrong
because Wesley decides to go a different
direction he just pushes the pawn that
was under attack but there all sorts of
tactics in the air here wow suddenly
getting really really uh kind of
concrete suddenly it's not about these
general principles that we've been
discussing it's about whether black can
kind of survive hold on move by move
especially this C6 pawn it might just
drop yeah you do not want to go to the
edge of the board ever your knight will
simply be pinned here and stuck here
defending a mere porn so that's the last
thing on Abdus soro's mind right now
Knight attacked porn attacked and he's
on the back foot NC doesn't Retreat he
doesn't go backwards so I want to ask
you a question is a knight to D2 a
possibility it gives a check but I can
very well end up getting or losing
material also after giving a check on D2
White's King will step forward putting
pressure on that Knight The Pawn on C6
still hanging and I'm trying to figure
out do you move back with the Knight to
the center of the board do you know what
tells the biggest story even more so
than the moves that are being played I'm
looking at the clock n der was up
several minutes and now he makes the
wrong choice goes to the edge of the
board and Wesley at any moment can push
his bwn one more time Kick That Knight
out of there to win the C6 Zone but I
like what Wesley is doing he's not
rushing he's not giving he squares back
to nyb Knight on the rim is looking dim
here and these pawns still are a problem
for black the Knight looks dim the
position looks Grim he's pushing forward
with his pawns but uh I always talk
about the theory of two weaknesses in
Middle games end games here black has
the horrible Pawn structure all of them
isolated now the second weakness is just
the placement of his Knight Wesley can
play against that long term he's happy
to trade off the other minor pieces
because if you compare the final pieces
remaining uh the white Bishop will
always dominate this Black Knight on the
edge of the board so a check if this
Knight is not captured it will simply
slide back blockade Black's Central Pawn
this is really classy stuff from Wesley
so this is where he thrives and I still
think nck is really going to need
something special to save this game
that's really great technique there
because when you trade it's not just
about the pieces that you've traded but
what remains on the board and if you
compare the white Bishop to that black
knight it's clearly superior to the
Knight which will be on the defense but
also Utterback does not have an option
he has to go for this bishop takes
Knight Rook takes Bishop there's still a
big threat of that B Pawn moving one
step forward and deflecting uh the
defender of the C6 Pawn B4 how do you
fight it and let's not forget that the
E4 Pawn is also on a light square and
white has a light score Bishop so G5 is
a great choice from no dearbeck it
allows him to bring his King forward and
keep it attached to that pawn but Wesley
he's not going to rush love that move
Rook to G3 that Rook did not have much
real estate now it's going to slide to
the H file that's a fully open line to
work with the white king can step
forward at any moment the Black Knight
is not participating right now it's
merely a defensive piece he's undaunted
Wesley so his Rook was a bit stuck there
he's simply going to take his time out
here dropping back he's going to
reposition his Rook repurpose it I mean
this is just so so tough for black to
defend and you can tell looking at the
clock Abdu Tor look at the body language
as well scratching his head he can
barely find a move there's not that much
productive to do and sooner or later as
soon as that white Rook activates the
threats will increase so okay he
activates his own Rook trying to cut off
the white rook's access to open files
really clever move there but now the
black ewn has been abandoned yeah and
there was so much hesitation by nbec
before he made this move so he's
definitely feeling uncomfortable in this
end game and again I've been talking
about this idea of just winning the C6
pawn and I'm trying to get my head
around why has Wesley not already gone
for B4 and Bishop takes Pawn because
sometimes the pressure is actually the
way to beat these top GMS you can win a
pawn then give them activity he just
stole the pawn at the right moment so I
love the way he's played and no D does
look uncomfortable here he's trying to
will himself back in this game but he
lost a C6 Pawn E4 is now under attack
white has these outside pass pawns that
he's going to struggle to deal with he
brings his King forward maybe he wants
to go further even more but Wesley gives
a check so if the King goes forward Rook
G4 check will win the G5 pawn and look
how calm Wesley looks right now just his
body language and meanwhile n with the
the pce toing you can tell that you
don't even have to look at the board to
understand what the evaluation is you
can look at the players and you know
what's going on then again a bit of a
scratch on the head of Wesley so and
he's repeated the position the second
time we've seen this again the second
time we've seen this position if Wesley
gives a check he might have the option
to repeat but he is a porn up surely
with white he should be playing for the
win he might be worried though because
if the black Rook can successfully slide
to d8 in it comes to D2 and that white
king is forc back to its first Rank and
that can be scary where you are up
material but your opponent who has the
coordinated pieces that Rook on G3 is
actually quite misplaced in this
position it doesn't have too much wiggle
room so nyck he loses upon Pawn I don't
even want to say he gave it up I think
Wesley Al played him there but he still
has good chances yeah and Wesley he has
to decide ethical decision here do you
play for a win in a short two game match
with white a porn up but with a bit of
risk attached or do you take the draw
bail out now safety get closer to that
Armageddon he gives another check second
time we've seen this as well and he
plays on he plays for the win he's going
for it he wants more in this position
Wes so is up a pawn and he's trying to
get the match advantage in this one the
bishop is attacked watch out Rook on
coming to D2 as well once the bishop
moves but this is clever stuff from
Wesley he repeated once then he spent
his time he can bring his Bishop to
attack the Knight the problem is if the
black Rook gives a check he first
protects his Bishop so look what he's
doing every single move he's restricting
Black's access I think that's a nice try
but it's clear the Eva bar is not the
biggest fan it says the black is
actually holding on can you repeat here
immediately with just the king Shuffle
keep attacking the white Rook I think
Wesley has calculated well there if the
black king shifts over to attack White's
Rook the white Rook slides to the center
and look at the black pawn in the center
it will drop off and once the white Rook
takes it the Black Knight will also be
hit so actually he's kind of setting a
trap here Wesley so if the black king
moves white would have had a decisive
Advantage instead the pawn pushes
forward a vulnerable square but closer
to promotion now the white Bishop is
really stuck you cannot move it out the
way because the black Rook will
penetrate will drop down to D2 with a
check you need to keep the black Rook
passive and I think this is a really
really important move from NC and my
question was going to be what's Black's
next move and Wesley he poses the same
question if you can't actually improve
your pieces let's go push those pawns up
the board and noty back pushes his own
pawns so now white has access to a pass
Pawn he can in fact take that pawn on A5
if KN takes back down goes that E3 Pawn
in the center he takes it more pawns off
the board but pawns on both flanks more
importantly so the bishop better than
the Knight and now can he take on E3 can
he take the black PA sitting in front of
White's King if he can he simply two
pawns up and should win the game but
perhaps that Bishop is loose on D7 so
tin his idea from earlier King G6 just
to kick that Rook out of there so Wesley
might Retreat his Bishop now that Knight
is on the rim so Bishop back to B5 the
E3 Pawn is still a weakness maybe black
has to go go all in but you look at the
time right now Wesley he's down to about
40 seconds no deck at 53 both players
getting nervous wow if Wesley so
captures the pawn the most natural
looking move the black king just follows
the white rook and there is no way to
keep the B to keep uh the pressure on
for white and that one Wesley needs to
find a way to keep this game going if
it's not King takes Pawn how does he
keep the pressure he can't move the
bishop the black Rook will jump in how
do you continue the game I like Robert's
move move the bishop where you control
the Black Knight just keep that Black
Knight sidelined on the edge of the
board but he does take the pawn and now
will we see this dance between the black
king and the white Rook you have a check
on E6 but Wesley just repeating and is
he going to give a check on E6 next
that's the big question and he does give
that check there's no reason that he
should just force a draw if the king
moves back that white Rook can attack
the Black Knight this is getting very
messy though because that Knight can hop
around with some checks W he needs to be
careful at this stage yeah the white
Bishop is really stuck right now the
Knight is attacked but the Knight can
jump out the way with a check the Black
Knight has to save itself do not trade
off White's Bishop for that night white
is two pawns up and now the white King
has to walk into a pin attacking this
Black Knight but once the Black Knight
moves White's Bishop is it doomed but I
think he's giving up his Bishop he's
recognizing that if I can trade Rooks I
can't lose that end game even though
black has an extra Knight white at the
very least can go to the king side and
steal that last gep Pawn he's got past
Pawns of his own so it's going to be a
counting game and nobody back down to 25
seconds is that a pawn too dangerous
great practical decision from Wesley so
playing on testing nck zero risk still
for white surely he's going to defend
his Bishop now Wesley so the white Rook
can step up one square to hold the
bishop for a move longer yes that Bishop
Falls but Robert your idea go for that
black pawn now white has still three
pawns remaining the Black Knight is a
short range piece uh piece can it deal
with all three pawns wow and look at nck
he just sets aside all the pieces and it
is go time for both these players as
Wesley saw he has two seconds on the
clock he's burnt so much time the good
news was was it was a series of Trades
quick moves they gained 3 seconds per
move the Knight does chase this pawn and
so the question is can the Knight get
back in time if that were a bishop black
is holding because Bishops are longrange
pieces but that Knight might be slow to
get back and Chase down a potential pass
G pawn and here we go the pawns
disappearing and it does look like nodec
here will be safe it's only two pawns
now the Knight will deal with one the
king deals with the other Pake draw nck
survives what a fight Wesley did
everything he could to maximize his
chances but nck with some sneaky defense
in the end sacrificing the pawns gets
the job done for himself that's a draw a
final rapid game coming up as the score
remains level what a hold from no
dearbeck up you see him breathing out
for probably the first time in half an
hour what a save by him because he was
in huge trouble Wesley was pressing and
Out playing
him just fantastic fantastic resistance
there by nbec under so much tremendous
pressure Wesley declining repetitions
not once but twice but in the end nbec
he managed to secure that draw a really
critical Half Point save especially in a
best of two David yeah it was essential
to hold that game he was on the back
foot pretty much entire for its entirety
right from the opening nbec Abdu
sattorov and I just wanted to highlight
that flurry of moves in the beginning of
the game where Abdu satoro actually out
prepared his opponent Wesley so basing
his preparation on Wesley's Chesser ball
course and
launching a novelty a bit later so it
was here where black after a trade of
Pawns on D3 played Rook takes F2
initiating tactics but after some queens
were exchanged after black won the
sacrificed Rook due to this pin we saw
an end game and it was here already on
move 21 such deep preparation nybeck
played the novelty the First new move of
the game not covered in Wesley's Chesser
ball course and despite the fact that a
few moves down the line despite the fact
he had isolated pawns we pawns all over
the board he was able to hold black here
is in real difficulties but that half
Point could be Priceless it shows how
deep preparation is at this level in
this day and age but Maxim Vash gra Was
Right Wesley was in his comfort zone he
had the upper hand he almost converted
there he stole a pawn but nybeck
deserves a lot of credit he never gave
too much ground he was able to hold off
Wesley so really nice start for him with
the black pieces he gets white in game
two you might have to give the nod to
nck having the advantage going forward
it will be a set three game two the
final rapid game coming up uh this was
game one and the scores remain level
Magnus gton is already through to the
finals after he sends Fabiano Carana
back home with his victory and it is a
big big game two coming up with so much
on the line and for the players they
walk a tight Trope how much risk are
they willing to take in Toronto for that
fight to the finals and it is going to
be exciting between nbec and Wesley so
we will be
[Music]
back we are here in Toronto I am uh Kaa
excited for the CCT finals here with
Wesley so nice to be here in Toronto yes
it's good to I'm also very excited and
it's good to see you back after such a
long time only eight of you made it here
to Toronto so what makes you excited I
did very well last year hopefully it's a
good good sign and uh it's the same
place you know this one of my most
favorite pel from last year so hopefully
that's a good sign what are uh the fans
in for this week you know things are
going to happen very quickly right from
the very beginning there's a lot in
stake here so players are going to be
very competitive and uh obviously
sometime ago you learn that the finals
would be over the board what was your
reaction to that in I don't know if you
know but we're playing in a computer
right no no we're playing over the board
or playing in a real board yeah yeah oh
so you're learning that now yeah I was
quite confused I don't know what mag has
been doing playing online all this time
then but okay thank you yeah can you
describe your playing style when I was
younger I would always play one E4 and
play the Sicilian with black like I was
very aggressive I'd go for mating
attacks but I could not play the end
game and then when I turned 16 I
started reading a lot of opening books
and then when I reached 2 I 600 I
realized that you cannot just go for the
attack every single game and hope to win
because B 600s are not stupid they will
they will bring you down and what would
it mean to you to to Win It Wesley it
would be amazing uh my last ter of the
year it's really it's really a big deal
uh this year it's much stronger though
than last year you got Magnus you got
Sati you got hikaro so there's a lot in
St Wesley so thank you and good luck in
the CCT finals
it doesn't look like much but neither
would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
give the gift of Chess as we celebrate
the holiday season with the ches kit
there's a 20% off for the rest of the
year until the 31st of December for the
ches kid gold membership so get going on
go. chesskid.com
SL ck20 and use the command ck20 in chat
for all the
information and it is one chest kid
we've got our eyes on it's nbec Abdu
satro who's fighting for that spot into
the finals to face Magnus Carlson but
he's up against Wesley so the first game
nck under big pressure survives and Kaa
had a chat with him right after
that all right that was game one in set
number three how are you feeling right
now nck
feeling good but um yeah obviously my um
my you know my quality has been dropped
since yesterday so yeah I am a little
bit disappointed um but um yeah
obviously I have one game ahead and
that's was white pieces so I'm looking
forward to to put up some pressure yeah
it must have been so important to come
out of this game with a draw after
Wesley maybe coming into set number
three with momentum him after winning
set number two yeah it was important not
to lose and yeah he he came extremely
close at the end I think I was just
holding by you know some miracle but uh
yeah it it worked out well and um yeah
it's it's been just a pure luck at the
end so you definitely know how to win
games against Wesley so we saw that
yesterday what will you take from that
into game number two here well I think
we are a little bit I mean I'm a little
bit struggling with white so I will take
it um easy and we'll see do you think
this will go to an
Armageddon um most probably oh okay well
good luck in game number two thank you
thank you okay you heard him he thinks
this will go to an Armageddon we'll see
back to you guys really interesting
insights there into nyack's mindset he
says he survived by luck but make your
own luck on the chessboard and I think
he was very resourceful with the black
pieces in game one surviving a difficult
difficult game and he also said that
he's not feeling very confident with the
white pieces David yeah a bit of a
surprise because traditionally he's been
super strong with the white pieces and
maybe it's just influenced by today's uh
games often uh as chess players we have
this short-term memory we only really
remember what's just happened uh we need
to block out the rest because it uh kind
of it's just too much and yeah just
judging by his body language which he's
banking on the fact that a one game
shootout in Armageddon might be his best
opportunity he has beaten Hikaru
Nakamura in two Armageddon so I wouldn't
be surprised if that is his strategy
going into this next game nck has been
The Comeback Kid so far and he did lose
set two to Wesley it is momentum Wesley
but nck survives game one of set three
what what would you say are the chances
of this going into the Armageddon well
Notre seems like an extremely honest
person maybe too honest for his own good
when there's match strategy at play but
he says we're probably heading to
Armageddon I've struggled with the white
pieces I think he's taken us to
Armageddon so if everyone is excited for
that you should remain at the edge of
your seat I believe we're getting there
but what about Wesley I mean I don't
know if he heard that interview or not
when you know that your opponent is
feeling a bit shaky do you try to create
your chances Wesley's black we saw a
Nordic did with the white pieces in game
two of set two he went a little bit too
hard with the white pieces so I don't
think that Wesley is the type of player
who goes all in with the black pieces
when he doesn't need to I really think
that for Wesley it would be smart just
to play the position in front of him and
if Norbeck forces a draw there's nothing
you can do this is the final uh rapid
game of the best of two NB starts with
the white pieces the first game Wesley
is the one who put pressure is that also
something for nbec to think about the
fact that he really never managed to
equalize out of the opening till the
very end it was a tricky end game it
will be on his mind uh nbec I think we
saw it then his body language when he
was chatting with Ka he was mostly
relieved uh kind of slightly
disappointed because he did land some
decent opening preparation but in the
end he was suffering and uh I think he
should actually take Confidence from
that who cares uh your track record with
white just in the last few games white
is white after all you have the first
move Advantage but uh it's up to him I
mean he knows better than anyone how he
feels he only knows uh kind of his
estimations his calculations with risk
versus reward of playing with white now
going all in Armageddon in the end would
be a fair way to decide and uh maybe the
only way to decide these two Fierce
competitors so much on the line for
these two players so much at stake it is
about getting into that finals and play
against Magnus Carlson it all comes down
to this final rapid game will there be
an Armageddon or not nbec has shown so
much tenacity and so much determination
and he's had quite the journey to the
Champions chest finals let's take a look
at his road to getting here
nbec Abdus satarov a rising star in the
Chess World won division two in the
chessable Masters to qualify for
division one in the chess kid cup and he
immediately Rose to the challenge Notre
Beck is not going to miss this he solves
these for breakfast he solved these for
breakfast 7 years
ago good by it's res signable really
just clinical play here and there we
have it nck of the satov takes the match
against yordan van furest another great
move Knight D6 there was Rook d 7 just
integrating the tactics perfectly and
he's about to win a third Pawn that
might trigger
resignation Black Knight no good squares
for it to use and I think Fabby you can
tell body language there he leaned back
has he resigned he has Abdu satoro takes
the match in the Grand Final he plays
kowana yet again and with another
impressive match win Abdu satarov
emerges victorious in the chess kid cup
to qualify directly for the tour finals
Queen D2 is that the winning move
and that's it we have a winner n abdat
wins the CH kid cup with an impressive
performance throughout the season Abdu
satarov has earned a total of 325 tour
points the same as Carana in second
place on the standings the 19-year-old
is definitely someone to look out for in
Toronto and it was at the chesit cup
that nbec Abdu satro punched his ticket
to torono and what a path he's had along
the way knocked out Hikaru Nakamura and
he does fight for that spot into the
finals in this game too it's going to be
about his decision he did mention that
he would be okay to take this to the
Armageddon he's got the white pieces
will he push for more or will he just
block down uh all play and take it to
the sudden that Wesley so still to
arrive well for no de Beck as David said
he knows how he's feeling so he knows
best if he feels that his chances are
highest in Armageddon take us right
there force a draw get all of us to
Armageddon and for Wesley he's probably
not so thrilled that nck put up such
resistance in that game it was his chess
course after all it was very deep
preparation but it didn't land him a
full point yeah and what a fight this
has been right nck takes set one in
convincing crushing manner Wesley takes
set two in convinc and crushing manner
the first game a big fight a big uh
dramatic turnar around at the end saw
nbec survived that so it does look like
Armageddon would be the fair decisive
game for these two how else to separate
them simply and uh we see him there
staring off into the distance nbec I
wonder what's going through that mind
right now if he wants I think Wesley
wouldn't be averse Wesley is so
pragmatic especially with black uh to
that draw to taking it to Armageddon but
maybe he's thinking ahead into the
future that Armageddon bid his approach
there depending on whether he gets white
or black the problem with Armageddon you
might get get white anyway and if you're
struggling with white if you bailed out
with a quick draw with white would you
be feeling confident I just don't
remember the last time I saw n back play
for a draw but when's the last time you
heard him speak like that about how a
draw would be okay and he's struggling
with the white pieces so I just think
he's honest at the moment the handshake
the glasses are off will the gloves be
off that's the question that we all want
the answer to yeah was that a bit too
honest did not a be give away too much
of his mindset when he said that he
would be happy to take this into
Armageddon will Wesley be the one who
start getting ambitious the black pieces
did pay off in set to when Wesley had a
crushing crushing Victory and it's go
time it's 1 E4 are we going to see a
Berlin okay the knights are out and uh
Wesley still adjusting his pieces I hope
he said Jadu and uh okay his Knight is
out as well big moments ahead nbec does
bring his Bishop out it's the Spanish
opening it is the Berlin defense but
anti Berlin from NOC so no forced draw
yet if he wanted the draw straight from
the off he could have forced it there
and then and what's this bishop A4 move
a little cheeky try from Nock usually
you put your Bishop on A4 after a pawn
goes to A6 but he voluntarily places his
Bishop on A4 it eliminates some of these
Knight D4 lines where black just tries
to trade all off all the pieces in the
center so it's a funny game thus far
from these two no Force draw no direct
showing that he may want to play on yeah
he means business this Bish Bay for move
Robert uh I don't know why but I've had
the bad luck of being on the wrong end
of it a few times uh a few of my
opponents have played this one it just
keeps the tension takes out these Knight
D4 ideas quick D5 ideas no way for black
to break the immediate tension so we're
pretty much guaranteed a long
maneuvering game and uh I must be uh I
must admit I'm a bit surprised here it's
not consistent with nock's interview he
said a draw Armageddon pretty much it's
fine but he wants to fight he wants a
lot battle here and Wesley again the
first to think it was that little pawn
move when move number four when nck
played D3 going in for the anti Berlin
that seems to show that nbec is in for
the long game in this one and Bishop to
A4 that last move by nbec at least it
made Wesley go into a little bit of a
think and use up some of that clock
which is critical in these situations
it's not your standard line so for
Wesley he can't rely on all his
preparation and he does lash out with
Pawn to D5 this can ruin Black's Pawn
structure you may think with double
pawns but I would prefer to have the
bishop pair in an opening position so I
think that uh for ner backck he's more
likely to bring his Knight out from B1
out to D2 just defend that pawn in the
center I do not think he's capturing
that Knight on C6 with his Bishop yeah
and trading pawns off in the center also
has its downsides if white takes this
black pawn in the Middle with his own
Pawn black would have a space Advantage
so uh really tense position we mentioned
a lot of maneuvering ahead Wesley is the
one to try and clarify the tension he's
the one to try and trade things off uh
try and guide this game towards safety
Suddenly It's nbec thinking yeah I was
praising him a moment ago this bishop A4
move a nice sneaky one okay he keeps the
tension doesn't spend too long uh so
backing up this small surprise in the
opening yeah this one it feels like it's
going to simmer for a long long time
it's just about whether it eventually uh
explodes later on this middle game yeah
and not back continues with his
development uh not giving free play you
really don't want to trade on D5
allowing a weakness on D3 so keeping the
tension in the center but to my
understanding in these openings when
black does get a central break like D5
that's already a mini success for black
it is a success because you get activity
for your pieces most of these top
players don't like sitting passively but
one of the downsides is when you push to
D5 like he's done instead of a D6 your
E5 Pawn can be a bit tender uh he has it
all under control thus far thanks to his
Rook on E8 and Wesley takes away uh the
G5 Square from any of White's pieces for
nir Beck often times you bring your
queen out to E2 or your Rook to E1 but
this is a draw that we could possibly
see you got Rook E1 Knight G4 we've seen
that in so many different positions
where someone goes after the F2 Pawn The
Rook slides back and the Black Knight
slides back as well I I'm just you know
joking here but it is possible that if
the players don't really want to
continue this game there are ways to get
this back and forth three-time
repetition which means it would be a
draw I just wonder if nbec wanted that
early draw would he have gone for an
anti Berlin would he have not just gone
for the trades the normal burlin and
kind of secured it faster yeah I think
we were all a bit thrown off we were all
a bit speechless we thought this might
be a short game but suddenly the players
really digging deep all pieces all pawns
on the board Clarity far uh far away
right now and uh Robert you're kind of
joking but not really joking about this
uh this maneuver because if nck does
play his Rook across one square right
now into the center rookie one probably
the most natural move in the position
black does have that option and we could
see a uh quick repetition so nobec may
be mulling over in his mind as well
whether to keep the fight alive whether
to uh play a move such as Pawn to H3 and
maintain the tension and uh yeah I also
just reminded of this interview we had
with Danny and Maxim Vash grav avoiding
the nbec death stair Wesley throughout
today he has had his hand on his head
just uh breaking eye contact we see nbec
mirroring that uh body language right
now yeah Wesley not so unbothered about
the that's there I think he's just not
been looking NC's way so if nck was to
choose the pawn move that you were
hinting at on the king side step up the
HB one step ahead that would at least
imply that he wants the game to go on
how ambitious it is if an approach we'll
find out later but at least it keeps the
game and keeps the tension on the board
so on the other hand if he slides in
with the Rook we might have a really
really quick road to the Armageddon and
he does slide in with the Rook but this
is moment number two because if Wesley
does go up with the Knight there is one
more way to defend the F2 Pawn Yeah The
Rook can slide up instead of back to
where it came from uh so Knight G4 is
the move that we have been discussing we
have seen this in high level games when
people would just want to make a draw
The Rook goes back to F1 and because the
Knight is not really doing anything on
G4 anymore it can go back to F6 and The
Rook slides back to E1 it's not really
notc Style to make a draw in this manner
and as was indicating you can bring your
Rook up into E2 rather than to the side
it's just a bit awkward to do that you
will play H3 kick the Knight back and
then probably move your Rook back to E1
anyway because it's on an awkward Square
so uh these are decisions that the
players don't take lightly and for
Wesley you look at him is he in a
fighting mood in this game does he
really want Armageddon because if we
believe what some of the people have
been saying he's the stronger player the
higher rated player the player with more
experience maybe he wants to try his
hand in a rapid game versus an
Armageddon game where the odds May tilt
in the youngster's favor yeah Magnus
mentioned in his interview earlier that
he likes to see it go down to the wire
if there is an option for the match to
continue longer we' all love to see more
chess but for now Wesley doesn't go for
the move that we were talking about
which could potentially invite a
repetition but instead he goes for the
pawn trade and now if nbec was to
recapture with the pawn the most natural
one we could still see the Knight
jumping onto G4 and similar lines yeah
Moment of Truth Wesley still has this
option Avail available to him and uh you
mentioned Magnus wanting to see more
chess Magnus also wants to tire out his
opponents before tomorrow because he
know uh he knows he's facing one of
these two he wants to see them push each
other to the Limit but Wesley doesn't go
for this uh night jump doesn't put
pressure on the F2 square instead gain
some space on the queen side prevents
white from advancing on that flank maybe
also activating the black Rook kind of
down and across the board we've seen so
many Rook swings Rook lifts this whole
tournament and I think he's justified in
playing on there's no reason to kind of
bail out to try and Escape there's no
reason that you're worse with black
simply and right now still pressure on
nbec to justify this whole opening why
should white be better here he moves his
Queen gets off the first Rank and uh
just looks very level very even to me it
is indeed and we've seen this type of
position at the highest level in the
Madrid candidates in 2022 hikara
Nakamura Tamor rajabov had a similar
structure like this with a Pawn on A5
it's good because it stops white from
flashing out with Pawn to B4 and gaining
some space but it gives the B5 Square to
White that A5 Pawn can be targeted
especially if the Knight on D2 hops out
to C4 so this may seem quiet the eval
bar may be right in the middle but just
like game one there could be more to it
that meets the eye and both players do
need to keep a watchful eye on different
squares and different pieces and Robert
you were in Toronto last year where
Wesley went on to win the event do you
feel that he's in the similar mindset do
you feel he's got the same Focus same
Zen with all respect meant towards every
single other player that was in Toronto
last year a certain player wasn't Magnus
Carlson so I keep saying it and it's not
even because I want to root for anybody
I never do as a commentator but when
Magnus Carlson plays on even terms with
everyone else he is the favorite so
Magnus was not there last year Hikaru
was there to really nicely played match
from Wesley to take down iar Nakamura
when most people thought iar would win
the whole thing so Wesley that was his
really shining performance in his career
but Magnus wasn't there so I don't think
the mindset is similar and by Wesley's
own words he said he just wanted to
finish I think top six or something like
that he's doing way better than that
yeah absolutely and that was at the
start when we had had a chat with Wesley
asking about his Ambitions in this
tournament and he revealed that he'd be
happy to just make it to survival to be
in the top six but the chest that he's
produced the aggressive play that we've
seen him all throughout the round robin
stage going on up until even today what
we saw it again it just feels like a
very different Wesley not the solid
Wesley not the one who's just waiting
for his opponents mistakes but the one
who's provoking those mistakes with
active player yeah and uh we should also
remember that there's so much at stake
in this game alone uh you talked about
Wesley trying to come top six now he
wants to come top two minimum the the
difference between second and Joint
third place for the player who's
eliminated here is an incredible amount
of money tens of thousands of dollars
and that's life-changing uh I mean
especially for someone so young as ABD
stov but also for Wesley it could really
set him up um yeah plenty of stake both
players fearing defeat but also
desperate to win I wonder if that's on
their mind because there's a $50,000
difference so if a player wins this game
they secure themselves minimum
$100,000 the loser well they'll take
some Solace with a 50k still a great
prize day for them but that's a lot of
money at stake and that could make
people more nervous it's a lot of money
but I think for these two players right
now they're not thinking about any of
that they're not even thinking about
meeting Magnus in the finals it's the
position on the board it's about getting
through this very match uh and for that
the big question is will it be decided
on this one will the players try to push
there is no margin for eror this is a
best of two this is the final rapid game
or will they take it more kgy more
cautious approach taking it down to the
arm but in this format You Can't Hide
for too long from a decisive result You
Can't Hide for too long and we did see a
shake of the head from Wesley so briefly
uh before he tried to uh revert to that
poker face and I think it might be
because White's position has been
improving blacks less so or at least
less obviously so Wesley's messed around
a bit uh especially this last Rook move
a bit mysterious the black Rook on B8
unless he's throwing pawns down the
board here and now then that could just
be a Superfluous move meanwhile white
has AED the dream setup in any Spanish
opening or Italian opening the two white
Knights love to park themselves on these
squares F3 G3 and great attacking
potential for abdor suddenly and as da
likes to say if you do step a you have
to continue with step B Rook B8 hints at
the move B5 but I don't think that black
can get away with it at least not in a
way that Wesley would prefer because
there's a queen on E2 and a bishop on A4
teaming up on that square there will be
some tactics here but B5 Bishop takes B5
this has to to be calculated and the
engine is also saying slightly better
for white so not the end of the world
but Knight D4 tactics it's really the
ones you try to uncork white can take
this back with the Knight which does
protect that Bishop over there on B5
there will be some trades in the center
but white temporarily at least is up a
pawn black would have to prove the
compensation yeah this is not Wesley's
style to sacrifice specul speculatively
like this and try and hope that he gains
enough compensation later on maybe he
does because the black Rook on the B5 so
active the black Rook on the E file so
active uh this Pawn is extremely weak
but yeah it's hard to envisage him going
for this one right now B5 it looks like
the consistent followup but he's
hesitating the longer he thinks the less
inclined he'll likely be towards that
pawn push and what else you would love
to kind of copy white and put the sorry
my arrows are going funky there put the
Black Knight over on G6 but the problem
is the E5 Pawn might be hanging on the
way so after a trade of Bishops you'd be
forced to take back with the Knight just
to hold this pawn and suddenly it looks
a bit clumsy these two knights are
clearly inferior to whites stallions on
the king side and yeah it just feels
like you might get tied up in knots so
what's he going for he plays Bishop to
D6 another clumsy move the Bishop looked
active now it's very much passive but
it's all to do with this Knight maneuver
next he wants to bring his Knight over
to the king side and it's also a trade
that you want right you want to get out
of this uh potential pin but also get
out of this uh light s Bishop Dynamic
that exists Knight E7 would offer the
bishop trade and allow a more free hand
on the queen side for Wesley to go
forward I do like the idea of knight7
Bishop D6 a retreating move but uh it
comes with a plan I just don't see why
Rook B8 was necessary like Bishop D6
makes perfect sense to me you want to
wrap your knight around and if he can
successfully get that Knight to G6 I do
believe he's equalized but I think he's
shaking his head because he feels that
Rook B8 was inaccurate doesn't actually
have a point to it and for white right
now for nyb he needs to play precisely
because if he doesn't keep up uh this
pull in the position it will just be
neutral territory will be equal maybe
move like Rook D1 I think that does make
Knight E7 harder to accomplish because
after Knight E7 if I take on D7 once
again you can't take with the queen
because the E5 Pawn is vulnerable there
and the engine gives up a pawn no
problem I would be looking at this and
saying what did I just do the engine
just doesn't
care all right it's a moment for nbak to
think if he wants to play Prof itic
chest there's also ideas uh that black
has with this move Rook B8 which you
often describe as a mystery move in
these openings it kind of is preemptive
of Pawn advances of expansion on the
queen side and then suddenly Rook B8
does make a little bit of a sense I
think it's one of those slow moves that
in the beginning it's harder to
understand but once the pawns start
moving down the board you're like okay
this I'm glad I have my Rook on B it
yeah the top players they somehow make
these mysterious moves work sometimes
they play a move it look looks a bit
silly and then 10 moves 20 moves down
the line you're like oh wait that was
the point so you might be right Tanya
and Abdu satoro seems to agree that
you're right because he's blocked the
advance of the black B Pawn the Black
Knight goes back now as predicted if we
see a trade of Lights squ Bishops yes
White's left with the superior Bishop
but uh the more pieces off the board the
less cramped black is look at this
maneuver nbec preempting Black's
decision to try and rout that Knight to
the king side now he's trying to land
his own Knights maybe into the f five
square interesting idea Knight on F5
dark Square Bishop for white that has
the makings of an attack so you do need
to be careful if you're Wesley you want
to trade on your own terms and trading
off light squore Bishops that should
favor white and if you ever push your
Pawn to C6 to keep your light score
Bishop on the board you're keeping those
pieces that's true but you're also
creating weaknesses for yourself so
these are not easy decisions I like not
back's clock usually when he's ahead by
a couple minutes it's when he's playing
his best chess and putting the pressure
on Wesley in game three of set two
earlier today nybeck was down two
nothing he had the black pieces he was
up on time he even made a mistake that
let Wesley back in the game but Wesley
didn't have enough time at the end and
Norbeck brilliantly won that one so I do
like the clock management for ab satarov
all right uh happy with the clock
management here for nbec uh it is about
whether the bishop stay alive or not and
they don't they do get traded off and
Wesley continues to offer trades right
now Queen to D seven if that's taken off
the board we're going to see black
trying to get those pawns moving up
meanwhile white that attack that you're
talking about without the Queens it
loses uh teeth yeah and a trap in the
position that's always a bonus uh just
to mention there is a pawn up for grab
suddenly we see the point of Wesley's
move Rook B8 he's saying oh no my pawn
and if white goes and takes this Pawn
The Rook goes back where it came from
and suddenly oh know my queen the queen
is trapped on the edge and uh really
sneaky idea there um you mentioned that
Tanya after Queen to D7 if the Queens
disappear I think black has no problems
whatsoever the pawn will land on A4 the
pawn will come to B5 the Black Knight is
actually poised perfectly to start
hopping into some holes in the white
position and this would be dead level so
if NOC here wants to maintain some
tension wants to play for the win I
think he might be forced to retreat but
suddenly black has uh certainly gained
something in this exchange white has
lost a bit of time and uh whether that's
advancing with the black pawns on the
queen side whether that's planting the
black Bop back on a nice diagonal before
the white Bishop reaches this Square on
E3 I think Wesley has solved his
problems I think he's equalized it's all
about those holes because the D3 square
like you mentioned the F5 Square for
White Knight and neither nyck or Wesley
I mean they don't know the evaluation
here whether to trade Queens how equal
is it it looks equal it should be with
best play but you never know if one side
has a slight advantage and for nir
backck he typically doesn't like trading
down and just accepting that at its
equal he may have some Ambitions but now
he takes the queen and he may be sending
us to armag again looks likely at this
point yes the White Knight has landed on
F5 but there's no attack uh con
connected to it because the Queens are
off the board I don't think it's really
a strategic threat to even take this
black Bishop Black's Bishop is clearly
inferior to White's Knight right now and
uh yeah it wouldn't damage the black
pawn structure too severely longterm I
think Wesley will either move his bishop
move the Black Knight maybe even start
pushing some in the next couple of moves
and really hard to imagine either side
winning this one not a back statement
from that interview earlier seems like
we're getting closer to that as the
pieces get traded off the board White
Knight has found its active spot black
without any problem here white without
any weakness here if anyone I think
black can try to push if you think about
Pawn breaks here Wesley might be the one
who might start thinking again about the
Thematic break with B5 B4 would that
give any chances for black in the sun
game get some activity that's for sure
but anytime you play for a win in a
position like this you could be playing
for a loss to some extent because
throwing all your pawns forward it
leaves holes behind s sound like Stanley
yellets I'm just talking about holes all
the time but uh this position remains
all zeros it looks like that Knight can
take the bishop on D6 at some moment
white can push the pawn to F3 keep
everything under control I'm not too
worried for Nock or for Wesley both of
them are with a steady hand it's
equal and to make it more equal perhaps
nbec will offer a bishop trade on E3
because if you compare pieces that black
Bishop on C5 to me it looks more active
than the White's bishop and you also
need to get that A1 Rook into the game
we've been talking so much about nock's
end game technique and how that kind of
separates him from his colleagues and uh
his generation just because he willingly
goes into end games and seems to outplay
from these minuscule advantageous
position sometimes the advantage isn't
even clear how does a player really
improve his end game technique at t a
young age well it's impressive uh I
think NOC one of his big strengths in in
the end game is his calculation he's
especially good in end games with small
imbalances he's especially good in Queen
end games where he very forceful where
uh he can kind of work out his path
concretely um in general it's just about
practice these uh end games there are
books out there there are Chesser ball
courses on end games U I'm not going to
name drop one of mine but uh but uh yeah
in general it's all about practice the
more you play End games and nbec plays
so many games throughout year um the
more you learn essentially and he's
practicing against the best he's
learning from the best playing against
Magnus playing against Wesley Nakamura
all these fantastic endgame players and
that's what's made him so good today at
such a young age and it's one of those
hardest things to improve on right
because like you were saying it's about
experience the play uh the amount of
times you've actually faced an end game
against a top player and for him at this
young age to get so strong at it it's
really a unique quality about uh his
chess and unlike openings where they
start from the beginning of the game and
you just make moves to get that
practical training exercises from an end
game what is an end game that you should
be studying what does a position look
like there's this famous book endgame
strategy by Mel sherfy that I
recommended time and time again really
wonderful it looks like just this
position most players would just shake
hands and you see one side
outmaneuvering the other and you have to
look what are the pluses what are the
minuses what are some squares that I can
take advantage of right now I love
Wesley's move H5 that he played because
he wants to follow with his G Pawn
pushing and he's not going to hang a
Pawn on the right hand side of our board
so I think that you know to study end
games like this you go to a position
like this and you play it out maybe with
a friend U you just train a little bit
maybe even against the engine and see
how you do requires so much patience and
we've seen so many tactical finishes in
in both of their matches but to me the
most one of the most impressive was from
set one this end game that nbec actually
converted and Wesley himself he's a
technical expert but n back in that two
versus one rook and night end game just
outplayed and managed to win that and
that can be really terrifying right now
both players of course playing very slow
and I think this is a very level game
and it just comes down to how much they
actually want to continue with this will
they take risks will they start pushing
pawns at some point to create chances
you have to push pawns you have to push
pawns but where and uh remember pawns
don't move backwards so you don't want
to push too far that the pawns become
weaknesses or the squares behind them
become weaknesses and uh you can see
that Wesley's pushed his Rooks pawns the
black a and black H pawns because those
only gain space nothing really serious
is Left Behind and uh yeah right now a
bit of a decision whether to chop off
that Knight or not Wesley says no the
White Knight looked like it was about to
become Strong by jumping into the center
but I'm going to uh fend off any threats
there I'm going to cover all the squares
and yeah actually if anyone I like the
progress that Wesley's making he's
gained space he's covered squares
there's easy plans the black king is
going to centralize in end games it's
all about these mini plans small plans
of improvement first improve the pole
structure second improve the pieces uh
that type of thing and feels like both
sides uh both players are just well
versed in this I'm with David there just
aren't any imbalances here the bishop
can take this Knight on E3 if you're
looking this from the perspective of
Wesley so but you would want to do that
if you could take control of a light
Square when your opponent has a bishop
it's inherently limited to that color
compx you want to take advantage of the
other complex as a knight can jump from
color to color but there aren't squares
to take advantage of here there's only
one open file we saw one pair of Rooks
trade we'll likely see another pair of
trade once that Bishop gets out the way
and without material remaining on this
board just seems like there's not too
much life left and you can see by their
movement here trades are about to happen
I think we're heading to Armageddon
we've been saying that for a while and
it looks like it's going to become a
reality soon and that last night move it
looks you might be asking why why is
nbec not developing that Rook on A1 it
will develop if Wesley does decide to
trade on B3 you do land up on the open
file so Wesley delaying that decision
keeping the tension on the queen side
and I think neither players are going to
Blink with a trade with that a and the B
Pawn Yeah black definitely doesn't want
to trade and develop the white Rook for
his opponent on an open file without
even forcing The Rook to move and
likewise white will not trade off
because white will be left with those
split pawns we all learned from that
bowling analogy
from Robert do not split the pawns but
wow really ambitious I will say pushing
the pawn to B4 uh bypassing Black's aorn
because now we talked about some uh
loose squares and it's about those light
squares the C4 Square was ready and ripe
for the Black Knight to jump into he
puts his Knight on the rim to prevent
the Black Knight hopping wow Abdus
satoro putting pay to these uh
assumptions we're making and that's the
problem is when you assume when you get
complacent and your opponent's still uh
going going on then you can lose track
of the position you can lose the plot
and I've had games just like this where
I just assume it should be a draw and
here comes the dark score Bishop for
white now that Knight was threatened so
Wesley jumps back to the last Rank and
I'm looking at the clocks as well nybeck
has a healthy lead on time if you can
poke and prod and create maybe a little
hole maybe a weakness the A4 Pawn in
particular he could possibly play for a
win at this stage and if you are playing
for a win do you want to trade off the
Lost PA of Rooks H tough question I well
I love and hate that you both looked at
me at the same time because it's so
difficult who wants to trade the Rooks I
would say maybe white now just because
with Rooks off the board Black's awn
looks like a bit of a uh bit of a Target
it looks like it's just stepped a bit
too far that's why I was so surprised
earlier that Wesley pushed the pawn uh
we were talking about Pawn's not moving
backwards it's so committal I have
commitment issues a lot of people will
tell you that but yeah that black porn
could live to regret the day that
it stepped onto White's half of the
board and yes the King has comeing to
the center but Moment of Truth can Abdu
satov trade Rooks off he's in no rush to
because he can play Rook D1 at any
moment and there's only one open file
Black's Rook sits on that file he can
play a little bit on the king says so
Rook G1 one of those moves that make
your intentions clear or so you think am
I really going to push that jeep on at
least you're going to have to calculate
it so for nir Beck he can trade off the
Rooks right now that will simplify the
position that A4 Pawn is hard to T white
doesn't have too many pieces remaining
and that's all that black needs to make
sure it's defended and we've been trying
to understand the mindset of these two
players do they want more do they want
to go into the Armageddon will we see a
quick draw will this go on to be a grind
and I think it's that cautiously
ambitious approach that we're seeing
he's still keeping the tension the the
play does go on and there are still
these small nagging problems for black
to be solved on the queen side you
pointed out that a pawn the Bishop from
E3 now quite an active piece the pawn on
B4 limiting Black's own dark Squad
Bishop from activity and yes the only
open line is captured by Wesley's Rook
but that King onu it takes away all
penetrating squares yeah uh right now it
looks like white stabilized and I can
tell by our voices we've liked the kind
of last few moves the way they've gone
in White's favor but Wesley still not
too many weaknesses and now he's asking
he's offering a trade of knights and uh
I think if the knights disappear
probably uh the remaining winning
chances disappear with the
but uh at this point who knows abdor
playing on I just wanted to ask now
we're around the three minute Mark for
both who's impressed you the most when
the clocks have ticked
down definitely no dear back for me I
think that Wesley sometimes panics we
saw that in set one in that end game
where he was holding on for dear life
and then unfortunately for him he went
wrong very late in that game and here
he's R doing everything perfectly and
he's keeping 2 minutes 44 seconds on his
clock so I think just in terms of time
trouble I would take n deer back in a
scramble yeah I'd agree with you Robert
I think he's just shown nerves of Steel
throughout he doesn't let the get
doesn't let the nerves get to him nck
we've we just saw it today itself right
this crazy position with black king and
with nck King out in the open how he
went on to play and convert that into a
win he's taken so many Armageddon and I
think he's been he's been just Fearless
with just seconds on the clock yeah
fearless and Wesley offers no I was
going to say a rook trade the way he
moved the piece there was a bit
unorthodox I thought he touched his Rook
he takes with the bishop so leaving the
tension now it's actually white who
holds the defile for now and nck really
ambitiously pushes his Pawn forward to
B5 that has totally removed the option
now of black touching Queens side pawns
Black's a pawn is a huge Target long
term uh actually if the Rooks disappear
maybe white would be winning this
suddenly and he's pushing all of the
pawns forward on light squares notice
because white has a dark Square Bishop
therefore he wants to control both color
complexes B Bishop dark squares pawns
light squares Wesley maybe feeling a bit
uncomfortable the problem for nirb and
he's playing this so extremely well he
doesn't have pieces to attack that A4
Pawn with there's only one open file The
Rook on D1 is doing a good job there but
he keeps pushing his pawns then that
black work will slide up to A5 and
challenge those pawns so it does feel
like NC has made progress and yet I'm
not sure where to next yeah it looks
nice and beautiful but that's always the
tough thing when it's almost symmetrical
the pawn structure when there's no clear
weaknesses when it's the same uh kind of
balance of pieces both here with rook
and dart Square Bishop you need some
kind of uh targets you need those two
weaknesses here black has zero
weaknesses to probat so still should be
a draw but he's going for it nbec he's
really going for it he's just pushed
that pawn all the way to C5 now that
white king is about to arrive on C4 and
to me it just looks like Wesley has
allowed too much to happen you were
talking about no piece assisting white
to attack A4 that King King is a piece
in the end Game King C4 King B4 and
suddenly I'm putting pressure yeah
really ambitious move and black does
have the option now of coming back with
his Rook giving a check kicking back the
white king but a rook trade and suddenly
Black's Pawn would be helpless the white
king would be superior and Wesley he's
pushing forward creating a route in for
the black Rook really clever play there
from Wesley so that he's going after the
E4 Pawn he went F5 earlier so if the
white king starts running on over to try
to grab that A3 Pawn you'll lose sight
of the E4 PA so Rook one is there going
to be a pawn push to C6 you have to be
careful because if there's a rook behind
a pawn you can maybe even sacrifice a
piece to free it and spring it to the
other side I actually think Rook A4 here
would be a pretty big blunder from
Wesley he can't get away with that yeah
and this is really storming up right now
both players under two minutes Wesley
under a minute and a half right now and
this is the most exciting the game has
gotten so many structural changes black
has pushed that pawn all the way to A3
where it is a glaring weakness you
always need to watch out he loses that
pawn that could be close to just a match
over yeah it's suddenly heating up and
it's not heating up in the typical way
with attacks checkmates it's heating up
in terms of the fact that Wesley is
walking a tight RPP he's got to avoid
certain uh kind of pitfalls here and he
trades a set of Pawns this doesn't
damage too much hesitation from nbec he
takes back and okay attacking White's
pawns now still feels like this could
switch this could flick um just uh tur
in either Direction with one mistake but
right now do you push a pawn do you
defend that pawn big questions for nbec
or do you go for the Armageddon with
King to C4 Rook gives a check King comes
back Rook goes back we'll find out who's
ambitious here oh but then the Rook
black Rook could get in Via B4 and come
in behind Okay The Rook does try to come
behind but first having forced White's
Rook into passivity really tense
position how does either side make
progress It's not obvious anymore if you
gave black some free moves I'm not sure
what he's going to do so look a small po
PA move and Wesley brings his King back
I think white can bring the Rook up to
B3 just keeping an eye on that A3 Pawn I
think that neither side can really
budget this stage they might have to
shuffle back and forth I don't see any
inroads yeah White's Bishop is tied down
defending the C5 Pawn White's Rook is
tied down defending B5 White's King is
tied down defending White's Central Pawn
it looks like he might have maximized
Abdu satoro here he's really pushed
everything forward especially on the
queen side but no further and Wesley so
is just yo-yoing back and forth with the
black king he's got simple waiting moves
will we see a plan will we see a winning
idea from the youngster here Rook back
to B1 that hints at the answer being no
the Rooks come from this square and
Wesley continues to wait with his King
as well and I think it comes down to
this now both players maximized the
position as much as they can tie down
each other's pieces and nbec says that
this is it it goes into
Armageddon we got a big one coming up a
level game throughout that's what
happens when two of the best players
play top level chess it ends in a draw
and goes down to sudden death I was
going to say there's little separating
them there's nothing separating them
right now it's an even score we are
heading to armag again you see them
considering they're talking to each
other and laughing they got to focus on
their
bids of course no that's not going to
happen 10 15
minutes
15 Wesley wants some extra time good
negotiator is it
545 is 6:00 good 6:00 or 65 and they're
figuring out when the next when the
Armageddon
started and finally Wesley get are you
guys okay with
605 okay 605 no is that good for you 605
so that's gives you 20 minutes okay NC
literally doesn't care so 605 I'm ready
and now they've got it put down a bit
and it's incredible to see the good
spirits both players are in despite
there being $50,000 being on the line
for the next game one player will be
eliminated one will go through 50,000 is
the minimum differential between them
but both looking chilled especially
Wesley so and that's got to be on their
mind that's a very chill Wesley pose
right now he's probably been listening
to some Loa Girl music right before
writing down his bid an Armageddon worth
50,00
coming up yeah I'm not sure if that's
chill or exhaustion but this is a stone
cold nordbeck Abdus satarov he was not
going to let this match go we head to
Armageddon who gets white who gets black
that's the only question that
remains you need to okay he's you can
just use your if that's okay thank
you and shout out to Judith our great
Arbiter there for keeping the players in
such great spirits not
feeling and make sure you Circle the
color please okay they had to circle the
color they have tole
white write down their bed okay that's
good and wow let I can't wait to see no
it's good okay o it all comes on to this
the semi-final battle goes into our
motten and not back he's looking have to
still reveal okay shatani Levy there
everyone's getting ready the tension is
on NC first to leave the playing Arena
and this is what they're fighting for
that final final space to fill in it
will either be Wesley so or nbec Abdu
sato's name and they will fight in the
title match against Magnus Carlson after
a big Armageddon we were talking about
momentum we've been discussing who does
it favor Wesley takes the second set to
day then two level games ending in a
draw it feels like an absolute reset and
the Armageddon all momentum everything's
been thrown off it could be anyone's
battle it's a marathon we saw Wesley so
slouched in his chair and I don't think
that's him chilling we do love lowii
girl but I think that's him just tired
he has been having to calculate so much
nck is Relentless even when we think it
might be a draw he keeps it going so
both players they may be on their last
bit of energy that adrenaline have to
kick in as we head Armageddon and for
one of these players this will be their
last game in the Champions CH off finals
Stakes are super high the tension has to
be super high right now as well
tension's high they have to rely on
their last reserves of energy the
adrenaline is guaranteed to pump in the
Armageddon game they will have been
playing for 6 hours by the time this
Armageddon starts so marathon is the
right word and it just comes down to who
has more left in the tank and no de back
abdar mean he seems like he's always
full of energy it doesn't matter if he
was stuck in a foreign city for a week
just struggling to get his Visa it
doesn't matter if he's playing six hours
in chess he's always ready to go he does
It For the Love of the Game wow and
you've got to be loving the game right
now as it goes down to the wire between
these two in our David game two it was
quite a slow strategic fight what stood
out to you yeah I'm going to pick out a
very different type of moment than we're
used to from these match highlights
because this one was devoid of any
tactics minimal calculation no attacks
whatsoever it was about small strategic
advantages just long-term weaknesses and
I just wanted to highlight this one
position as a indicator of nbec Abdus
tor's strength and ambition in end games
here with white plenty of us myself
included would have been happy to just
sit and pretty much do nothing there is
no real way forward for white and uh I'm
just trying to find my mouse but simply
white could wait with the Rook with the
King instead he pushed forward with Pawn
to C4 five and once the black Bishop
fell back he decided to run forward with
the white king it looks like he's
actually getting towards the queen side
but Wesley so showing his tenacious side
his resourcefulness by pushing a pawn
forward and activating the black Rook as
we saw in the game in the final position
simply no way forward for either side
the white king is stuck defending black
the white Central Pawn the white Rooks
are stuck defending the far Advanced
pawns on the be and SE files and
therefore it was a draw but nbec did
push as hard as he could Unstoppable
force me immovable object it seems like
nb's always ready for the fight he gives
it his all every time but Wesley one of
the most precise players in chess
history he's not going to break that
easily yeah I can't imagine a reality
where Wesley actually breaks but not
back he's been putting the pressure on
when he gets the opportunity it is a lot
on the line for these players and before
uh we reveal the bid we are going to
Toronto where Danny James and Levy will
be breaking down the action and the
drama coming in from the playing Arena
punches are coming up in the Armageddon
gloves are
[Music]
on I'm here with nck up to satoro
finally in Toronto after a crazy travel
how many days have you been traveling to
get here so I traveled to Berlin in on
November 30
wow so it's like more than a week
finally I got the Visa yesterday and
just I'm really really happy what is in
store for the fans watching this week
there will be a lot of um exciting games
a lot of those moments where you know
where you will never uh forget I think
this is the most like dream tournament
for chess fans this a lot of action and
a lot of um excited and imagine uh some
days from now you are standing there as
the winner of the Champions chess tour
2023 what would that mean to you it's a
long way to to to get there but I would
be just um incredbly happy and you know
this would be my biggest individual
achievement I think finally for any new
fans watching can you please describe
your playing style pretty much all super
Grand Masters uh are are you know are
Universal so I would say I'm a universal
player and um I like to to calculate a
lot and that's kind of my style well nor
we appreciate so much your efforts to
get here to Toronto I hope you get some
rest before it starts and we wish you
best of luck thank
you it doesn't look like much but
neither would a Sicilian Defense to the
untrained eye this is a performance
enhancer you don't see it how about now
manage your air quality sharpen your
performance change the game with air
things a new opening for your wall is
here capture new major pieces on unique
metal posters from displate now with the
official collection from chess.com Mount
them in seconds with a toolfree magnet
kit and swap them whenever you like make
your move get an exclusive discount on
all metal posters shop now with the code
Chess at displate.com
[Music]
[Laughter]
we are back here in the playing Hall at
the 2023 Champions chess tour final you
know what's at stake wrench alongside
James cany and Levy Rosman we are
getting set for what will be the final
Armageddon of this epic semi-final Day
called it you did call it you did I did
you also called it I think you guys all
called it yeah kind but all right are
you surprised about how we got here
right the tensions seem high neither
Player is taking too many risks in those
games but your thoughts about the two
games that actually got us to the
Armageddon I think they just need to
regain a little bit of energy I mean the
truth is there's a lot of games to be
played here and we got a hotel contract
we can't be here for you know 10 days so
it's a good reminder we got we got to
get out of here like we got you know we
we have a certain amount of time we're
here so the guys are a little bit tired
they regained some energy now it's
Armageddon time yep yeah they have some
extra time of course right as we're all
waiting for the games but I mean this as
David say six hours of play here right
really that stamina who's going to have
the right stamina especially in this
last game of the day I think that's a a
really good point because I think we all
talked about the big storyline of the
week when Hikaru went home because so
many fans wanted him to be here but one
thing we talk enough about is part of
the reason he didn't have it against
Notre Beck is I think he was just
exhausted that was a very long day of
eight hours of Chess this day is going
to be the second longest day that we've
had and I think that both of these
players have got to be checking
themselves before they have like wre or
wrecking themselves chess puns hopefully
not checkmating themselves wow we we
have been here for a while and uh we're
going to be here a little bit longer
because the players have Armageddon and
Ka caught up with them when they gave
their Armageddon bid and let's uh let's
find out the big reveal who's who's
playing what color everyone's just
smiling when they're coming in here uh I
am so curious to see these Arma get on
bids you guys go ahead and turn your
boards let's see
them same time same
time what you see nine
919 927 with a cat but 919 okay with the
black pieces what is this about um yeah
I don't know just I think doesn't matter
at this point just just choosing black
and hoping for best I saw you write
something and then you wiped it out what
was the first bid first bid was
906 so I just you know yeah all right
well Wesley how do you feel about the
result of the bid here we'll see mean
it's been a it's been a long day so
anything can happen hopefully not the
break Place
badly must win now with the white pieces
do you think the cat will bring you luck
yeah uh hopefully it worked before you
miss your cat at home no no I I was just
at home so it's good and after this
tournament I don't have anything for two
months so that's cool okay well you guys
awesome bids good luck in the final
armag get on here back to you
guys I I think did did Wesley draw his
cat or did he draw mittens that's
exactly what he drew it's mittens right
it look exactly the same it kind of
looks like mittens with like Wesley's
face actually though I we can zoom on
that W human face that's human that's
mittens right there that's the
indication of what the I don't mean to
kill the mood but this chess game is
worth 50 Grand it's worth
$50,000,000 American not Canadian
dollars that's a lot of money are you
surprised that nottock is playing Black
in this one I thought for sure Wesley
would would would be getting low enough
to get black but he bid so low 9 minutes
and 19 seconds is a risky bid Fabiano
said he would never get lower than 9
Minutes on a bid not worth it to risk he
taking the risk I mean he's like look
I've tooken out Nakamura I've made it
this far I'm playing strong chess I am a
world rapid Champion youngest ever to do
it right I'm I'm just going to take it
this is the last shot so I'm going in
with everything I got 919 listen I did
statistics in college I'm mostly just
fast that was just a quick flex but I
fascinated about the the data noted yes
because you know we we we're now
Gathering all of this data and
information of what's like a good bid
right what's a good bid so we don't know
919 is that enough of a Time deficit to
still have that second result I I don't
think we realized having two results in
your back pocket in a chess game that's
huge like like white has to win I wonder
how much of this psychology here was
putting Wesley in a must-win situation
because I think Wesley is more
comfortable with the draw odds right and
playing low on the clock your thoughts
on putting Wesley in that chair where he
has to go all out well he did he
actually did that with Magnus with that
Knight G5 he had to go all out and he
did it so he can do it but it's it's
about him defending and having that I
mean I'm taking black every time if I
can get that second I can draw or how
Magnus found the uh the Knight D2 to B3
draw six stuff if you could find that
draw you win the game it's 50 extra, too
50 extra, Grand how much that suit cost
50,000 was it um a lot okay might have
gotten the hook up you know say Jo
bananas
shout no but okay so Wesley has to go
for the win he did do it against Magnus
and maybe what has object arguably been
not objectively arguably maybe been the
game of the tournament so far yeah you
think Wesley can uh can bring the heat
here against Notre Beck I have been
saying this every time they put us on
this beautiful panel Wesley so was my
pick to advance to the final we have one
game left if I jump ship now then I am a
bozo say so I got to stick with my pick
I think your thoughts cols change your
thoughts on this not at all I'm still
going with flex Serrano but at the same
time I do like how not backck is
swinging I mean right we we called him
right the Magic Dragon but now he's he's
changed into morphed into something else
now he's a beast we've been debating his
hisame I will get back to
everybody snow leopard snow he's
everything he everything he's been
everything today and he is everything as
candy likes to say half man half
everything else as we can see there on
the graphic Magnus Carlson is still
waiting for whoever is going to join him
in the finals will it be Wesley so will
it be Notre beab duat turov that one
toone score in the set format we have
doesn't quite do justice to where we sit
here at past 6 p.m. on the East Coast
because they've played a lot more than
just two games ladies and gentlemen if
you're just tuning in Where Have You
Been we're rocking it's the 2023
Champions chess tour semi-finals and
we're going to have an Armageddon game
in just a second so all right guys well
Wesley uh Wesley is going to have to win
with white he did do it against Magnus
Carlson in their Armageddon game I will
say like you guys I'm still not going to
jump ship now I also picked Carls and
Wesley but I don't feel like Wesley
looked excited about what happened
because now we're talking about Notre
Beck playing Black look how low Wesley
bid he bid 927 that's also one of the
lowest bids we've had Levy you talked
about the stats we're going to have on
Armageddon over the years yeah I can't
wait to see when we look back and talk
about the meta that we've learned in
terms of what the real right strategy is
the players were discussing this earlier
maybe it was yesterday and I I hopefully
tomorrow we have a stat of all the
Armageddon maybe that's a good idea
shout out to the to the team here but I
think white was doing very well in this
event yeah white with the time Advantage
was doing a good job now Karo might have
messed that statup Karo didn't have his
best chest and he lost a few with black
but he had a few again there will be
outliers but 9 minutes and 19 seconds is
still plenty of time against a guy like
Wesley to play a solid game a e45 before
you know we're going to get a main line
unless plays B3 again I would love B3 I
would love to I would love B3 all right
well we would love B3 we know we're
going to get all the chess that we want
and I think uh Osa would love if we
threw it back across the sea Tanya
Robert David the band the team take it
away are you guys ready for Armageddon
we're so ready uh Danny it all comes
down to this one and I think we at least
in the studio were pretty sure that this
will go down to the wire especially
seeing the first few moves that game two
I was just surprised how long that game
two went but rest assured it was always
going to be armagedon yeah it's such a
big one with so much money on the line
so much glory on the line of playing for
the championship of a season long tour
David yeah this is uh one of the highest
stes games that these players will have
ever played especially Abdu satoro for
such a young career but he's already won
a World rapper Championship I do
actually think I was just pondering in
that last break maybe he was trying to
tire Wesley out that was the only reason
that last game went on so long long
maybe he's trying to ask a few questions
saying you're a bit older than me mate
I'm going to try and uh break you down
wear you down eventually but it all does
come down to this one yeah and we see
nck stamina has definitely not been a
problem for that chess kid now the
Armageddon bids nag starts with the
black pieces uh what do you make of that
because Wesley his bid also he was also
wanting black he went pretty low for the
black pieces well they both won the
Black pieces because nothing separated
them in that two mini match we saw two
draws the first game Wesley did have his
Chan with the white piece it was a
forcing variation so not back with that
20-minute break that he just had if he
looks at that line he probably doesn't
feel that afraid to get black withdraw
ODS what do you think is going on in
NC's mind winning that very critical bid
and getting black right now I think uh
actually it's a bit of an adjustment I
think maybe he's gone back to his hotel
room called up his friends called up his
seconds his coaches saying what should I
do against 1 B3 I think it's purely
about the technical aspect right now
because if he emerges with the uh from
the opening in good stead with enough
time he will be the favorite with those
result odds but um there's no guarantees
I think it's very very focused uh kind
of thought process now for nbec he left
really quickly from that uh playing
Arena as soon as he submitted his bids
we saw nbec was the first one to leave
in this kind of a situation do you think
it's a better idea to just take rest the
long day that you've had and be fresh or
are the players really looking at the
opening lines and their approach right
now considering what Wesley tried in
that first game of set three I do think
that nck would be well advised to
actually prepare because Wesley he show
that I will I'm willing to go down that
deep line you better know what you're
doing he made a chess course about it
after all so maybe watch a little bit of
his video that early night G5 do you
think he's going to try to get that or
will nybeck switch it up from uh the
Kings spawn opening it's really hard to
say nybeck in general likes to be a
moving Target he likes to duck dive dip
Dodge duck yeah all of that stuff he
loves to just avoid his opening his
opponent's preparation he loves to be
the one dictating the pace the nature of
the game so I wouldn't be surprised if
nck is actually the first to surprise
the opponent unless Wesley plays B3
again oh one B3 but that can't be too
much of a surprise for nck he has to be
ready for that to to me the approach of
1 V3 it feels more like a one game
opening uh rather than to reemployed and
there we've got the players they are
ready to start the action stay hydrated
it's been a long day of Chess they're
ready to go nbec with the black pieces
and let's remind everyone a draw would
mean that nbec takes the match goes into
the final eliminates Wesley Wesley with
the white pieces has to win to knock out
not a back up to satov this is such a
huge moment in the career of both of
these players but in particular notbe
abusar he's younger he has won a World
rapid Championship but wesle so with the
dominant force a year ago in Toronto
nordbeck wants to send him home yeah
absolutely and in just a few seconds we
will see their opening approach so
critical with no increment on the clock
which player gets the kind of middle
game that they want they enjoy playing
will Wesley get his solid approach or
will n back be able to create initiative
and Wesley surprises first with the
English opening the English opening it's
1 C4 and uh some quick moves here some
very quick moves from nbec as he builds
a strong Pawn center with black we see
pawns disappearing already in the middle
of the board
and a transposition to what we call the
tarash defense where black often accepts
an isolated porn but compensates with
dynamism really fast start to this game
by both players and for Wesley so he
doesn't mind having the white pieces he
beat Magnus Carlson with white in and
Armageddon but it's a very different
type of position than this here it's
going to be a struggle is that isolated
Queen Pawn that pawn on D5 is it a
weakness or is it something that black
can play around you have open files when
you have an ised Pawn the adjacent files
are free for the black Rooks to step on
those lines and stare in into the white
position and we when you're the one with
the isolated Queen Pawn what you have in
compensation is play is the activity
you're looking at not only taking
control of the open files as Robert
pointed out jumping forward with your
pieces the knight from F6 will land on
e4 at the at some moment for white it's
going to be all about doubling down on
that D5 Pawn one thing's for sure that
these middle games are going to be
dynamic with the asymmetrical Pawn
structure yep and uh Dynamic is not the
name of Black's last move Pawn to H6 I'm
really surprised by that one one thing I
will mention is that Wesley so is one of
the best players against an iqp that
I've seen in a long time uh when he
faces this isolated Queens Pawn Wesley
so he has a great track record uh often
just controlling squares outmaneuvering
the opponent both of White's Bishops now
are on the longest diagonals fan kod uh
will their x-ray vision come into effect
nbec having to play quickly tries to
break down White's quein side structure
I really like that move because you
couldn't let Wesley have all the fun
you're trying to carve out some squares
for your own pieces if you take on A5
then that means the A3 Pawn that becomes
a weakness long term and if you don't
take inste you push your Pawn forward
that hands black some critical dark
squares on the queen side namely C5 and
B6 so this is the right approach from
nybeck you don't give your opponent all
the space without countering but he has
burnt a minute both players have burnt
around uh around one minute right now
and Wesley the first long pause of this
game he just needs to decide how to fix
the structure how to decide the
structure clarify it on the queen side
and uh the key moments are still to come
still ahead but kg start now especially
with wesle so going into the tank he
needs to move he needs to keep his time
Advantage because Black's position is
still healthy for now that last move it
feels as if things are Brewing up in the
position kg so far but A5 that's the
first question in the position that
Wesley needs to answer what does he do
with the B Pawn it's attacked not only
by the pawn but the bishop on E7 as well
do you defend it keeping the tension do
you push it giving away some key squ is
in the position I think Pawn takes Pawn
would be the last option on my on my
radar here giving a solid weakness on A3
is not what solid Wesley will ever do I
would want to push the pawn to keep the
game going and exactly not to force off
a series of Trades but look at how
quickly and confidently nck is
responding to Wesley's moves he
understands the plans very well he may
have made a quiet H6 move but he's just
developing the rest of his pieces now
that Knight can hop on out to a square
like B6 and there it goes it's defending
the iqp the light score Bishop is free
and watch out for the light squares on
White's Queen side that Knight could hop
into C4 and suddenly it could be trouble
for Wesley yeah potentially missed this
last move by Wesley so because he's
allowing Black's Knight to hop in and
suddenly trouble White's Dart Square
Bishop is a big big Target I think he's
actually arranged his pieces
suboptimally here Wesley so and you can
tell the usage of the clock right now NC
has spent one minute pretty much 1
minute since he started this game Wesley
has spent almost 3 minutes so the uh
clock times are are starting to get
closer together nothing wrong has
happened here at all for nbec so I think
he wins the opening battle and uh he
should be feeling the more confident of
the two already a kind of position where
black is the one who's pushing for the
initiative and once again it's white who
has to win on demand black needs only a
draw a night trade offered I don't
expect nbec to trade and ease off the
pressure I like the idea of the KN
jumping forward to C4 to put pressure on
that Bishop on B2 also that A3 Pawn on
White's Queen inside is a weak Target he
reaches out it does arrive on the board
it looks like Wesley's pieces are
lacking coordination right now it looks
really not fun for Wesley look at that
Knight on A4 it's on the rim it offered
a trade trade was refused that Knight on
C4 hits the bishop on B2 and if that
Bishop moves forward on that dark Square
diagonal that A3 Pawn is in the sights
of Black's pieces namely that Knight
that just hopped in C4 and the bishop on
E7 I'm not liking this at all for Wesley
it's a must-win game he's the one who
burning clock and nybeck he's just
making very natural developing moves
that have a clear purpose yeah black
still has the isolated Queen's Pawn but
we're forgetting about that factor
because it's not relevant right now
Black's isolated Pawn if anything just
covers some key squares and helps the
black pieces and pawn Sacrifice from
Wesley so he is saying take me take that
white A3 Pawn he's trying to uh at least
activate the white pieces and I think a
good decision in an Armageddon game but
objectively can black take the pawn that
is the big question nobec for the first
time in this game is pausing stopping he
is tempted is greed good here and that's
the question black could just ignore
things develop bring out the black light
Square Bishop to a uh any Square pretty
much uh but key moment the first
critical moment of this game big
questions to nck and he has to decide on
the board he mentioned in his interview
calculation is what he lik to do but he
has to do it quick and he does decide to
not go into the complications with
White's Knight jumping on to B6
potential cap capture on F6 if you think
about going on the left side of the
board NC wants none of that he wants to
develop his pieces keep the activity
going rather than getting greedy I
didn't love his move he developed his
light score Bishop but it was attacking
a pawn that was easy to defend I would
have preferred bring that light scored
Bishop out a little further maybe to a
score like F5 but I think that pawn on
A3 it was capturable not by the Knight
because that would have handed white the
B6 square and that looks very ugly as
black is super cramped and white is
definitely going to win back some
material but he could take him with the
bishop but that's neither here nor there
at this stage of the game he probably
didn't like how discombobulated his
pieces look instead he's playing with
that I said Queen pawn it protects both
knights in the center he's using it as a
lever yeah and look at these two black
knights they are beautiful pieces they
are glorious pieces but actually what
are they attacking they're not creating
any threats right now black will try to
activate the Rooks but actually it's uh
just hard to see what next so nbec he's
going for stability then again he has
moved this bishop twice it's kind of
done a a shimmy step here to D7 and then
to E6 I think Wesley should be feeling
positive about this change in
developments suddenly rather than being
down a pawn with white he has a very
playable position yes he has given the
opponent squares especially the Black
Knights but white has squares two these
Knights compensated for by this Rock
Solid Bishop this powerful Bishop in the
middle of the board looking at both
flanks and uh I think this one still in
the balance and the clock could play a
key factor nck interesting maybe a bit
of indecision there it was so tempting
to grab a PA Wesley trying to shut
things down or at least trade off one of
uh one of the sets of knights uh
interesting move there a retreat I like
it because he's getting rid of his own
Knight on the edge for a knight that's
extremely active so definitely a trade
that will favor white also if it's done
on Wesley's term a knight takes KN the
queen does fall back recapturing and
then there'll be suddenly attacks along
the diagonal with the queen and the
bishop lining up so wondering if nbec
Will decide to just keep the tension on
the board keep that Knight on C4 let
Wesley trade it sort out your problems
of the isolated Queen Pawn that way a
lesson we learn when playing with the
isolated Queen Pawn we typically do not
want end games the fewer pieces that
remain the harder it is for the side
with the isolated Queen Pawn because we
want to be active around that pawn so I
would not be taking on B2 if we're going
to trade black should trade on his terms
maybe Rook C8 that way his Rook can join
the party on the C4 square but nck he's
down under 6 minutes so we're looking at
the move 18 42 moves before you get that
1 second bonus time these are not easy
decisions for him to make I also
wouldn't be surprised if he drops his
Knight back to D6 because that Knight on
B2 it's not the best piece in the world
and that Knight on D6 can reroute to the
F5 square and they keep posing some
important questions in the center he
does drop back as you recommend Robert
but uh the move itself is secondary that
was a long think one and a half minutes
on the clock in Armageddon as black
that's a huge chunk a huge proportion of
your time and yeah that might come back
to haunt him it will get fast and
furious sooner rather than later so I'm
wondering whether uh that time was
better spent just choosing a move
trusting his Instinct it feels like he's
not quite in the flow yet neither player
actually uh kind of unleashing this
quick flurry of moves trusting uh their
instincts but okay it was a good
decision in the end keeping pieces on
the board it's just same move faster
would have been uh better of course but
Wesley so now up to him he would love to
just push the white a pawn one square
forward solidify the queen side not um
kind of beat too loose over that flank
anymore but maybe he thinks there are
more urgent priorities in the position
one of the priorities that I see for
black would be to try and get rid of
that dark Square Bishop that Bishop on
D4 to me looks uh like such a strong
piece taking away so many key squares
and uh he does it I was thinking about
the bishop move to F6 but nbec finds
another way he reroutes that knight from
C4 to attack that Bishop on F4 Knight
jumps over to F5 none of pieces have
been traded off there's so much tension
along the D line as well it's those
positions where it's really Brewing up
to explode and with 5 and a half minutes
on the clock things are going to get
very tricky for nauy back I do like
Wesley's last move though he's giving up
his dark score Bishop which looked at
the pride and joy of his position but a
knight that was on the rim on A4 it's
wheeled right back around to D3 that can
jump to F4 putting pressure on the light
squore bishop and that isolated Queen
Pawn so look at ner Beck he's not taking
that Bishop there's no real Rush yes the
bishop can slide back but that doesn't
solve all of White's problems so both
players are handling this position
extremely well yeah really classy games
so far from both they've navigated those
critical moments those tricky decisions
really really well but now Black's Rook
occupies this powerful open Line uh the
SE file right now is ripe there's plenty
of squares for the for for The Rook to
jump into so it does feel like Wesley
should Challenge fight for the open
lines maybe he's just afraid of these
exchanges knowing he needs to win at all
costs with white but uh it feels like
the moment to be objective just
challenge there we go he activates his
rook and uh how will black continue the
momentum maybe it's time for the black
queen to move when do you trade off that
Bishop in the center big question still
and Wesley he made the move Rook to C1
and with a shake of his head every piece
trade makes his task a little more
difficult to try and create those
chances that he needs with the white
pieces in the Armageddon a must a must-
win game for Wesley so Rook C1 play but
I'm getting worried for nck he's
spending so much time on the clock now
he's under 5 minutes and there's still a
long way to go before the position
clarifies he's a Speed Demon but he is
getting quite low on the clock
especially that considering he has 39
moves to make to get that extra time he
goes Queen D6 talking about trades Queen
A3 that's a pretty clever idea to get
those Queens off the board and without
Queens maybe just maybe not back's
feeling comfortable and that he can play
the next moves quite quickly really
really nice move but that one was a slow
one I think you're right Robert he at
least has a click up plan now and that's
the main thing in Armageddon no matter
how bad your position is no matter how
bad your plan is as long as you're
consistent and you have an idea in mind
it allows you to play quite quickly
allows you to get a flurry of moves in
and um I know that these days a lot of
younger players very rarely play without
increment but this is where the speed
really is necessary and I'm shocked I
thought the black queen was coming in
trade off the Queens but no nbec wants
to peer down at the white king the black
queen is on the same diagonal as White's
King making Wesley feel slightly
uncomfortable here um actually the more
I look at it the more I like this move
really ambitious from NC not only making
him feel uncomfortable on the king side
but Queen on the queen side as well
because there is a threat of the D Pawn
moving forward to D4 and x-raying that
Queen with that Bishop on E6 and if that
pawn was to move forward suddenly from
becoming a weakness it starts becoming a
strength in Black's position and that
Knight on F5 is actually such a heroic
piece because not only did it kick that
Bishop out of the center it protects the
G7 Pawn so if white does Slide the queen
back to B2 and that's played right now
it doesn't carry a threat so I think
that trade is the name of the game
Bishop D6 let's trade off those dark
Square Bishops and black does have a
firm command over the queen side and the
King side does feel well defended as
well look at Wesley on the camera he's
getting ready he's flexing he's uh just
trying to get in the optimal position
for the imminent time scramble it's 7
Minutes against 4 minutes essentially
still a three-minute Time Advantage half
what it was at the beginning of the game
but enough to cause uh some Delight for
Wesley so I think he's going to start
hustling on the clock you can see on his
body language he's itching to make moves
and nbec is still freezing it's been
three or four of these moments where he
spent 30 seconds 1 minute one and a half
minutes you don't have that luxury in
Armageddon chess whatever your move
trade off the dark Square Bishops like
Robert says push pawns trade off Rooks
whatever you got to move quickly the
more pieces on the board the more
calculation based the position becomes
and with seconds on the clock you have
to rely on intuition you have to play
faster instinctively but right now if
nbe keeps continuing to keep these many
minor pieces on the board that's going
to be a tough task Bishop to D6 trade
off that monstrous Bishop on E5 he keeps
thinking and now he's touching the three
minute mark he must be getting nervous
right now because there's so many
options he does go for a bishop trade
the Eva bar actually slightly goes up in
White's favor I like the decision I
don't like the time it took to get there
so for Wesley he now has just under
seven minutes he's well ahead in the
clock here's a moment where he has
several different options just don't
blunder your F2 Pawn because the most
tempting move in the position for white
is going knight from D3 out to F4 but
that will drop your F2 Pawn so just be
careful if you're Wesley no game- ending
blunders yeah maybe trade-off Bishops
first and then that move Robert uh it
looks like Wesley has to part with his
Dart Square Bishop that beautiful Bishop
of whites in the center of the board but
he can do some dancing with his Knights
and the nerves are definitely kicking in
Wesley occasionally he looking off at
the clock already this early in the game
it's only move 23 he does trade off the
Bishops and now the white Knights do
they start rolling do they start
entering the center Knight to F4 looks
beautiful putting pressure on uh that
black isolated Pawn reminding abdor that
he took on the isolated Queen PA PA no
he drops back a bit of a
counterintuitive move retreating when it
wasn't necessary he wants to stop
Black's Knight getting back into the
center where it previously stood strong
yeah and that kind of really throws the
ball on nbe's scod because Knight E4
would have been an obvious move but
suddenly he has to slow down now he puts
his own Knight there's a big threat on
the board uh he has to take care of this
Knight takes Pawn coming in with a fork
you see how NC just leaned forward when
he was making this move Knight to D4 so
looking for that piece activity it's
super complicated because white can
bring his own Knight to F4 which defends
the E2 Pawn but then you need to
calculate the moves like G5 so things
are getting spicy Wes he calculates
things quickly or he just wanted to play
for NY Beck's time tra nbe's about to go
under three minutes G5 is incredibly
tempting but it likely does not work
yeah white can just Counterattack I
think here against the Black Knight and
yes pawns pieces will get traded but the
black king would become open so this
didn't happen Bishop to G4 instead
there's pressure there's threats on
Wesley so this Pawn is attacked twice
now not be is trying to save time on the
clock Force his opponent to waste time
on the clock by going on the offensive
uh this is a good strategy in general
when the clocks are low attack it's much
easier quicker instinctive to attack
than defend and look at this contorting
himself wo drops his KN back clearing
the second rank the White Queen now
defending that row but yeah it looks a
bit odd suddenly Wesley forced backwards
when you need to win you often want to
avoid trades but I think Wesley's going
a little bit too far out of his way to
avoid the trades he's going backwards
but so is not's clock I mean it's
ticking down here this is a problem for
black you're not even at move 30 yet and
you don't get that one second at a time
per move until you get move 60 so Tanya
I'm starting to like wesy chances 100% I
mean it's the clock in the position as
well there's this long-term weakness
that you have with the isolated Queen's
Pawn Wes is going to play this out till
the very end uh and you can fight
against it it'll always give white an
edge unless black is able to create
proper attack on that F2 Square Knight
E4 is the move that you really want to
make in this position but white is just
in time to block this diagonal with the
move E3 but Tanya look at the clock 30
seconds only got 2 minutes left this is
too slow and he's been so fast
throughout the tour final and then
suddenly in this Armageddon with $50,000
on the line a final spot on the line n
back he needs to make a move wow he has
spent nearly 50 seconds on this turn he
is less than 1 minute 45 remaining is he
forgetting that there's no increment
because he hasn't played again all day
today they played six games of Rapid
chess with 3 seconds bonus time per move
but he is just stalled he's
Frozen physically incapable of making a
move right now what is he doing why is
he fiddling with pieces you've got one
and a bit minutes 28 moves only we're
still miles away from the increment
stage he plays Rook to d8 a passive
defensive move holding together black
isolated queen porn but he needed to be
consistent attack go on the front foot
when you're down on time
and now he's retreating this is great
news for Wesley so terrible news for
Abdu satov 1 minute 20 the key moments
are still ahead there's still so many
pieces on the board and Wesley just
makes the most natural moves now it's
easier for him to play there is no
attack on the E2 Pawn on the F2 pawn and
Wesley is going for that isolated
Queen's Pawn trade on offer Wesley takes
the pawn the thing is for nck the moves
are going to get easier because a bunch
of Trades are happening but you're now
just down material so unfortunately for
nck he froze he might be panicking
internally and now Wesley clearly has
the upper hand simple porn up for white
no deficiencies to the white position
just convert that extra Pawn he'll also
be left with a bishop versus a knight
with pawns on both flanks he's going to
reach for his Bishop he captures watch
out for the black king vulnerable to
some checks on the light squares nock's
position and Clark situation both
collapsing simultaneously he drops his
Knight back attacking the bishop holding
on good move but uh look at that he's
panicking now he looked over at the
clock realizing only one minute oh my
God nck down to a minute no increment
down upon he needs a miracle to save
this one he rushes with the Rook trade
and it's going to be all about combining
the efforts of a queen and a knight
which can be quite dangerous and tricky
against a queen and a bishop and Wesley
you know this Rook on D1 that was just
captured he moves his Bishop back out to
B3 he needs to pile pressure on some of
Black's vulnerable pwns so for Wesley
right now plenty of time on his clock
for not back he's down under a minute
he's down under a minute and uh okay
ignore the board he did capture that
black Rook at the bottom on D1 it's now
Queen and Bishop versus queen and Knight
white is just a porn up so let's ignore
that small board for now let's focus on
the players and it's all about whether
nbec can hold on it's not going to be
easy longterm but he's got the move
counter there look at the tablet move 37
he needs to make 23 moves in just under
one minut his chair is shaking like you
could see how nervous he is right now
because he does not have time to
calculate he just put his G Pawn forward
so he's down a pawn he tries trying to
make space for his King W doesn't
immediately have threats that's the one
bit of good news from Noir back to be
precise he's got 48 seconds on the clock
with no increment to be made the good
news for nbec is that he's got the queen
of Knight but how does the Knight find
itself find a good post into Wesley's
Camp right now I don't see a clear part
and what an angle we see visibly nervous
now shaking he's trying to get the
adrenaline pumping I think he's just
trying to set up a fortress erect that
fortress on the dark squares white only
has a light squared Bishop so if you
hold the opposite color complex you
might be able to fend off the attack and
uh okay we see a check a quick
repetition of the position Wesley cannot
draw he cannot repeat a third
time of course he doesn't but that gives
extra moves to nybeck that was very
helpful for nybeck and the bad thing for
Wesley is he doesn't have an eval bar at
his disposal he doesn't know that he is
objectively winning if the Queens come
off the board can the Knight establish a
dark Square blockade that's the big
question he's also dropped to second
Pawn can Wesley grab he does take on B6
and now that's just one check it was
only one check the white King's safe if
the Queens come off now it is dead white
is simply winning due to the two extra
pawns especially the protected pass Pawn
on B5 he can centralize now I think this
is going to kill the counterplay Abdu
satoro is on the brink of elimination
and Wesley he did the right thing he
gives a check to centralize his Queen he
can bring his Queen back to help Shield
his King which is vulnerable in the
second row but he can even bring his
Queen back to its starting square and he
could trade piece any time but this is
even nicer going in for the kill going
in for the kill look at the light
squares the Queen the bishop lined up a
battery on the diagonal white is
threatening Queen to F7 check next to
the black king that would be lights out
Black's Queen forced to defend for nck
he's got no time as well and lost on the
board these are the final few seconds of
nck in the Champions Chester finals and
the queen can take this Knight a new
Queen will appear and I think that
will nck knows it he resigns wesle so is
in the
finals what a game between these two and
you have to feel for the youngster and
look at Wesley he finally can catch his
breath he's been exhausted he's played
for over 6 hours today but he makes it
through tomorrow Wesley so Rises to the
occasion takes it in the Armageddon in
style with the white pieces and not be
Abdus satra what a journey it's been and
it is heartbreak for the young usbig
Phenom wow such close action notc he
just froze at the critical moments it
was the mammoth occasion it was the
money on the line it was the thought of
facing Magnus Carson tomorrow it all got
to him and ultimately Wesley was just
too composed too calm and that's calm is
the name of the game when it comes to
Armageddon and Wesley is the one who
showed nerves of Steel in that one
playing quickly playing keeping his
options open in that position keeping
the tension going and I think this
armagedon it just felt like n back
ention got the better of him W did the
right thing he was avoiding trades early
on no easy simplifications for nbec
abatar and nbec had $50,000 on the line
in a single game where he needed a draw
to move on so much pressure for a
19-year-old and credit to him he's been
an amazing event he is done here at the
Champions chess T finals but everyone
should give him a round of applause
because he gave it his all he is a
Phenom yeah he really did so much to
learn from nck about how you need to
work and play with sheer determination
to make dreams come true but his dream
comes to a stop in the semi-finals and
it is Wesley so who will be fighting
against Magnus Carlson and what a day of
stress it has been for Wesley and it all
came down to those critical moments in
this Armageddon where did it turn around
David yeah what a day it's full of
roller coasters in this semi-final
between Wesley so and aboro it had
already gone wrong by this point but I
wanted to highlight the fact that the
clock played the the biggest factor in
this Armageddon here Abdu satov with the
black pieces it has gone a bit wrong
he's down a porn white here having the
extra ewn however black does have Queen
and Knight a famously strong Duo and
black has set up a bit of a fortress on
the dark squares with more time Abdu
satoro might have found an idea such as
Pawn to G4 locking things down creating
the threat of some counterplay and it
would have been really tough for white
to break through and win this game later
unfortunately though with only around 20
30 seconds left he blundered a second
point Queen to E5 let loose the B6 Pawn
this was snapped up by Wesley so and yes
it was a check hitting the white king
but it was only one check Wesley had
much more time than his opponent and was
able to calmly find this block and then
this queen Retreat and the killer blow
Queen to C4 coming in with the White
Queen Wesley simply too fast and earlier
on Wesley he could have initiated a
series of Trades but the game review
gives it a question mark but maybe it
was a great decision because it put the
onus on nck to find Clarity in the
position he wasn't able to do it at
least not in time and for Wesley so he
did earn his championship bid he moves
on to the finals to face Magnus Carlson
he played a great game that was a great
and to that Armageddon Wesley at the
early at the start of the day said that
he's a fan of Napoleon and he played
like a true leader today and like a boss
winning that set to and then taking it
in this final Armageddon where NC never
really got a
chance yeah it's as simple as that nbec
his only chance was to keep Pace on the
clock but ultimately yeah too many
freezes too many freezing moments yeah
and it was those moments that define a
player and Wesley was just the better
one in that Armageddon and we are headed
towards Wesley so Magnus Carlson final
and for more on that action we are going
to head over to our gang in Toronto who
is with the man of the moment Wesley
take it away
guys thanks Tanya David and Robert great
call on that action Wesley great chess
on that action you did it yeah thank you
guys guys all pick me
yeah I have a lot of friends who are
rooting for me here and online so really
great really great stuff you have a lot
of friends you got a lot of fans a lot
of people look at Wesley so in Toronto
and say is that the best rapid player in
the world what go what's going on with W
with Wesley so when he's in Toronto uh
yeah well first of all
uh all thanks to Jesus Christ for giving
me the victory today uh it's only
through his will I was really running
out of steam like in the end I didn't
even care you know I just want to play
make use of my chances but we were
really running on fumes it's been a
brutal slugging match it's been really
long really tough at the end of the day
it was about who had more energy who had
stamina left and uh I think I was kind
of figuring no de back I mean first of
all a big congratulations and shout out
to him he's an amazing player he played
really really well in in this match uh
but in the end I thought I was kind of
figuring him out in the end like getting
positions that are better better suited
to my style than his so like uh I think
I lost almost three games with one e
four is it three or two with what with
white yeah so at the end of the day I
had just had to stop playing one E4
against him it wasn't working yeah so
that's why staring new openings like
B3 B3 baby you got B3 too didn't you the
problem with B3 is that I think it works
very well against one E5 like if black
applies E5 because he get the Target and
stuff uh but if black plays like D5 and
the normal stuff and then the Bop is Li
squared Bishop then he gets a good
position that's why I was hesitant to
play B3 once again because not the Breck
goes up to his room after pretty much
every other game too yeah prepare I
assume so yeah I didn't have the courage
to play it again although I would love
to maybe against Magnus yeah maybe I
played beer against Magnus in the
speeches Championship didn't work out
well but maybe tomorrow it would okay
but it's it's nice I mean it's I didn't
expect to still be I mean I'm very happy
to reach a semis but I was going to say
what did you expect for today because
you lost yet you lost yesterday right
and you came today we we we kind of we
kind of scripted our our day take you
through behind the scenes we kind of we
do our pregame run a show rehearsal and
we're looking at the day I'm like well
if Wesley if Wesley's playing in the
finals that means we're going to be here
all day because we're going to go it's
going to take an all the way comeback in
order for that to happen and you did it
yeah I think uh I think everything
played well in this tournament right
from the very first day right since
Hikaru didn't accept a draw against me
like everything had to go my way because
if I finish second even then Magnus
would pick another back for sure and
then I'd face a a tough opponent with
Fabiano and I think Fabiano has a huge
favorite Against Me based on style wise
so everything had to go my way for me to
reach the the finals uh also I realized
today that I did I didn't tweet
yesterday before my match and then it
ended really badly so I was like tter
you know what let me thr Anish again if
it works and it worked well giri under
the bus on Twitter makes everyone play
better chess it's just
science just uh just having fun my main
idea really was to you know I like I had
no intentions to start anything on
social media like I'm our family is very
reserved very quiet like we live in
Minnesota yeah but my idea was just to
troll Anish and watch the games uh
online and then one thing led to another
but I'm hoping I'm I'm hoping I qualify
to a candidat and I'll be back in
Toronto my lucky City okay very very
long day of chess for you of course
where do you get yeah very brutal where
do you get more of the stamina from
especially needing it in this last match
here where cuz it seems like you're you
know you just High Spirit feeling good
like you yeah feels like looks like you
you haven't you know you just woke up
like you look fresh so what where does
that come from not really no I was
really feel fresh doesn't feel fresh did
I do I really look like wow I was like I
think at the end of the day both not be
and I were running on our last energy
reserves like I think the reason why
Magnus is so good is because he's very
fit compared to many other chess players
but you know not me but hopefully I can
put up a good fight um I could ask the
same thing about you guys you guys have
been here since like 12 what we're doing
may not be quite as hard as what you're
doing um although I appreciate that
thank you um but uh yeah it is a long
day and you did it you pulled through
yeah for sure and there was it's crazy
like there was I was thinking in the
Armageddon game there was a huge amount
at stake like 51,000 so I mean it's
crazy that that uh so much at stake at a
single
armag playing a $50,000 chess game
$50,000 is it 51 cuz 51,000 I thought if
you win a match you get bonus 1,000 he
count all every
dollar ask me I'm the details anymore
don't put me on the spot on that you
don't read the contct also of course I
do but I you know I hate to have to lose
today because that means I probably have
to change my ticket and all that and I I
hate doing that that's why you can stay
through the closing anyway right if
Fabiana joining for tomorrow yeah he
probably will probably will Fab's got no
place else to go who are we kidding he
going to stay here Fab's home is where
chess is you like any video games huh
you like any video games uh guys have
been playing uh Clash Royale all day
against each other so really I I like I
played I play like Counter
Strike all
thata like during the pmic of playing
Counter Strike you know I thought I
thought I would never play over theboard
Chef again during 2020 s like killing
dime but hey yeah life goes on but
uh um last week won a Nintendo switch so
it'll be very
interesting yeah what games he used but
also I'd like to thank take the
opportunity to thank our sponsors and uh
you know there's huge money at stake
here and I personally don't really play
chess for money but I really appreciate
that fact wait we have sponsor I thought
that was all just out of Danny's I
thought Danny was just
writing you don't have to ask the
players to take the sponsors Wesley just
did it thank you very much and of course
yeah I also thank you to all the people
who are rooting for me both here and on
on the and online I think that's one of
the main reasons why I played so well in
Toronto last year and also this year and
also shout out to Michael brancato
because before tourament he said he
wished that the dream finals would be
Magnus and me and I was like what I
would reach a
semi I mean you you're from small little
place in uh in in Minnesota which I
think is is kind of how they I always
seen that meeme like one day in
Minnesota 5 days in Minnesota and then
you just turn more and more into a
Minnesotan does the local community
there like know who you are like around
your neighbors do they root for you do
they talk to you do they know theyve got
a a beast chess player around well I
think I'm the only Grandmaster in the
entire state of Minnesota for now for
now for now until you make a chess
Academy and then you know and a good
idea Al Le gets her Grandmaster title
yeah she live St Paul but uh yeah I
think the we moved in this new place
four and a half years ago and then
there's annual neighbor meetings and
they figure out that I was a chess
player so they're like last year they
were asking during the party they were
like oh who hand deman who hand
deman that's all they ever talk about
but I mean I think chess in Minnesota is
growing slowly but surely like it's
being included in high school and also
in acade in uh what do you call that
after after academics yeah so it's like
one time I like some sometimes people
recognize me in a store I like hey most
aren't you the chess player and they
like they be Googling me looking my but
it's not it's not like the attention
that you get in St Louis Missi and then
they ask you if you've ever played Hans
even is that what they ask you they say
have you ever played Hans even I Crush
that all right Wesley you know I will oh
sorry I was going to what was say uh
Minnesota gonna
say uh
you're tired yeah yeah conf I'm I'm
gonna give you one last question because
I think setting up what Michael brancato
said his dream final would be was
probably based on the fact that we've
got the Champions chess tour defending
champion in Magnus Carlson you have the
chess.com Global Champion that's you
that's right if you missed the memo
right so you versus Magnus is a true
kind of marriage of what was previously
two separate online tours now with one
with one you know one ring to rule them
all right one ring to bind them so let
me tell you this let me ask you like how
does the best Wesley so show up tomorrow
the Wesley so that believes he can beat
Magnus Carlson in a match well you got
you got to cheer me up then you gotta
pump me up like I'm asking you want to
go you want to cat your date tonight you
want to catch your date coupon tonight
maybe Magnus I can switch to CH
960 I'll be cool with that but I have I
mean overall I had like a horrible
lifetime performance against
Magnus uh but
uh yeah I I'll I'll give my best Magnus
if you're listening maybe take it easy
on me tomorrow give us a match well I'm
I'm sure you'll bring your best and I'm
sure that we're going to have a match I
I really hope so a lot a lot of people
believe in you a lot of fans a lot of
people think this is going to be a
thriller and there's a reason why a lot
of people wanted to see this so yeah
don't forget our date I'm not going to
forget our date you've got the coupon I
could never forget um All Right Wesley
we are going to let you go let you get
some rest enjoy your night you've got
you've got two more big days of Chess
ahead your job isn't done we wish you
the best of luck against Magnus Carlson
yeah yeah for sure I'm just very happy
to be in the finals
but yeah I really hope it'll be a match
tomorrow all right Wesley good luck budy
thanks for being with us well there we
have it that was our guy that is our guy
Wesley so who punched his ticket and now
we know who's going to play
the Carlson and Wesley so will throw
down in the title match it starts
tomorrow it's Friday and uh wow you know
it's Friday Friday we're gonna play on
Friday but before we sing or do whatever
else we're going to do to get out of
here I'm going to let everyone catch up
with Kaa who caught up with Notre Beck
after that tough
match us an incredible fight but it ends
here so how are you right now
nck yeah I'm bit of disappointed CU When
I
played today you know um I I played it's
you know very badly but um you know also
Wesley you know shout out to him he
played very very well after you know
yesterday's tough tough loss but yeah um
yeah it sometimes happens you know I had
every chance to win this this match but
um yeah that's that's what it is and you
went all the way onto that final armagon
it was crazy to watch you were shaking
we could see your feet shaking can you
take us through the emotions in the end
yeah no I got decent position out of
opening you know I I I like the tourish
structures um I I've played many games
there you know I I've got very very good
position but then you know I I somehow
you know start to to S and you know
played
passively um so yeah that's you know
that's why I I was you know I was
punished by by Wesley um but um
yeah you know generally I you know today
was not my day so uh I just I have to um
I have to come back stronger and we
definitely think you will but uh what
has been the highlight for you the fact
that you've been here one of the
youngest players fighting it out and
making it all the way to the semi-finals
no it's been a great event um you know
first of all big big thanks to to ch.com
for hosting this great event you know
giving opportunity for
me um yeah it's been a wonderful event
for me you know my highlight was of
course yesterday uh when I you know I
won the I won the match very
convincingly um even when I lose the
first game I I wasn't disappointed
because you know I was outplaying
him there yeah um but today you know
something went wrong and um he he was
clearly better than me well order back
we know you went through a lot to get
here staying in Berlin for8 days you
given us incredible entertainment thank
you also for sharing your thoughts here
in the mix Zone and we wish you best of
luck in the nearest future thank you
thank you let nordc Abdu satoro a great
guy who is uh knocked out of the CCT
finals but what a what a performance
he's given us back to you
guys wow after being excited here in the
studio with Wesley it's hard not to now
just go quickly to the other side and
feel heartbroken for Notre back Ley your
thoughts on on just the emotion how much
he clearly wanted this yeah listen um
losing one chess game is tough losing a
chess match uh is especially one that
you felt like you could have won is even
tougher and when you add on top of that
that uh it was potentially 50 to
$150,000 not to mention a match with
Magnus uh I can't imagine like I I I
really I truly can't imagine it's it's
really heartwarming uh and special to
that the players here are giving these
uh solemn and open interviews to all of
us because uh historically chess players
do not give interviews when they lose
they run off somewhere and they are not
seen until the next day of action so uh
really nothing but respect to these guys
for being a part of this and you have
nothing uh I mean you just look forward
to their next event which for noer just
so happens to be in his home country the
world rapid and Blitz Championship so
the guy looking forward to his next uh
set of tournaments same here I'm looking
forward to the next set of tournaments I
mean you got a feel for him is 50k match
that's a lot of money there but he also
made 50k he also played against some of
the strongest players the strongest
players in the world so it's nice
practice for him as he goes into the
next rid tournament this to do his thing
I mean we saw Dennis lose one title
Tuesday right you know so we see Notre
backck lose here maybe he'll win World
rappid Championship we don't know but at
the same time there good confidence for
him at the end of the day so got to feel
for him it is 50k I think for Notre Beck
uh like like many others it's not even
necessarily about the money you you know
that he's now at the place where he
doesn't want to hear things coming out
of commentator's mouths anymore like
well next time or practice or he's young
he'll get there he's tired of that you
can see that he wants it you can see how
much he cared about this and I think for
the fans and everyone watching it really
helps you appreciate that this has been
a yearlong ordeal to get here right this
this tour has had a lot going on for
these guys with so much at stake so
great to see the emotion we do
appreciate him um giving the interview
and we know it's it's obviously not not
ending the way that he story lined it
for himself but best of luck to Notre
Beck uh in his next event and best of
luck to all of you fans whatever you're
going to do tonight uh be safe and uh
and uh maybe get some rest because we
still have a couple of days of Chess
ahead so for everyone here the crew KY
Levy in Toronto of course everyone
across the pond as well doing everything
that they're doing to bring this to us
remember we have two more days of Chess
it's the championship chess tour finals
the title match between Magnus Carlson
and Wesley so it's here tomorrow don't
be anywhere else and we will see you
[Music]
then he just crushed nybeck never gave
him a chance Fabby he makes the wrong KN
jump but he slowed down and now the
queen comes to G5 Wesley strikes again
with the black pieces and that is a 2
to0 win for Wesley so Wesley keeping
things alive with a nasty move what a
sick move what a fantastic game I've
never seen anything like that Fabiano
Carana is eliminated Magnus Carlson
stamps his ticket to the finals we are
getting set for what will be the final
Armageddon of this epic semifinal day
nck knows it he resigns wesle so is into
the
finals
[Music]
e
oh